open the hearing on house bill
on that'll be helpful
there we go
get it down to my level
um
so
okay
thank you mr chair so for the record i'm
jerry conner carroll county three
and uh
this is i think all you know i've done a
lot of work in healthcare this is my
transition from healthcare to death care
just for fun so any case um
with as with many bills there is a
backstory to hb 1320.
i'm currently serving as a mentor for
anya nickel she's a constituent
and a girl scout working on a gold award
and she's here to testify today
she's taken on the task of advocating
for natural or green burials
burial is when you are buried without
being embalmed
using a simple casket or shroud and
without a concrete vault or maybe just
some portions of those changes
natural burial and avoids the
environmental degradation due to
leaching of embalming chemicals
into the environment and it consumes far
fewer resources and less energy
than current traditional burial or
cremation
and is much less expensive than either
of those as well
natural burial is not prohibited by
state law but many cemeteries do not
allow it
due to custom and their own regulations
so therefore ms nichols work is going to
be two pronged effort that i'm working
with her on involving advocacy with
local cemetery trustees
to law natural burial and addressing
embalming legislatively
now it's actually kind of odd to call
burial of an embalmed body in a large
casket in a cement vault a traditional
burial
because traditional burial for millennia
and still now in many parts of the world
is what we would call a natural burial
embalming became much more common in the
mid 19th century to allow viewing of the
dead body over a short number of days
and embalmers do a fantastic job if that
is desired
but embalming is not done in most of the
world and is forbidden in judaism and
islam
now we only have one embalming statute
at least that i've been able to find rsa
tb2540a which states
quote
no dead human body shall be exposed to
the public for a period
in excess of 24 hours
unless said body is properly embalmed
end quote
now that's can be kind of prone to
misinterpretation both by funeral
professionals and the lay people
suggesting that embalming is required
when it is not
the current statute dates from 1971 is
really probably not needed
and we're the only state that has this
kind of unnecessary misleading law
in addition
embalming is not really necessary
from a public health point of view
and sometimes it's actually even
contraindicated for example embalming a
person who died from hiv or tuberculosis
particularly done soon after death not a
long time
potentially exposes to disease
the embalmer who's entering body cavity
is handling blood and tissues
those viewing the body are not at risk
and respiratory diseases are
not very likely to be transmitted from a
dead body
because they don't breathe a whole lot
so they don't generate very many
droplets or aerosols
refrigeration is an option that can take
the place of embalming
if preservation is needed due to a delay
in viewing or burial
now the bottom line is that hp 1320 is
very straightforward it just repeals the
statute
it does not prohibit
embalming
embalming will still be an option
it's an option
that people can choose
it's an option that can be a policy of a
funeral home if they choose
but this gives the deceased and their
family a choice unfettered by an
outdated and confusing statute
i'd be glad to take questions on some of
the specifics i do have a couple people
that work in this more and i think we
have some representatives from the
funeral homes also here
um and
as i said anya nicholas here to testify
as well
any questions
how do you tell us is this on
um in would you would you suggest that
if the body would be
uh viewed
you know as part of the funeral
viewed
longer than 24 hours would you put some
kind of criteria in there that would
have to be held for a certain
temperature for a limited number of
hours one could but i think there's
since that is the
the simple alternative
that
yeah the funeral home themselves should
develop what policy they want because
the problem is going to be simply a
matter of aroma
and if they're concerned about that they
would refrigerate it but you know it's
it's not too tricky you'd refrigerate
the same way you'd refrigerate just
about anything
except you pardon
follow-up follow-up except you would
need a refrigerator at the right size
well yes but again that's that's
something that would be their own choice
in their own policy it could be a
marketing thing a particular place might
say
we provide refrigeration other ones
would say no we don't provide that just
you know it would be there it would be a
choice a policy of the
funeral home and they would do it
whichever way they would feel most
comfortable and then the um
the consumer shall we say or their
family
would then make the choice of where they
yes well first of all that really isn't
germane to this bill i should point out
because one could
repeal the statute on embalming and
still a cemetery may choose to have
their own rules about cement vaults
that's why it's a two-pronged job for
miss nickel but the issue is that that
is a surmountable thing first off many
people who are going to choose such a
thing would also not choose a giant
heavy
casket mahogany casket they might choose
a shroud so all you're doing is really
adding a little matter to the soil
you're not actually taking away and just
like if anybody's ever
dug a hole to put something in and you
when you put it level sure it's going to
sink so what do you do you mound it up
this isn't rocket science you mound it
it settles over time so that's you know
that's that's a surmountable issue we
don't have cave-ins and things like that
and cement vaults tend to leak anyway
but again that i should that's a little
off topic on this particular bill
but very important
any other questions of the
i have one would this would this mean
that
um
at my death
i could be buried in the ground
uh in the
chapel uh memorial garden at our uh
faith-based medical center
and there's no regulations that says my
wife could not bury me in that spot
actually again that's a little far
afield from the scope of this bill no
but your closest guy
i think the experts behind me could
conceivably answer that and but the
thing is there are rules about
cemeteries you can bury on private
ground there are distances from water
sources and things like that that have
to be taken into account but it really
is a rather low impact thing and it's
what we used to do for many years and we
all know there's a lot we're in new
england that's a lot of small private
cemeteries all over the place where
people
were married long be you know long time
ago without bombing caskets and all that
kind of stuff or maybe a simple pine box
thank you any other questions
thank you representative thank you very
much chair calls anya nickel
and please tell this eagle scout uh what
is the girl scout equivalent of a gold
award
can everybody hear me ah okay
so the gold award like you kind of
mentioned is close to the boy scouts
eagle awards
it is the highest honor a girl scout can
receive and it's supposed to leave a
legacy or um
yeah a legacy behind after the girl
scouts so it's supposed to
live past her
good morning my name is anya nickel i'm
a senior in high school from freedom new
hampshire and an ambassador girl scout
a few years ago i began researching and
learning about green or natural burials
without embalming caskets or cement
vaults
i never imagined that it would leave me
here today speaking before you
what began as a german class assignment
on sustainability with the potential
free trip to germany if i won
turned into a passion to ensure people
have a choice on how they are buried
i dove right in determining what was a
natural burial and what were the
existing new hampshire laws if someone
wanted to choose such a burial for
themselves
i quickly learned that while it is not
illegal it was unclear what the statute
was
each town
had different levels of available
information
many didn't even know what their
requirements were and some just referred
me back to the state statutes making the
whole experience quite like i was going
in circles
i couldn't imagine being someone in the
process of making such an important life
decision for oneself and not being able
to uncover basic information
the one day i was sitting in the freedom
village store having tea with my friend
who happens to be a non-agenarian and
long-time beloved freedom resident
my true passion for this topic took hold
i was explaining how i had taken on this
project and would be heading out to
videotape myself and our local cemetery
to submit my video for german class and
the contest
she shared with me her own personal
experience with trying to be buried for
her beliefs and wants
she as a jewish woman wishes to be
buried not embalmed in a pine box
without a vault
she as she put it the sooner i am
pushing up daisies the better
however she reached out to the selectmen
in town after speaking to the cemetery
trustees who were not aware of the
town's requirements
she was told she must be buried in a
vault she as you can see is quite upset
at this as she wants to be buried
in her town according to her beliefs
when reviewing new hampshire statutes i
noticed that one statute about embalming
and felt that a bombing should be a
choice
some people would like to avoid all the
chemicals used in embalming which are
then placed into the ground
i didn't win the contest for my german
project however i did decide i couldn't
stop my work on natural burials as one i
learned so much about it and how
important it is to so many people and
two feel strongly that personal choice
is important especially in such a
personal manner
as i said before i am a girl scout and
have been one for nine years the
organization teaches us how to be the
change in our world
so when i decided to continue my work on
natural burials i developed a plan of
action
presented it to the girl scouts gold
award committee for the green and white
mountains and was approved
since that day i have had the privilege
of working with representative connerk
it is my hope that this committee will
agree that everyone should have a choice
on whether or not they will be involved
which will aid in the realization of
religious beliefs as well as people's
would you take questions
chair calls peter
moore is it moran or morin
morin
representing new hampshire funeral
directors
i do have copies mr chairman of my
testimony
okay thank you thank you very much
yes mr good morning mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
peter morin i am a
i am here
as the executive director of the new
hampshire funeral directors and
embalmers association our trade
association here in new hampshire
we have members across the state
approximately 200
individuals are licensed funeral
directors and embalmers i am myself also
a licensed new hampshire funeral
director and embalmer
and i'm here uh here to testify today on
behalf of the nhfda members in
opposition to house bill 1320
which calls for the repeal of rsa 325
it's interesting that
new hampshire is one of about 40. there
are 39 other states
in the united states that have a similar
requirement either in statute or in
their administrative rules
and i do have that that document with me
here today
it's a survey that was done
nationally
and i believe that new hampshire's in
fact a leader in the fact that we have
it in statute because administrative
rules can be changed
in comparison to statute relatively
easily which statute is a much more as
you all know
a prolonged and detailed process
i also want to mention that there are
many funeral directors that were unable
to be here this morning that wish to be
uh but they are back at their homes in
their communities uh engaged in serving
the grieving and uh by caring and caring
for the dead
i also would like to take a moment just
to pause my testimonies i'd be remiss if
i did not address a subject
which is inevitably connected to the
subject of embalming
and that subject is decomposition which
is a natural process and the reason i
bring this up is because
many of us here today
have no doubt lost someone close to them
someone could be a spouse could be a
parent child siblings or family or
friends
and with this consideration in mind uh
as a both from a both personal and
professional perspective
uh
for the committee members and others in
attendance today uh i'm compelled to
suggest that this hearing is not the
appropriate time and place for an
experienced or graphic description or uh
discussion of decomposition
uh i think i'd be happy to answer those
questions in another venue or personally
that sort of thing or direct you to to
sources if if you're interested in
knowing more
i do want to point out that
here in new hampshire according to vital
vital records
is in 2021 according up into this year
there have been approximately 13 860
deaths here in new hampshire now a few
few thousand more of those were
attributed to
covid uh
but in 2021 as far as i can see from uh
from my research that there were 61
green barrels
so that accounts for you know
thousand eight hundred
uh other new hampshire residents uh who
have died and they need to be
be cared for and that's what our our
profession does
um
and although we admire you know when we
admire and support green burials
and have since they were first
introduced here in new hampshire we've
had a very good relationship with the
folks that advocate that and we
certainly encourage any families that we
work with we help them assist them in
any way can with home funerals uh with
green barrels i think there's some mis
interpretation misrepresentation here
and i do want to mention to to our uh
our civics project uh the young lady who
who spoke before me um miss nichol uh
that that anything that's i express here
today is not personal this is merely our
my my position professionally and i
admire what she's doing uh i myself was
a political science uh major in school
and very interested in how the whole
process works and so i applaud that i
and would certainly be able to you know
offer my assistance if there's anything
basically with that number of of deaths
and there's some confusion about vaults
of course which is a cemetery
requirement
uh it's entirely a cemetery's decision
and the rules and regulations of whether
a vault is required or not many
cemeteries do have sections where they
don't require vaults or they will make
exceptions in terms of for religious and
and other uh traditions uh that would uh
would require a simpler burial such as
judaism uh islam and others
what 325 colon 40-a does is that it
offers it's offered for the last 50
years um
a guidance to the public on
the display the public display or or
exposure to
an unembalmed body
for a time period you know longer than
24 hours after death
and what this guidance really does is
that it helps the families make
perhaps what could be unfortunate
choices
you know given the the unpleasant
realities that accompany
decomposition which is a natural process
and i'm not going to get into any more
detail at this time it also
helps reduce the liability on funeral
homes because if we were to provide
services that we weren't comfortable
with or felt pressured by family
the idea of exposure in terms of mental
anguish and suffering would be i think
would be severe
and that those that liability on both
funeral directors as individuals and as
funeral homes as small businesses here
in new hampshire
now a lot of funeral homes do have
refrigeration many don't
i know it's been grandfathered and that
it would be another be a financial
burden on the funeral home to to have to
be required to do that
um
the other concern we have is that the
the repeal of this statute
uh is going to have a ripple effect on
the administrative rules that receive
their authority from this statute and
there's one in particular about
embalming requirements for winter and
tumens here in new hampshire
many many many cemeteries are closed for
the winter they're inaccessible even in
good weather they're hard to get to
they're small
uh and they they require winter and
tumen uh so that's another consideration
uh they're those sorts of administrative
roles that could be adversely affected
by this and and i really think the
statute the way it is and yeah it is
i think it could be clearly more clearly
written but that's my opinion
uh and that uh it does help protect both
the physical the the mental and
emotional well-being of of our our
friends and neighbors
and also i think in closing i just want
to thank you all for your
your service and and your time and
consideration i'd be happy to try to
answer any questions you have
are there any questions representative
weber
thank you so much for taking my question
uh i guess my question is just as
currently
we have people who
choose
to
follow various different practices
and
with varying degrees of difficulty
wouldn't it be possible even in the
absence of the statute on embalming and
viewing
for any funeral director or embalmer to
set for their own practice whatever
standards they believe are
correct and proper and necessary for the
circumstances the weather and everything
else and let me say just as an aside
that
those of us who've lived through the
resume debates before have no
but
shouldn't that be a matter for
individual
preferences and practices and an
evaluation on
with respect to each individual
circumstances my question
given that the circumstances are very
different say winter to summer and
otherwise and family situations are very
different right thank you that's a very
good question uh representative weber um
what's
already i think one of the
misconceptions here is that
the public actually already has choices
to they have the opportunity to make it
whatever choices they want to make the
only requirements would be if it were an
open casket viewing to the public you
know several days after death the
funeral home would require embalming uh
it's here in the statute but also i
think personally they would
they they do have there is a
federal trade commission regulation
which is federal regulation which does
allow funeral homes to set their own
their own requirements for what services
they provide that will
require embalming but the public
actually has the option to have other
services whether it be a closed casket
many cases that's the case
close gasket if they choose cremation
whether they have services or not
and it's i think my in response to your
question more detail is that
it's very hard to
predict
how
each individual
body is going to to respond and for me
to say
even even with refrigeration which is
only a temporary measure does not
replace the
level of preservation that we get from
embalming
and even under refrigeration the process
will of decomposition continues
and to know what
state that body may be in and three or
four five days from now uh it would be
impossible for me to determine
and uh i think it's i think again it's
don't want to traumatize them we want to
make things you know unpleasant for them
they're already going through enough as
it is
and i don't know if that's answered your
question or not
okay thank you any further questions
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh just a question
about how you read the current statute
which seems to me a little odd
no dead human body shall be exposed to
the public for a period in excess of 24
hours unless
um if i um
say i die and i'm
at your facility for five days
and there's a wake and the fifth day and
people come for an interval of four
hours
um
and then go home
could they come again the following
tuesday for another week for another
four hours
uh at which point that would be nine
days post death
because the way it's worded it says no
dead body shall be exposed to the pub to
the public
in excess of 24 hours in other words i
presume that's cumulative so it seems
like this is worded kind of strangely it
how do you interpret that well thank you
representative woods
you are correct um that there's um
when i look at what i see as the spirit
of the law or i think it's the intent
is that
the intention is the the intent is that
that a dead human body would not be
exposed to the public
um
after they've been dead for more than 24
hours from the time of death that's the
way that the clarification that's the
way i believe it should be
okay um
it's it is uh it is confusing uh it is
not a cumulative time amount of the of
the viewings and so forth and that if
the body were embalmed and you had a
viewing had a calling hours on friday
and then you wanted to do it again
sunday or monday you could definitely of
course you could do that yeah
is that
your comment about it uh interpreted to
a a particular family that comes in and
you say well you're not gonna have this
uh for two day uh awake for two days
then do you tell them that no it has to
be involved the law requires it to be
embalmed within 24 hours is that how you
present that not embalmed within 24
hours but embalmed if he the person the
individual is going to be uh exposed to
the public after the 24 hours from the
time of death thank you
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here and taking our questions
um i see that the rulemaking authority
actually is in 325.9 so that would
remain and there would be the ethical
and professional standards so my
question is if right now the faith
communities judaism and islam
if right now they are limited from
having open casket viewings if they are
not involving the bodies and if this
might be something where certain subsets
of the of the professional community
might adopt this but everybody else
might stay with what's currently in
statute
well thank you representative for your
question uh in both of those traditions
uh they strictly forbid
uh
a viewing of the body the body is in a
closed container on aaron in the jewish
tradition but even in the in his islam
uh they are not exposed to they're not
uh viewable or exposed to the public in
any way as part in terms of like
conservative judaism uh
that that is the case there so it
wouldn't affect them anyway they would
not they would not be embalmed to start
with because of their religious uh
traditions
or law thank you i just wanted to make
sure to protect uh traditions i don't
know quite as well as i agree and we
serve all of those communities and and
yes um
and uh so yeah there is that right
thank you mr chair
thank you mr morton for taking my call
my question
would this bill
limit in any way
what a funeral home could share with the
family about the potential issues with
displaying a body for longer than 24
hours
if i understand your question
representative kennedy would it prohib
prevent us from explaining that right uh
no of course it wouldn't um i personally
um
as i said i know now that everyone is
has the experience of representative
weber from the resume
hearings years ago
it would be it's it's also a
conversation that i you know do have on
occasion it's not a regular one i have
with families uh but you know i'm always
very very very guarded in how i explain
that
and that uh
what you know the need for that and
having having a statute that says we
have this requirement
is helpful in that respect
it's really i've never had a family
argue or ask
when they understand that well i can't
really guarantee
what your loved one's going to look like
and i really can't
can't do that and and frankly i wouldn't
really
i wouldn't want to
um and that's it would expose me a
any other questions
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
am i can you hear me now yes
okay
um
so
i do believe there are certain buddhist
traditions which um
do have um viewings of a body or sitting
with the body for um an extensive period
of time after death and i was just
wondering and i apologize if this was
covered i did come in late
um if the statute as it's written
currently
does it only apply to viewings in
funeral homes or
if these viewings are done
elsewhere in a place of worship or in a
home
does the statute still apply
well i don't know if i'm qualified to
make that that uh that distinction uh in
terms of the interpretation of the
statute i i've had a i've done buddhist
services with just the situation which
you have you have described where the
individual uh who was from tibet uh he'd
been under hospice care he remained at
home
after his death
and the monks from a local temple came
for three days to pray uh as we all went
um
what i think
in a case like that uh what the family
chooses and in that is it's
again i don't regard would regard that
as being exposed to the public that
would be more of what i would think i
would interpret as a private service we
have home bear we have home funerals
where people might use dry ice or other
means uh
again i'm not the i'm not the embalming
police here this is not i think this may
be more towards like those public what i
would consider a public venue thank you
how's that perfect
the red button
um if the family wanted to have a
natural funeral but they could not get
their family all together
in 24 hours
would refrigeration function okay
if it was uh 48 or 72 hours in your
experience
well thank you representative for your
question um again that's
every every case every
individual that we care for that's in in
our care uh
it has a potential being a different
very indifferent scenario there are
different considerations in terms of the
cause of death
the size weight of the individual
they're things that can can affect
uh how well that would work and so it's
a very it's hard fart for me to
determine whether
now are you talking about a service at
the funeral home right now or is it this
being their own home or
funeral home
uh
i
i can answer this personally i can't
answer for every funeral director i i
would be more comfortable if they were
involved if it was going to be three or
four days later yeah
follow up
i'm still trying to under learn the law
so
is it okay
to have a closed if you had a casket
could you have a closed casket
is this 24 hour limit currently
just for an open casket or does it apply
to closed too
you're absolutely correct it is only
applies to like a public viewing an open
casket both of my parents their wish was
would not was not to be embalmed to have
no public viewing we did have calling
hours with a closed casket there are
other means of of things that in
preparation that can be done but they're
you know they're in a closed casket so
they're not exposed to the public uh and
other precautions are taken and i
respected their wishes and uh you know
and that we we have services in with
that all the time how long how many days
thank you very much i appreciate your
testimony we've got to move on
and the chair now calls lee webster
the hampshire funeral resources
education and advocacy
it says
and you are here to support the bill
correct
yes it's a long name
good morning
my name is lee webster i'm the director
of new hampshire funeral resources
education and advocacy we also call this
new hampshire free
just to have a nice
acronym
at a family barbecue a few years ago i
was the one getting the grilling about
home funerals and green burials from my
aunt
who lost her husband a couple of years
before
when i explained the new hampshire
embalming law to her she was devastated
to learn that my uncle needn't have been
embalmed
i didn't want that she told me but they
said we had to
that it was the law
over the past 15 years leading new
hampshire free and several other related
national nonprofits
i've heard countless similar stories
first hand from people accompanied by
tears of anger and guilt
and panic about how they'll pay for it
and i've spoken with many conscientious
new hampshire funeral directors who are
well aware that this law does not
require embalming 24 hours after a death
it's common misinterpretation
at issue here is the difference between
business policy and the law
most funeral businesses have in-house
policies that require embalming before
public viewings that last any period of
time and that's perfectly within their
rights as business owners
for instance
quote it's our policy to require
embalming if a body is to be held in our
facility for over 48 hours and quote
appears on several new hampshire funeral
price lists
but this bill isn't about a business
policy it's about a law
and the law says that proper embalming
is only required in the event that a
body is going to be exposed to the
public
in excess of 24 hours
the law doesn't say what constitutes a
proper embalming or anything about the
time from death to the procedure it only
states the public viewing period
and still you'll find some new hampshire
general price lists that erroneously
state quote
embalming is required if viewing occurs
more than 24 hours after the death
per
new hampshire rsa 325 40a
and quote
many people have reported to me having
heard similar claims in funeral
arrangements
conferences
the federal trade commission the agency
that oversees the funeral profession
with what's called the funeral rule
requires anyone who provides funeral
services to declare the following on
their written price list quote
embalming is not required by law end
quote
it goes on to empower funeral businesses
to require it if they choose but doesn't
legislate it
some forms of embalming laws do exist in
other states in fact 14 states have some
wording that requires either embalming
or refrigeration after a certain number
of days
about half of the states don't mention
in the law embalming whatsoever
new hampshire stands alone in requiring
embalming for a day and night long
viewing of a body
here in new hampshire cemeteries often
use outdoor storage until the spring
burial season for those who die during
the time when the ground is frozen an
embalming fluid manufacturer recently
confirmed to me that the preservative
effects of conventional
formaldehyde-based embalming last about
two weeks
what then is preserving the bodies in
the winter
it's the cold
new hampshire law doesn't mention
refrigeration and accepted an effective
natural burials that don't allow
embalming including those for jews
muslims quakers and several other
religious traditions have occurred year
round the world round for centuries
sextons in northern natural cemeteries
routinely clear snow
thaw frost when necessary dig in close
graves in winter
the choice of whether to offer burial in
winter in new hampshire municipal
cemeteries rests solely with our elected
trustees who write and enforce each
town's cemetery bylaws
their choice to limit burial in winter
is not a good enough reason to limit new
hampshire citizens right to say no to
embalming
one more observation
new hampshire law confers full custody
and control of a dead body to the next
of kin in rsa29017
can this be true if another law takes
that control out of their hands
to take it a step further some might
also consider the state compelling its
citizens to pay for
to pay for a family member to undergo
embalming for any reason
and infringement on their family privacy
rights
leaving this law in the books keeps the
door open for continued
misrepresentation that has already led
to the limiting of personal choice and
created immeasurable financial and
emotional hardship for some new
hampshire citizens
removing it will not affect the rights
of funeral professionals to offer or
even require embalming in their place of
business but it will provide clearer
choice for consumers and the families
being served
thank you
miss webster would you take questions
i know that i'm trying not to say doctor
[Laughter]
representative
thank you mr chairman
um thank you for taking my question um
have you experienced through your work
with free
that
family members find the cost of
embalming to be a
burden a financial burden
i can tell you that i
frequently receive calls from new
hampshire people who are
looking for a way to be able to afford
all of it
but
that is a particular concern for them
often because they've been told that
it's required
regardless of what their other plans are
so i would say
yes it's a hardship
thank you for your testimony and uh miss
mr morin you had handouts did we get
them did you pass them around
the chair uh now recognizes
and i'm going to do it the way i was
taught in a new england mill town
am i right on conway
that's the old french way we've
anglicized it a bit uh mark conoyer
but uh thank you thank you
a uh
i'm a fellow uh eagle scout as well and
i appreciate
but again i'm here a
30-year funeral director and obama here
in new hampshire
i did submit my
testimony in writing uh last evening
and
i would like to make myself available to
answer any questions uh pertaining to
that
i uh i do want to state very clearly
we're here
i'm here in opposition of the bill
i uh
there is a a common misunderstanding
that embalming is is required
um it is not it is
it is uh very infrequently uh not
required but there are always
instances that arise that do
it is the best practice or best choice
of care
to help satisfy a family's request
to take the requirement out of the rsa
would allow
uh a family to decline what might be the
most appropriate approach to
satisfying their requests
um so that that's my concern and and you
unintended consequences of of removing
it entirely rewriting or amending
the bill to be clearer for the public
would be wonderful but um to eliminate
that that requirement is a concern
i have a question for you sir i've been
ordained for 47 years so i have been
part of at least 200 funerals in that
capacity
and probably about a third of them i
accompanied the family in their initial
visit to the funeral home
i don't ever recall a funeral director
saying that there were a variety of
choices such as green burial or these
things only once did a family ask and
they were very quickly talked out of it
with an intention
i'm not saying that's you i'm not saying
that's new hampshire i've not i've only
done a handful of funerals in new
hampshire
but i am saying that it is not my
experience that
funeral directors as a rule present
anything other than what is their
so my question is would you believe that
my experience
even though it's considerable is an
outlier
well thank you for your question i would
feel that way i i the the funeral
directors
and and figured me for not saying before
i i have served on the ex
the
new hampshire funeral directors
association i've also served nationally
with national funeral directors
association as a liaison between new
hampshire and the national
um
i would think that's a rarity the the
funeral director is
that i'm much more familiar with
have always been upfront with families
regarding choices
personally
even though alkaline hydrolysis is not
allowed here in new hampshire i've even
helped families acquire those services
in maine
so
most funeral homes most funeral
more of a concierge in trying to meet
anyone's request
instead of declining uh any any part of
care for any reason
that was only my follow-up is that was
only in one occasion
that it was lobbied against the most the
rest of the time it wasn't mentioned at
all
so anyway representative weber
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking
thank you for taking my question it's
awfully hard when you can't see people's
i'm kind of interested in following up
on your statement if i understood it
correctly about
taking this out of the statute might
interfere with a family's
most appropriate way of
honoring their
decedent's wishes and
i'm trying to figure out how
taking this out of the statute would in
any way
interfere with the family's desires
because
clearly if a family wants embalming
they may have embalming
clearly if a family wants a viewing a
number of days in the future so that
others can get there
that is a discussion that must be had
with the funeral
uh
home
about what
what is appropriate and what is not
appropriate and what what their choices
are under those circumstances but i
don't see how reviewing
how repealing the statute could in any
way
interfere with the family
making the most important choices
wouldn't necessarily interfere thank you
for your question it wouldn't
necessarily interfere with their their
choices i i
i don't believe it would interfere with
their choices it would be
um
like in the case of of organ donation or
autopsies the you know the organ bank is
that
organ donation is such a great gift of
life um and they
do share with each each donor's family
that they can see their loved one again
after that process
and if they're able to
you know decline uh if it's not a
requirement
in in any way shape or form
if they're able to decline
that type of care after a donation
just for an example
it's not going to be a very pleasant
goodbye for that family
that that's i don't know if that would
that would be a good discussion to have
with a family regarding
you know the good and bad of of seeing
someone
after any type of death and
it should be a careful discussion held
and it's on us as funeral directors to
make sure
uh the families take their time in any
choice that's made
but um
i think without having that as a
you know as something to fall back on as
a requirement if absolutely needed
i think that
is my concern more than
anything else
follow-up
but is there anything that stops you as
a funeral director from saying that is
yes
i understand i understand that these are
very difficult times and very delicate
negotiations and i have been
certainly been part of them on a number
of occasions
but
isn't what families are asking for at
this time
just a straight answer and straight
information
on what
on all the consequences of their choices
because
i do understand that people come to
this process the first time
with a lot of misconceptions and
misunderstandings and
is isn't that the basis of what your
profession is providing
kindly guiding through those choices
and the consequences
pleasant or unpleasant of any choice
they might make
it it is and it is on us to
be very
clear in answering their questions
but in a gentle way it's not on the
funeral director to say no to a request
without
you know very carefully
reviewing
all that's involved right and just just
one final very quick follow-up if you
may but it's certainly in the purview of
a funeral director to say
uh the choice you are making i believe
is a hazard to me and to my employees
and we simply can't
help you in that respect
is that not true i mean i know that
that's not something you want to do but
you have that option do you not
we do we have the option of not helping
the medical examiner we have the option
of of all of this but
it's not an option that any of us are
i saw another hand
waving off okay thank you sir appreciate
you thank you
the chair calls up susan hopkins new
hampshire state board of funeral
directors and
it's abbreviated but i'm going to stick
a stab at it it's embalmers that is
correct
good morning good morning chairman
pearson and members of the committee my
name is susan hopkins and i've been a
licensed funeral director and the ant
obama in the state of new hampshire for
the past 20 years i own a business in
salem and i am a current member of the
new hampshire state board of funeral
directors and embalmers
i do want to state that no
state
currently requires embalming of every
the state board of funeral directors and
obamas are opposed to
to changing the embalming statute
rsa 325 40a
we don't know how the repeal of this
statute would impact the administrative
rules and the legacy of funeral service
funeral service has not changed much in
decades
and embalming remains the only way to
temporarily preserve a deceased person
for viewing
embalming doesn't stop a deceased person
from returning to their natural state it
only slows down the process
embalming sanitizes
and temporarily preserves a deceased
person to allow family members and
friends the opportunity to have a
private or public viewing if they choose
embalming is not mandatory
and currently is not required if the
family chooses
a service with a closed casket or
cremation prior to any funeral services
there has been some discussion about
green burial
and i can't speak to every town but in
the town of salem
there is no cemetery that would allow
green burials
there is also
in salem
no cemetery
that would allow
a jewish person to be buried in
their
faith tradition
but there are certainly
other
mostly jewish cemeteries or
other cemeteries of faith tradition
where people can have
their
loved ones buried in their faith
tradition that they would
like
for me personally the biggest issues are
public safety around the natural
decomposition process
and the mental health of families that
we are honored to
serve
i am about to give a graphic explanation
of what happens when someone passes away
but i think it's important for you to
understand the process and it's
necessary to understand the consequence
of repealing this legislation
when a person passes away
decomposition begins within several
minutes with a process called itolysis
or self-digestion
chemical reactions occur
enzymes digest cell walls
tissues and organs break down
discoloration occurs
rigor mortis sets in
bacteria spreads throughout the body
gases build up and the pressure causes
fluids to leak out
this happens at different intervals
we do not want to traumatize families if
they witness any consequence of the
decomposition process
embalming is currently the only way to
delay this process
most funeral homes and nursing homes do
not have refrigeration
and many hospitals have very small
morgues
refrigeration does not prohibit the
chemical reactions from occurring
the same way that embalming does
often when death occurs in
suddenly
in a hospital or nursing home
family and friends may have minimal
contact with them
due to the current pandemic it is not in
the best interest of the public to view
people that have died of covet 19
without their being embalmed
families may not have been able to visit
with their loved ones in their last days
because they are in isolation
it is difficult to place a value on
comfort
it is a treasured gift for families to
safely have the opportunity to say
goodbye to their loved ones
families are often relieved to see their
loved ones at peace
this also happens
helps with the grieving process
and when i personally meet with the
family i ask them
what type of service they are interested
in
and
many times embalming is not involved and
that
of course
every family should have what they want
and we do need to have discussions
about what families would choose
these are just a few of the reasons that
i urge you to find house bill 1320 in
expedient to legislate thank you thank
you miss hopkins are there any questions
thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question i'm trying to
discern whether the consequence that
people
refer to
may be an unintended consequence
is that a
public health
consequence is there a danger of someone
becoming
ill or harmed from a decomposing body or
is the consequence that we're discussing
one of psychological potential
psychological damage or trauma and if
that is the case
are we trying to protect someone from
themselves
when people should really have the
opportunity to make those decisions
themselves
they currently do have the opportunity
to make those decisions
in what they want but as
mark conoyer mentioned if somebody
does
choose to donate organs or
that is not
a good situation for family members to
view
you know trying to be delicate and we
would have to have that discussion with
people
and
to your point representative pearson
as a member of the new hampshire state
board of funeral directors and bombers i
and members
of the board go around to different
funeral homes and inspect their
paperwork
and
every price list in every there is
documentation
that states embalming is not required
and the funeral role of the ftc funeral
rule of 1984
follow-up
yes thank you um and i'm sure that
in my experience
funeral directors
that i have dealt with have been i'm
very skilled and very sensitive about
having these discussions at a time when
it's absolutely necessary and i
appreciate that
i still didn't understand whether the
consequence that we're talking about
is a health consequence
or
or an issue of trauma
well unfortunately
we
certain causes are put on the death
certificate but that
doesn't always state everything that the
person died of
and with the current pandemic the rules
keep changing about what is safe and
what isn't safe
and
we can't say for sure
we don't always know what sort of
medications chemotherapy
the half-life all of that
we are not aware of all of that so i'm
not trying to avoid the question but i
just don't have the medical
background
and we're not informed with all of the
medications that were put into
their bodies prior to us having them in
our funeral homes
and
with respect to
autopsies and organ donation
that would be more of um a traumatic
experience
thank you over this side of the
playground yes representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um so
i'm trying to understand um you said it
wouldn't be a good situation
for a
unembalmed viewing
after an autopsy or an organ donation
and you mentioned um
you know
that
there may be some issue of trauma in
your testimony
and
i i'm wondering
um
why
why we should continue to not allow
there to be a choice because i consider
that some families may be traumatized by
not having the option of having a
viewing
in any situation
and you know and many are willing to
face the reality of death whether it's
after
an autopsy or an organ donation or an
accident
many are willing to face that and many
just want to honor their loved ones
wishes and
removing the ability to choose would
i don't know if i mean i i don't want to
get too graphic but when
it
they do
have their organs removed including
their brain
and there is
multiple there are multiple incisions on
their
head as well as their body
that
with the embalming process it's easier
to hide that incision
[Music]
families do have that opportunity within
the 24 hours
but
that would be a delicate discussion
because we certainly
want to help families move forward
and
and not
soloway chairman uh thank you mrs
thank representative
hopkins for coming um just a very quick
question it's a follow-up to
representative shapiro's question which
i think is quite incisive
um he asked whether we were dealing with
issues of grief or issues of public
health were you practicing at the time
that we got the first ebola cases that
came to this country or
sudden acute respiratory syndrome sars
and did you get directives from the
department of public health or any other
agency on how to potentially deal with
um
bodies that had died of these causes
we do get some directives
but
things change as information becomes
aware
and
that's the difficult position that
funeral directors would be in just
looking at the recent covet pandemic all
of the changes that have been made
we want to keep everyone safe and there
are options to do that currently
good okay and we're going to have to
really pick up speed as we come to close
here so just one question with no
follow-up please okay
um how long excuse me how long would you
feel comfortable
and could you choose not to offer the
service if someone said i'd like a
viewing with an un my unembalmed family
member but i'd like it in two days or
three days
would you have the right simply to say
we don't do that
we
would be able to have that right and as
peter morin previously stated
there isn't an exact science about how
decomposition occurs
it
it's a variety of factors that
we don't have time to go into today
thank you and thank you uh so much for
coming thank you for your time the last
pink cut i have is from josh slocum from
thank you good morning
funeral consumers alliance is a
non-profit educational organization
think of us like we were consumer
reports magazine but focused only on the
end-of-life transaction
um i'll go quickly through my testimony
but i did want to offer a correction to
what i think are some misunderstandings
that were introduced earlier
it is not the case that 39 other states
have a law on their books that requires
embalming for viewing a body
i know this because i am the co-author
of a book called final rights which is a
compendium of state laws all 50 states
in the district
on funeral and burial law written from a
consumer perspective new hampshire is
the only state i am aware of in updating
this research that has a law that claims
that embalming is necessary in a period
in excess of 24 hours
i would also like to state it is simply
not the case that this is a public
health issue the centers for disease
control the world health organization
the pan-american health organization
have all repeatedly
clearly stated
that simply viewing an unembalmed body
is not a public health problem we are
all viewing each other right now in this
room this is a mass viewing
we are not worried that because we are
unembalmed
that we are going to be a danger to each
other
hb 1320 is about freedom of choice this
bill would remove new hampshire's unique
statutory requirement that anybody
displayed to the public in excess of 24
hours be embalmed
as others have noted the statute is
confusingly written when you read it
you're not sure if it means one of two
very different things number one
once 24 hours has passed since death any
body that is going to be looked at has
to be embalmed or number two
anybody embalmed excuse me anybody
viewed by the public for a cumulative
duration of more than 24 hours must be
embalmed we cannot tell from the
statutory language
this ambiguity has led to some new
hampshire funeral homes stating that
embalming is required by law in order
for the family to view the body if it
takes place more than a day after death
since it is practically impossible to
organize a viewing within 24 hours of
death for most families these families
are forced to pay for a process that
they may not want and they may not be
able to afford and i'd like to
highlight here
it is not uncommon to see a price tag of
between 700 and 1200 dollars for
embalming
i don't know how everyone else in this
room is fixed financially but for a lot
of families that's quite a significant
outlay of cash
we think this is not an acceptable
situation the choice of embalming should
remain a personal one and we don't
believe that the state has a legitimate
interest
in compelling families to choose a
process and to pay for it
that they may not want that they may
find unnecessary invasive or contrary to
embalming is a cosmetic procedure whose
effects last in general about two weeks
and it's important to remember that this
process
was developed during an age when the
idea of miasmas or smelly air
was believed to be the chief cause of
illness
when this law in new hampshire was
enacted in 1971 germ theory was well
established but this particular point
was not as well understood
50 years later we know that corpses are
almost never a source of disease
transmission certainly not to those who
are merely viewing the body
half the states do have laws that speak
to embalming or refrigeration they
include this choice
none require it as a matter of course
hb 1320 would simply restore this choice
to families where we believe it should
be
the bill does not take away any options
from any party to this transaction it
does not bar funeral homes from
requiring embalming if they choose for a
public viewing
most funeral homes already do make this
choice we're not asking the state to
stop funeral homes from setting their
own policies we are asking the state to
remove a confusingly written law that
has been misused by a minority of
funeral homes to compel a purchase that
some families don't want to make there
are times when embalming is the most
practical choice and if it's desired by
the family they should have that choice
but there are other options such as cold
storage or mechanical refrigeration that
solve problems having to do with
preservation
no funeral home and no family in new
hampshire will be bereft of options
if this law is passed and i thank you
we've done a lot of work with end of
life decisions
in fact i just did that with my will
uh it seems to me we're hearing about
the decisions of
those who are still alive instead of the
decisions
about the person that's dying
and that i would prefer and i'm getting
close to
because of my age to be thinking about
this
i would like to have some say in
that funeral
or the whole process
so i did go to my local
funeral homes of
people that i've known for
a long time but seemed to me they were
mostly talking about money
and that i should get insurance and
raise eight thousand dollars so nobody
has to take that burden
but i didn't have much information about
my decision about what i want
done at that funeral
do you have any thoughts about that
and maybe
that should be included
in the legislation
well i'd actually i think there are ways
for people to have um influence over
what funeral choices are carried out
after their death
i think that's probably something better
addressed in a separate conversation
because i don't believe that
i don't believe it's something this bill
could could practically address
but if you'd like to give funeral
consumers alliance a call you and i can
talk about that i'm happy to help anyone
thank you
thank you very much um this card just
they should come earlier
and i will accept no further pink cards
david bryant you asked for three minutes
i will allow you three minutes
representing bryant funeral homes and
crematory
not just a nudge
thank you sir
um
very briefly
came down from coast county this morning
but
families have choices now i really don't
believe
that this regulation prevents people
from
having what they want if they make an
educated decision and i think by
educating yourselves
ahead of time that's the best way to go
about making these decisions of course
we all know that deaths occur
unexpectedly and in tragic circumstances
but
education in advance my personal opinion
is by far the
best
way to go
i'm kind of the young guy in the room
i'm 28 so i'm one of the younger funeral
directors in our state
and i'm not opposed to having a
conversation with people when they come
into our facility about what they want
and generally it's how i start every
conversation what do you want
what is it that you're looking for how
can i help you
i understand probably other funeral
directors may not do that i think the
vast majority do
embalming
is not
the sole
complication with green burials the
green burial council does have embalming
chemicals that are certified their
national nonprofit organization
that they allow
for the embalming process to take place
and to for the person to be buried in a
green burial uh environment
um so i think embalming
doesn't necessarily preclude someone
from being buried in a green environment
i think they just need to be educated go
about it the right way there are a lot
of other regulations such as the
cemeteries requiring vaults that are
much more applicable in my experience
i'm not aware of one cemetery in all of
coast county which is the largest as you
know
that allows green burial
and each cemetery requires that on their
own basis as is previously stated um
cost
i think there's been a misrepresentation
in my own opinion
mr slocum i'm sorry if i didn't get your
name right
uh
uh i think is right with you know
embalming in my experience with new
hampshire funeral homes goes from you
know somewhere around 595 dollars to up
to a thousand dollars i'm sure i'm not
it's not a scientific estimate
but that's only one cost involved with
the funeral process the federal trade
commission has a whole list of items
that we have to follow and many more
are applicable not just embalming so i
think that may have been misunderstood
and i finally i think i would argue that
refrigeration is the best form of
temporary storage embalming is a
temporary process but in my experience
an embalmed body is
much better suited for temporary storage
than a refrigerated one and to not
require embalming for winter storage
which kind of came up a little bit i
think would be not dignified number one
and not sanitary go to a hospital
doctors nurses everyone's gowned up to
deal with somebody with body fluids
i think it's probably
viewing an unbound body can be a health
hazard i'm not you know a physician or
anything like that i think it could be i
think it's
more often than not a psychological uh
type of issue but i would say that
refrigeration is not to be all endo
well first of all thank you from for
coming down from way up north
and thank you for being
speaking for uh
two minutes and 72 seconds thank you so
much
i appreciate your effort all right
take care thank you thank you and with
that uh bring to a close
how's the
committee hearing on house bill 1320
thank you anya for coming and let us
know when you
uh get the equivalent of eagles okay
thank you
now
open the hearing thank you for house
and the chair recognizes the prime
sponsor let me see if i get the last
name right i've been on a losing streak
on that kim rice
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
i apologize i do not have written
testimony um
because i i couldn't
put this down on paper
um so
hp 1439
[Music]
is a bill that no patient left a loan
act
when this
bill was brought to my attention this is
a bill that passed the oklahoma
legislature and was signed into law
in may of 2021.
i jumped right on this because the last
six months have been
horrible in my life
so i just want to share my experience
and how i firmly believe
that no one
should be left alone to die
i left alone in an icu without a loved
one
i do believe it makes a difference
and i will die on that sword
so in september my mother passed away
a month and a half later my 86 year old
stepfather
whom i had to go check on frequently
because he lived in rochester and was
stubborn and wouldn't come and live with
us
had fallen
so i called an ambulance he was taken to
the hospital and sent home
that i got him into bed and said i'll be
back in the morning
in the morning i got there he had fallen
again
so i called an ambulance and took him to
a different hospital
and i am his dpoa so sitting in the
hospital room with him
until
he got a positive covet test then they
kicked me out
now mind you i'm vaccinated
i thought i was doing everything right
and i was thrown out to leave my 86 year
old stepfather alone in the hospital
not knowing if he was going to live or
die
and i was mortified i
he was already severely depressed having
lost the love of his life of 42 years
and to leave him alone i felt was
so cruel
so he was quarantined for 14 days during
i got a call
that my little brother was in the icu
and i needed to get out there because
before he was intubated he made me his
dpoa i wish people would quit doing that
and my little brother was in the icu i
got to go in i had to show my vaccine
card i was going to do whatever they
wanted me to do
to be there with him
so he knew he was loved he could hear my
voice
so while i was there
in that room every day holding his hand
the doctor came in and said to me you
are his medicine
everyone should have their medicine with
them
no one
should die
wondering where is their loved one
why aren't they here with me to comfort
sadly when i left hawaii that night
by the time my plane landed my brother
so then
i have a friend angie simpson
whose 31 year old daughter jessica
she could not be there with her daughter
they wouldn't let her in she didn't get
to hold her she didn't get to whisper in
and sadly jessica died she was 31
without her mom
then my friend shannon
just passed away a week and a half ago
from koben in an icu
by herself
with no family member
near
to speak to her
and i know
that
these have been trying times
and we're all learning
and while
i appreciate the fact that they can
facetime family members it's not the
same
it is not the same as feeling that loved
and whether i don't know if it was more
comforting for me
to be with my brother or more comforting
for him
but regardless that doctor said
i was his medicine
that's from a doctor
i need a tissue i didn't i was hoping i
but
i firmly believe that it's cruel thank
i believe that it's cruel
and it should not happen
again
i would have done whatever i had to do
to be there with my loved one and i
think anyone else would do the same
if not someone in their family
but they should not be dying alone we
have done a huge disservice to our
elderly who have been left alone without
their loved ones
and i just don't know how as a society
how we can
accept that
that's all and i i've also passed out
information
um
regarding the the law in oklahoma and
regarding a couple from i believe it was
chicago whose newborn baby tested
positive for covid and they wouldn't let
the mother near it to even nurse it
there's something wrong
there is something wrong
and and that's that's all i can take any
questions
sure
is your experience
that of my recent experience
in
talking to
the chief executive officer of a new
hampshire hospital
who said this law is not necessary
because we do all these things now just
like this
no this law is necessary i wouldn't be
here
if this law wasn't necessary i wouldn't
be sitting here
my follow-up would be
then this law is no threat
to a hospital who's already doing it
absolutely not be a threat to the ones
who aren't correct
is that your experience that is my
experience thank you thank you any other
questions
representative acton
thank you
mr mr chair um and thank you
representative for taking my question
i thought that i thought that these
we as a society had had saw
how bad this was in the early days of
covert and this this had
changed it wasn't being done anymore but
you're saying that just two weeks ago
you were denied to see someone
this has been
my mother passed away
september
4th
since september 4th i have dealt with
more nurses hospitals
than i ever cared to in my entire life
okay and i can tell you that shannon's
family was not allowed to see her
and this was a week and a half ago
um angie's daughter passed away and i
believe it was november it was right
okay thank you representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
thank you um madam speaker pro-tempore
and i'm really sorry about condolences
for the terrible experiences you've had
over the last several months
uh i have my question is on the bill um
on
page
uh
on the first page of the bill
language on in section three it's line
12.
um this section says a healthcare
facility may establish visitation
policies that limit or restrict
visitation when and then it goes through
a couple of
reasons that they could deny visits and
my concern is that
for a the presence of visitors would be
medically or therapeutically
contraindicated in the best clinical
judgment of healthcare professionals i'm
concerned that that would kind of um
provide opportunity for a doctor
or a nurse to
and i and i i agree to a sense um i
think we have to afford them some leeway
because we are not privy to every case
that's in there i mean for example i
would think a mass casualty casualty
incident would be
you know not in the best interest of
everyone to have a a hospital full of
people
you know looking for their loved ones
when they're they're trying to care for
you know a number of people at the same
time but i mean listen
i'm open to suggestions this spill is
now in your hands and i trust that you
all will do
what's best and right
and i really
express right
where it comes to
humanity
and people
that's where i am
representative
thank you very much um and thanks for
taking my question and it's a follow-up
actually on representative cushman's
question
um
clarification i think is is the concern
because what do we mean by medically or
therapeutically contraindicated and what
i was a little bit concerned about is
there are some procedures we do to
people that are
can be for the lay person a bit gruesome
intonation draining a large
pocket of pus
these could be done at the bedside um or
insertion of a central line
and um
they oftentimes may faint in the middle
of this and we can't be resuscitating
them at the same time
so i'm just trying to figure out again
that that issue of how we define these
because it's probably not medically
contraindicated nor therapeutically but
just as you were here for much of the
last bill it's a little bit of
a queasiness factor perhaps for some
people
you might want to warn them you really
ought not to be in here because well i
think that yeah well i think that um
hospitals do that now um you know listen
this is what we're going to do be doing
you may want to step outside
you know a lot of times i step outside
because i am queasy
and i don't want to see it but you know
it so could i mean cpr is very brutal
you know i mean
but this is something that you know
people need to
understand when they're going in but i
don't find it to be a reason to keep
someone
away
follow up uh
but that's what i'm trying to start out
there yeah
your final comment is but it's not a
reason to keep them away so you're
saying
this should not be construed as to
a lot as to allow the hospital say you
shouldn't be in here when we're going to
be intubating this person
well i think that
i think maybe we could find
some better language if you have any
suggestions you know what i mean but i
don't think it's a reason to kill the
bill i think it's a reason to work on it
and and and bring some humanity
and compassion to
these sick people
representative folsom
thank you
chairman pearson and thank you
representative rice
my own personal experience with my
mother when she was older and in the
hospital for specific reasons
she had diminished capacity for
understanding what was happening and so
the staff actually liked that i was
there because it kept her calmer
she had an infectious disease
what the hospital
asked me to do which i comply
was to make sure i wore gloves a gown
and a mask
every time i stepped into the room
i took it all off
as i left
and
redid that every time i went in and out
of that room
um would you be comfortable
um if we
somehow
um did an amendment where uh that one
section that representative cushman uh
referenced
uh was replaced with uh something to the
effect that
the facility
could um
could
you to have protected
whatever it is in um oh that's online
money yeah okay so we're upset with that
but
um okay listen i certainly don't want to
make anyone's jobs harder but i will
agree i don't
you know um but i do believe that you
are absolutely correct that i had to
have my stepdad in the er two weeks ago
and
he was a little combative they didn't
want me to leave
and the only reason i got to go in was
because i was his dpoa
right and at the time he had a lot of
confusion and couldn't make decisions on
his own
but they didn't want me to leave because
they couldn't check on him
i was in the er six days after i tested
positive for covid not for covert
related symptoms but for something else
and they made my husband my husband
whom i live with
sit in the truck
and put me in a room i swear no bigger
than a closet on a gurney that couldn't
even be stretched out flat because it
wouldn't fit
closed the door left me in there alone
for two hours
could have died in there nobody would
have known
right so what harm would it have done to
have my husband in that room with me
and and that's and i again i don't mean
to sound unsympathetic to our health
care workers i know they're strapped
and i feel for them
we have to look at both sides of the
picture
thank you and thank you for taking my
question and i'm so sorry
for your losses
i'm wondering
as i look at this
does not the language that is on line 16
that says the presence of visitors would
interfere with the care of or rights of
any patient
deal with the concerns that oh my gosh
somebody's standing there and they're
going to pass out and the medical
professionals are going to have to step
over them while they're trying to care
for the person who is ill
and
is it
not clear from the language that's
submitted here do you know what let me
just take a detour do you know if this
has been adopted anywhere other than it
has oklahoma yeah i think arkansas has
something similar going i'm not for
certain
um but you know i will say you know it
has been signed into law in arkansas in
may of 2021 and
2021 and the sky has not fallen okay
thank you i think i'll leave it there
thank you so much representative the
says
uh chairman pearson members of the
health human services elderly affairs
committee for the record my name is john
williams i'm the director of legislative
affairs for the department of health and
services
and also heartfelt condolences to the
very long year that reverend rice went
through i've known many of you for many
years so
it's it's been tough time for many
i'm here to provide at least
three areas within the bill that we're
asking the committee to look at we're
certainly here as a resource to
represent rice to this committee to
leadership uh for both um parties to
working on legislation um and i think
that representative cushman
representative connerk and represent
weber uh and also reverend folsom
pointed out a couple of the items that i
would like to touch upon very briefly
looking on page one of the newly created
rsa 151 colon 2j which would create the
visitation policies for the presence of
parents and spouse and caregivers you'll
see in paragraphs one and two that it
enumerates in paragraph one
as it would relate to children or minors
and then paragraph two as this law would
relate to each adult
the reference that you'll see in both
paragraph one and two on lines six and
ten respectively make reference to those
healthcare facilities that are licensed
pursuant to rsa
151.2 and for those of you who have your
laptops open and you actually can open
up to see what 151 2 specifically states
that there is no specific definition
within that rsa for healthcare
facilities so you'll see that the
the bill
as currently drafted should have further
consideration to identify what types of
facilities if we're talking about
hospitals are we talking about
ambulatory surgical care centers are we
talking about nursing homes in long long
term care facilities but it also
includes such entities as adult day care
and the community
health clinics and
the
various other facilities such as renal
dialysis so the net is currently drafted
because of the specific reference to rsa
151 just needs to be teased out a bit
more to identify which specific
facilities that are being identified as
part of the legislation
i'd like now to move to my second
commentary around starting on page two
on starting on lines 4
through line
line 7 which is paragraph 7 of the
proposed newly created section
in 151
it provides that in paragraph seven that
each healthcare facility license
pursuant to rsa 151-2 and again we see
the reference that it's too broad
it shall post on its website information
materials it's the following language
where it says developed by the
department of health and services
again developed by the department of
health human services explaining the
right specific uh specified in this
section that the following sentence also
is of concern which is the department
shall develop such informational
materials and make the materials
available to health care facilities our
facility for this purpose
currently under the licensing oversight
that we have as an agency this would be
the first of its kind in terms of us
providing direction to those facilities
in this manner
we would request consideration for that
to be placed upon the facilities
themselves to work together
collaboratively to define what that
standard would be and what type of
notices so again it's because we do the
regulatory oversight of the facilities
uh and this would be again something
that we have not
been required to do in new hampshire uh
until this this legislation before you
so again we don't think that the idea is
uh necessarily a bad idea but we do
think that it should not be something
that the department should be involved
with so as to paragraph seven we just
respectfully ask for deletion of the
references to the department if you
start with the first
sentence you would just have to on line
five
delete from the word developed all the
way through the word services
and then on the final sentence for
paragraph seven delete the
entirety of that sentence that directs
the department to perform that otherwise
we would not have further concerns as to
that particular section but also but i
would like to defer also to the health
care provider community that i
anticipate will be testifying because it
may have additional thoughts so i don't
want my commentary to be limiting to
them but rather focusing on the
department and what our
scope of our regulatory authority would
be
paragraph eight which starts on lines
eight through line 17 of the bill and i
think it goes back to represent cushman
who identified in an earlier provision
where there was some need to bring
greater clarity if you'll see here it
says specifically unless expressively
required by federal law or regulation
the department or any other state agency
shall not
take any action against a health care
facility for
and it's just a drafting item because
usually when we're granted authority
shall you shall be able to do this you
can do this as opposed to you shall not
and then you know the enumerated items
below um just need further clarification
as to what direction to give to the
department for purposes of its
regulatory oversight i think of some
concern would be starting on line 12
under subparagraph roman 8 b
failing to protect now just put this in
perspective with the introductory clause
the department
or any other state agency shall not take
any action for healthcare our healthcare
facility for and and b it says for
failing to protect or otherwise ensure
the safety or comfort comfort of a
visitor given access to a property or
location controlled by the healthcare
facility and true we wouldn't be looking
necessarily as to individuals who are on
the property we'd be looking at the
facilities itself again but obviously
the focus on patient and in people's
safety it just it just raised the
question in terms of is this the uh what
the um
proponents for the bill really would
like to see in terms of not being able
to take action relative to individual
safety
and then paragraph c and again i'm
trying to be careful because we really
don't want to encroach upon those areas
from a regulatory oversight but if we
were requested to doing that you could
see where it would be problematic for
the department uh the next
item is under subparagraph roman 8c
starting in line 14 failing to follow
the guidelines for these
cdc and prevention or other federal
guidelines that require or recommend
restricted visitor access and uh as as
you know um you know that would be
something that would be contrary to what
the department's general missions and
goals are relative to
adherence to guidelines to protect
individuals so we just would ask for
further consideration about how that
would be drafted
in a more
taking the word not out in the
introductory and then identifying
specifically what it is you're looking
for the department either to do so with
that
that concludes my um
overview of the three areas that the
department
had concerns about but i just want to
emphasize again heartfelt
um
thoughts towards
miss representative rice and her family
and also that we are here as a resources
committee to
assist at as appropriate with
the language around the bill thank you
you
asked for questions
the committee services has texted me and
said they're going to do a research on
similar legislation either pending or
enacted in other states so we can have
comparisons on all of these things
thank you mr williams and it's always
good to see you again because you share
i wonder if some of your objections and
some of my concerns might be addressed
when we have on line eight of page two
unless expressly required by federal law
or regulation the department or any
other state state agency and i'll work
out the shell knots and shells later
because that's making my brain explode
at the moment but
uh shall not take any action
against a health facility for and what i
would like to add in is arising out of
this statute because there are lots of
other things that a health facility
might do
that we might all very much like the
apart department to take action about
and
then
so would that be okay and then i have a
follow-up
it would be okay okay
and then my follow-up is
i was very concerned about the failing
to protect or otherwise ensure the
safety or comfort of a visitor
but
isn't it true that
this section only applies to the
department so there would still be the
entire body of tort law available for
a visitor
whose um
safety has been interfered with so
they're not left without a remedy
is that true
that would be my understanding as well
okay and and would you
um would you be willing to forward me
the suggestion of how we get rid of the
shall not and make that into a shell
because i'm having a hard time
explaining how i say shall
and then
make it a positive shell but forbidding
you to do
i can say shall be forbidden to but i
don't see the difference between that
and shall not so if you have suggestions
i'd appreciate them thank you and
represent pearson you've just seen the
exercise of some of the difficulty that
needs to be worked out so we certainly
would be a resource to represent weber
um my initial thought would be that
typically in statute when it provides us
with regulatory oversight it is a we're
being provided with authority not told
what not not to do so it does it does
beg the question well what do we do and
why is this important to having in here
particularly if we don't have oversight
as you point out of those individuals uh
in terms of visitors and their safety so
calling it out here in these exceptions
pulls us more into that conversation and
perhaps you may even want to reconsider
the entirety of that section and what it
actually brings to the um to bear on the
goals of the underlying legislation does
it really add more or does it cause so
much confusion that it actually makes
more complicated the goals of access to
loved ones during their final stages of
life you and mr chair could i make a
question of the chair you may make
although before you do
i am going to
ask the members of this committee
to think about whether you'd like to be
on the amendment writing team
with
all kinds of nice friends and so on now
you may inquire the chair well i was
going to acquire the chair if the chair
would consider this bill to have an
actual proper subcommittee process
because it sounds to me that like there
are a lot of players here
and it's a very important concept
and
as one who very much appreciates all the
efforts of everybody on the various
and sundry ad hoc
teams
i'd really like to get this one right
for everybody and i wonder if you would
consider an appropriate subcommittee and
i'd certainly be glad to volunteer for
that thank you the chair and the
any other questions
for
representative williams well thank you
for coming don't be a stranger and thank
you for elevating me to the general
court jeremy pearson thank you
that was meant as a compliment and i
representative aaron would you like to
good morning chairman pearson and
members of the health and human services
committee it's good to see you all today
thank you so much for all your hard work
i'm here today to ask that you support
this bill hb 1439
this bill is an extremely important bill
and it is also very personal for me and
my constituents
from my own experience
this past october
my husband fell ill
and i had to take him to the emergency
room at dartmouth-hitchcock hospital in
keene
they would not allow me to accompany him
inside
because they had just instituted a code
red
which was a policy that did not allow
anyone but the patient inside the
hospital
i couldn't even sit and wait with him in
the waiting room
a waiting room by the way which had
other sick people in there waiting for
care
if i was already with my husband at home
then what sense was it to keep us apart
if the facility is worried about
transmission of an illness be it viral
or otherwise
they can certainly require accompanying
or visiting family members and loved
ones to wear the same ppe or protective
gear as a facility staff caring for
these patients daily do
those caregivers also go out to grocery
stores home to their loved ones and
other places after seeing patients all
day long
sensible accommodations can be made with
visitors and people accompanying family
to doctors offices or to emergency rooms
that was an awful feeling that i could
not be by my husband's side in his time
of need nor could i advocate for him
they made me wait outside the building
and they watched me like i was some sort
of criminal
i'd been caring for him at home and knew
all the particulars of his care
i had valuable observations that i could
share with those seeing and treating him
they would have none of it
i tried to reason with the people there
calling
calling the supervisor and spoke to
people in charge
but they refused to let me be my by my
husband's side
i'd never experienced anything like this
before in my life and i hope i never do
again it was frightening and went
against everything i had ever
experienced with the medical community
i was so scared
because i had no idea what was going on
or if i'd ever see my husband again
do you understand that
i'll say it again
i had no idea if i would ever see my
husband alive again
can you put yourself in that situation
for just a moment
can you imagine how that felt
what would you have done in that
situation
you feel helpless
and completely cut off
countless of people have been in that
situation
and it is not okay
to continue to allow that to happen
pandemic or no pandemic
thankfully my husband was fine and was
sent home after a half an
hour and a half of observation and
whatever tests they gave him
but i have a good friend of mine who
wasn't that fortunate
and she never saw her husband alive
again
he died a week and a half later in the
icu
with no one no loved ones there by his
side
they wouldn't even let her see him
or hold his hand when he died
she couldn't speak to him or communicate
with him during that time either since
we've had this same situation happen to
our elderly our mothers and fathers our
grandmothers and grandfathers
ending up dying alone in an
institutional setting
how is that okay
it's not
no one should be sick and be alone and
certainly no one should die alone
we cannot continue to allow this to
happen to families and loved ones it is
barbaric
and it is immoral to bar spouses and
family members from being with their
loved ones in times of crisis especially
when the person needing care doesn't
know what's going on or cannot make
medical decisions on their own
we cannot let this type of policy
continue to stand and i hope that you
will pass this bill out of your
committee
with an otp recommendation or add
whatever amendments you feel
you seem to you know feel fit to do
but
do it so no one has to live with the
anger the guilt or the lack of closure
that these policies create in families
in sickness and at the end of life
i appreciate you listening
and i'm happy to take any questions any
thank you so much thank you
chair calls paula minihan from the new
just
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is paula minihan
senior vice president state government
relations with the new hampshire
hospital association representing all
our hospitals in new hampshire
the hospital association has concerns
with this bill the bill before you would
establish in state law specific hospital
hospital visitation requirements with
limited exceptions
in reviewing this bill with our hospital
members and all understand and fully
appreciate the challenges individuals
have faced especially in the last couple
of years during the covid
19 pandemic
when they wanted to be with loved ones
that were being cared for in a hospital
the hospitals have learned a lot through
these last two years here in new
hampshire and nationally
regarding how visitation policies can
impact loved ones wanting to be with
their family member in the hospital
unfortunately due to the nature of the
pandemic and the lack of personal
protective equipment early in the
pandemic among other reasons the
hospitals had to limit visitors for
their safety as well as for the patients
they care for
their visitation policies were modified
to ensure patient staff and visitor
safety since then however many changes
have been made to allow for visitors and
designated caregivers to be present
under many circumstances
in addition to visitors being allowed to
be present when a patient was at their
end of life hospitals have allowances
for maternity labor and delivery
patients pediatric patients disabled
patients and outpatient procedures
federal centers for medicare medicaid
services cms conditions of participation
require hospitals to have a visitation
policy and the current hospital
visitation policies were developed by
compassionate individuals at our
hospitals the hospital's individual
policies established with clinical input
all are posted on their websites
and have been designed to balance
visitors access safety of all involved
and caring of compassion and support for
patients while they are in the hospital
of course visitor policies may vary
slightly by hospital for reasons such as
visiting hours
while our hospitals are asking what our
hospitals are asking is that they are
afforded the op the ability to implement
visitor policies that provide needed
flexibility
while balancing the very important needs
our of patients to have visitors and
caregivers by their side
i was told recently that a hospital had
to adjust their visitor policy twice in
one week due to the current coveted
surge that they were dealing with on top
of other high demand for inpatient care
for non-coveted patients
it is difficult to legislate that type
of flexibility
in addition there are other federal
requirements such as occupational safety
and health administration osha that
require screening of all those that
enter a hospital if a visitor is ill the
hospital is not allowed by law to let
them in the hospitals need to be allowed
to adjust their visitation policies
quickly depending on the changes in
circumstance in their hospital or in the
community
one other issue that's already been
noted by um
by john williams um is in reviewing this
bill the statute being modified actually
applies to both hospitals and nursing
homes and but the bill is silent
regarding nursing home visitor policies
but the bill is drafted if passed would
also include nursing homes it's unclear
if that was the intent of the sponsor
for these reasons the hospital
association is concerned about this bill
as drafted and we are certainly willing
to work with the sponsor to determine if
there is a way to amend this bill that
addresses the hospital's valid concerns
and i will say i have spoken with
representative rice numerous times
starting with when the lsr was issued so
she has been very open and willing to
chat with us and we appreciate that and
she agreed yes just yesterday to sit
down with us to talk further so we are
happy to continue those dialogues and i
think it's
important that those that have developed
these policies be part of the
working through what the um
what an amendment if an amendment um is
is introduced in this committee be
considered and thank you for the
opportunity to provide comments and
thank you for your testimony
representative canuck thank you very
much uh just a quick question
given the fact that a lot of the issues
that came up were about covert and as
you pointed out we did not know in the
beginning a lot of stuff we didn't know
the ppe
um and this bill in a sense is kind of a
public health bill because it has to do
with the public health
um
do you do you think that it is
not a good idea to
place in statute restrictions on how
one may respond to a public health
emergency
that i think is a valid concern and and
i think that that is maybe why um the
department raised some issues and why
hospital visitation policies have not
been in place um have
been in statute and um nationwide in
talking with my colleagues throughout
the country um very few states have
actually implemented
such policies to date
some have
worked on it but
i i think it'll be really interesting to
see what legislative services comes out
with legislative research because um
there are very few um so hospitals have
been around as you know for a long time
um and hospital visitation policies are
a requirement again of conditions of
participation and they have them and i
encourage everyone to go on the
hospital's websites because they do post
those
hospital visitation policies
and again they try to make exceptions
for
what i identified relative to end of
life um
a disabled individual those that need a
caregiver etc um labor and delivery um
but i think um there are real concerns
like you said representative relative to
um public health concerns that it would
be hard to it'll be difficult to try to
figure out how to
legislate that
representative shapiro thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
um giving your um
quite eloquent description of how
hospital
personnel come together to make these
how difficult it is
and how much effort is put into it
given that and given um line 14 on the
first page of the bill where
allowing limits or restrictions if the
presence of visitors would be medically
or therapeutically contraindicated
in the best
clinical judgment
of healthcare professionals which would
be the hospitals
um
i'm having a little difficulty seeing
where
[Music]
this would change anything
in terms of the process that's already
in place in healthcare facilities
um i that that line may not be a problem
but um other parts of the of the bill
are more um expansive so i i think we'd
have to go through every part of the
bill again um i've met with a lot of the
hospitals um
and that was the feedback i received
that this there are some
issues with this bill and as
representative rice um clearly and and
correctly stated this comes from
oklahoma the oklahoma hospital
association was involved
in drought in in amending this bill
quite significantly to what it is today
but that's oklahoma that is not new
hampshire um and i would um appreciate
and um expect and i think we will have a
new hampshire solution not an oklahoma
solution thank you
now because we are running very very
late here we're going to move on and the
final three speakers i have no more pink
cards and will not accept any more
representatives you each get two minutes
and the chair calls rusin chester from
thank you chair
thank you committee members um
i
want to
speak in support of this bill i actually
have a situation not covered related but
happened during the covet pandemic a
25-year-old mom
um she had had a c-section the month
before she was ill so she went back to
the emergency room her partner was not
allowed to go into the emergency room
with her
um
and um because of the current status
that she was the current condition that
her situation was in i suspect but i
don't know because no one went in with
her that she was not able to accurately
explain why she was presenting at the
emergency room
they gave her a prescription and sent
her on her way she collapsed in the
parking lot
her husband saw her collapse he
immediately took her to another hospital
by the time she got to the other
hospital she was declared brain dead
um
that's unacceptable
i now have
we now have four children
that have no mother
we now have a significant other that
feels somehow it was his fault
that he didn't take her to the other
hospital in the first place because he
knew
the potential of the of the limitations
and he chose to take her to the closest
one instead of the one that was the that
she wanted to go to
the bottom line here is is that i
understand the concerns i understand the
concerns with department of health and
human services i understand the concerns
but the bottom line is our hospitals
have become such a reactive situational
place
that i feel that a bill like this will
put some checks and balances on that
thank you
in two minutes wow
we'll make a video of this and show it
to others thank you so much
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman um just quickly i
i wanted to bring up um
to the to the last speaker but i can ask
you the question also um i'm just
reviewing the um
the new hampshire statute
on
residential care and health facility
licensing licensing that's 151 there's a
patient's bill of rights under there
and number uh
number roman numeral
where did it go
well first of all it says that patients
shall be free to communicate with
associate with and meet privately with
anyone including family
and
resident groups unless it would infringe
upon the rights of other patients
and
um it also says they'll be
entitled to have
there's already in statute something
about minors being entitled to have
um their spouse or i mean i'm sorry
their parents if they're a minor
and
for adults their spouse or next of kin
visit the facility without restriction
um especially if they're considered
terminally ill
um jump towards a question so i'm just
wondering do you think that
the practices that we're hearing about
today
are upholding that law that already
exists and and that that's why we need
to make it very clear to the hospitals
that under no circumstances can they
violate it thank you for the question uh
yes i agree that that that the patient's
rights should be
um more important than the
potential
ramifications of making it more
difficult for the facility uh but i also
think that it's very important that
they that our hospitals and healthcare
facilities cannot hide behind the guys
if it's an emergency so we don't have to
follow the rules thank you thank you and
thank you for your testimony
representative betty gay asks for two
minutes
these rules are harkening back to the
1920s in the hospitals uh i had an aunt
who was
20 years older than my mother who was a
nurse then and the rules there were
totally different from now president
eisenhower's first baby
died as they watched him in the house
through the windows in the hospital
because they were not permitted to be
so they ended up with one son after many
years but that heartbreak was
devastating
personally for me in a nursing home one
of my friends who was 97 dorothy died of
a broken heart according to her daughter
because she was not she wasn't even sick
at first but
the nursing homes were just shut down
you could not visit your your loved ones
and when finally her vitals went really
low they let her daughter come and spend
the last couple of days you know fully
gowned in ppe
with her but like my friend said mama
died of a broken heart
my sister-in-law in houston who's the
was the director of the the jewish
nursing
assisted living which is you know a
lovely place
where mama had lived
she had 102 year old
man resident
who was fine amazing
but then with this extended separation
from his family they called her at home
it was she happened to be at home when
they called her and said his vitals are
really dropping
well under the circumstances if they
were close to death they would allow the
family to come in
so
annette
ordered that
so the family came in
within four hours he was totally
recovered
i do see that there should be some rules
that the hospitals and the nursing homes
and all these places should be covered
by these rules
but i can see that you come up with
limitations of how many visitors you
what what they should be wearing
but this has been
criminal
of and damaging and it has killed people
but it doesn't have to kill people to
mean that it's essential
thank you representative the quality of
and finally the chair calls teresa
rosenberger
from new hampshire health care
association
thank you mr chairman welcome
members of the committee it's wonderful
to see you i'm theresa rosenberger i
work at bernstein shore and i'm here
representing the new hampshire hospital
association
as i think you've heard before this bill
includes nursing homes because 151 colon
the facility the licensed facilities
statute includes nursing homes if you
read the bill it talks about hospitals
and it talks about nursing homes and not
nursing homes health care facilities i
think as testified before we need to
clarify
with this bill exactly
what facilities we're talking about
secondly nursing homes are regulated and
have visitation guidelines put out by
cms of the federal government they
revised their regulations on november
12th of 21
and quote visitation allowed for all
residents at all times
so
with nursing homes now
visitation is allowed you can stay as
long as you want so i think
i'm not so sure that we need to be
included in this and and more
importantly i think as john williams was
talking about we need to make sure what
we're doing in new hampshire
it's not contrary to what people have as
rules and regs and they have to abide by
to be licensed with the fed so we need
to be careful about that
so that is really all i have to testify
question
representative
thank you and i'm sorry i had to step
out for a moment there but uh
did you give us written testimony and do
you have the site for cms
for that i even actually have the
document but i'll send it to you if you
would send it out that would be very
helpful thank you very much it was
revised and
in in november thank you very much
you're welcome be happy too you get an
extra 33 seconds the next time you come
here
thank you i'll note that
thank you thank you the chair would like
to ask representative weber if she would
chair this
work this bill into something that
representative weber is very reluctant
but yes yes she would and that's the
story
i will try and find
i've got a number of things going on at
the moment there was a yes in there
subject to defeasants yes
yes
would it be appropriate representative
weber then to ask right now who on this
committee would like to work with you
you may you may ask anything you want mr
well within reason
i don't always get it uh who would like
to work on this committee with
okay
um we'll be looking at hands here uh
maybe it would be easier uh
councillor williams to say it in the
negative
who wouldn't because i see so many hands
all right are we counting hands here i
no
that was actually a joke
representative cushman wood
representative kelsey representative gay
representative nutter upham dr makai
dr woods
and solo way
and did i miss anybody
good and the clerk is writing like
madden don't remember all the names you
said i remember them all
my good friends i got you yeah
mr chair
is is this an early bill
uh probably by the time we're done with
it no no it's not good that
life much easier
and
the
great number seven representative leon
lay on would like to be on
and with that
post
the hearing but go ahead
could i just make my usual observation
that
we in this room are all here because we
are representatives
we all have life experiences and
professional qualifications
but in this room we are representatives
we are not any of our other aspects of
our lives and should be addressed as
such thank you
okay
now
open the hearing on house bill
1384 establishing a committee to study
the need for child care and ways to
supplement and fund it in new hampshire
representative fenton prime sponsor sir
please present your bill i'll be brief
guys
thank you mr chairman and ladies and
gentlemen of the committee
i am representative donovan fenton and i
represent keane
i'm here to talk to you about hb 1384
which is establishing a committee to
study the need for child care and ways
to supplement it and fund it in new
hampshire and i will be brief because we
are talking about a study committee and
i know how much we all love those
so i came up with this bill because i
have a small business and i lost
employees during the pandemic i'm proud
to say we didn't lose anyone because
business was slow but we lost them
because they had to stay at home and
take care of their children
parents can't find or afford child care
right now in new hampshire
this is the real data right now there's
an 87 staff shortage for child care
centers and there's a 58 long wait list
wages of child care professions are
causing recruitment issues which in turn
are closing these centers
when parents can't find child care for
their children they turn down job offers
and i'll let you know this is a real
thing i have my hr department work on
locating child care for new employees
and a lot of times we can't find any
openings and we lose that potential
employee
we need to get these parents back to
work
these are the issues that keep parents
out of the workforce and they are the
backbone to new hampshire's economy
my hope for this bill is to study and
find creative ways whether it be through
grants federal funding programs you name
it that will help alleviate this issue
and this is an issue that's only going
to get worse until we address it
i thank you for your time and i'll try
to answer any questions there were a
couple of child care experts that were
going to testify but they have coveted
so they won't be here so
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
i have heard and maybe you can confirm
this so the question is can you confirm
these numbers i've heard because demand
and supply
is uh is unbalanced right now that some
peop some parents are paying as much as
1200 a month to send their child to
child care
absolutely uh thank you for the question
representative i can confirm that
because i pay 1100 for one child to go
thank you anyone else with uh yes
representative shapiro thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking the question i wholeheartedly
agree that this is a serious problem
that may not be
um answered by the
free market and so we have to think
about how we can
make something else happen
and i'm just wondering in terms of
creating a study committee if you know
if this
effort to
analyze the problem come up with new
ideas come up with solutions if this
overlaps with any other efforts
currently going on
through state government yeah absolutely
thanks for the question representative
um
dhhs offers a
scholarship program for low-income
individuals that's a certain program
there's also another bill in the senate
but i don't presume or assume what the
senate does um
and i you know this
i don't think there's a
right now we have a band-aid for a
shotgun wound in my opinion you know
these grants these child care
scholarships they help but
this issue is still happening so my hope
for this bill is that you know we come
out with multiple legislation or one
great piece of legislation that will fix
follow-up yeah really my question was
not about scholarships or efforts to
help
but
i was talking about if it overlaps with
other efforts to study the issue
thank you again for the question there
was a similar bill to this uh that got
lost in the covid translation um
i believe casey cohn representative
connolly sponsored it but
we all know what happened kind of to a
lot of our bills so it's very similar to
that but the bill again
disappeared
i have uh
it's going to try to be a question but
um
those of us in committee leadership are
being told
by both
the speaker's office and senior
democratic leaders
that we're running out of people to go
on these committees i'm one that is
regularly asked by the speaker not just
for health issues but for numbers of
issues to fill committees and i'm
finding it getting extremely difficult
because people are turning me down
either they don't want to do this at
this time or they're already doing it in
five other committees and
every time i get asked i find it gets
more and more difficult i hear that from
my colleagues on the other side as well
we are being instructed to kill this
bill not because it's your bill and not
because it's not needed
but because we can't make it happen
and my question to you is
would it
be
an alternative to
grab an ad hoc group of people
stakeholders interested parties
as well including legislators if you can
find them and come up with something
that would make a wonderful lsr next
summer
thank you for the question mr chairman
um you know i agree i hate being on
study committees especially during the
summer time um and but i think we're
doing a big disservice to our
constituents um by killing this bill
as i said this issue isn't going to go
away like an ad hoc is a great idea um
you know i'd be happy to volunteer for
the study committee um and i'm sure i
can wrangle some other folks too as well
but i understand your concerns and i've
been told that as well that you know
like don't pitch a study committee but
it's just
you know i don't want to put the cart
before the horse and i think a study
committee is necessary for this such a
prevalent issue the question my
follow-up the question is not is a
committee to study this necessary
i run a healthcare organization i have
health
child care issues a lot with my staff
it's very needed the question is what's
the best vehicle to do it is it
the
three members of the house and three
members of the senate
or is it a group you can gather together
to study it
and then bring back some specifics
um as early as next
fall that's my question only and it's um
i hope it comes across as an honest
question because it is oh no absolutely
and i completely understand the concerns
um my fear for that is
a non-mandatory
group of people might not always show up
and might not always be present
and it's much easier having the state
legislature behind you when you're
recruiting these professionals to come
in and speak and these experts um you
know that's why i think the study
committee is so much more prudent than
an ad hoc but i i completely understand
your concerns um and that is a that's an
issue
okay this is not a question but kind of
a statement sure if the bill passes i'm
going to hold you to help me i'm going
representative acton
thank you mr chair uh real quick um
and thank you representative um
uh would you believe that i was on a
study committee similar to this about
two years ago
and we uncovered many things that needed
to be looked into further
and i would also say that in regards to
an ad hoc committee there are a lot of
people that will volunteer to help you
if if you need to pull something like
that if this doesn't move forward
we should communicate there's there's
activists within the um
the community and there's there's a
lawyer that represents so there's a lot
of smart people out there that want to
move forward on this issue so i just
wanted to let you know that oh no and i
again i completely agree the whole the
whole reason for the study was just
you know to kind of handcuff you to
showing up and going you know
volunteers are fantastic but i
um
i've been in positions before where i've
had volunteers not show up and i'm just
fearful of that
but i completely agree
representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative uh would you believe that
even on study committees people are not
mandated to show up and it's very hard
to get a quorum and a lot of times
they don't even meet the requirements of
the rsa because they're not able to get
a quorum and finish and publish their
reports
i would absolutely believe that i've
been on study committees during the
summer times and they're not fun and
some people don't show up
and again i'll just echo what i kind of
said earlier it's uh
having the force but with the
legislature behind this bill means a lot
i think and especially to a lot of
experts and organizations you know i
think they
uh will play a bigger hand in it um the
ad hoc committee is certainly a
fantastic idea and i completely agree
with that especially if this doesn't
pass you know we'd certainly go without
it um
but like i said i think you know i truly
believe the study community beneficial
however you guys this bill is in your
hands so i i'll leave it to you
thank you mr chair and thank you very
much for taking my question it's always
is not
the point
that
members of the public
and associations interested in a
particular matter
get notice of when and where
a particularly important matter is to be
taken up and so
it enables the participation of people
that we might not think of when creating
say a commission or something like that
simply because notice is being published
in the house calendar
thank you for the question and yes um
you know they get published in the house
calendar
uh you select a chair um you get regular
emails through your legislative email
account um
some you get paid mileage for which is
also fantastic and lucrative um but no
no i completely agree and
again my
i'd really like this to be i really like
bipartisan legislation to come out of
this bill that's why it's you know it's
a bipartisan bill with the study
committee the speaker would appoint
those members and i think we could get
some really good bipartisan bills out of
anyone else representative gay
surprise
i don't know how to okay i have a
feeling
that this may be the new way to get uh
interested parties on committees instead
of assigning them have ad hoc committees
but also
see if
we could get them noted no
noticed in the calendars because i also
sympathize since i want a committee too
but i figure
like like representative acton said
there are people who are interested so
hopefully
if we can have that policy that we could
get the
meetings noticed we could do that and
draw the people who are really
interested and passionate about it
and thank you representative i
completely agree and maybe we could ask
for volunteers before we start a draft
anyone else
thank you so much thank you guys
thank you and with that we closed the
open the hearing on hello house bill
1608 requiring the department of health
and human services to contact certain
individuals whose information was
included in the state immunization
registry and if you're going to send me
pink cards this is a great time to do it
the prime sponsor has contacted me and
said that he needs to be in boston at
this time but someone will fill in for
i think we have a filling in for
and to uh representative
welcome you know i mean this this is we
have
are you filling in for representative
proud
thank you
is this hi
okay
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record i am um
melissa blasik i represent hillsborough
21 the town of merrimack i am here to
introduce hb
1608 fn
gotta catch my breath
i just ran in here okay uh this bill is
a follow-up to emergency order 76 issued
by the governor during the covet 19
state of emergency
this order suspended the opt-out
provision of the immunization registry
for the coven 19 vaccine and made the
government collection of data on private
citizens mandatory if they wanted to
receive the covet 19 vaccine
the order has expired but the
immunization registry retains the data
collected that we don't know if the
individuals wanted the state to have
retaining private data on individuals
without their consent implicates the
right to privacy article that the people
of new hampshire recently approved with
81 percent in favor
so this bill tries to find a solution to
the problem by having the department of
health and human services reach out to
individuals and asked and ask them if
they want the state to retain their data
and in absence of that belated
permission would eventually delete it
while the individuals could submit a
form to withdraw their participation
is the option to withdraw which almost
no one knows about enough
the existing dhhs rules suggest it has
not been considered enough in the past
he-p 307.06
is specific that each patient must be
made aware of their option to opt out
opting out is not an obscure provision
of state law and rules that one must
know about to exercise we require that
they be explicitly asked the question be
made aware of the choice
we should apply the same standard to
this situation and say that an option to
withdraw is not that is not widely known
is not enough
we need to either know that the
individual was asked the question
provided the opportunity to say no you
may not keep my private data and admit
that the state has no business retaining
their private medical information if we
don't
thank you for your time i'll be happy to
take any questions
representative folsom
just a quick question sorry
which emergency order number was that
seeing no further questions thank you
and
what's your is that's your daughter this
is my daughter this is natalie hi
natalie
[Music]
and abby rogers
good morning representative pearson and
members of the committee my name is abby
rogers i'm the legislative liaison for
good morning chairman pearson and
members of the committee my name is
i'm the immunization section chief
for the department of health and human
services division of public health and
thank you very much for allowing us to
be here today
i'm here to provide testimony in
opposition of hb 1608 relative to
requiring the department of health and
human services to contact certain
individuals whose information was
included in the state immunization
registry
an immunization information system iis
also known as an immunization registry
is an electronic system used to track
administration of vaccines an iis
contains vaccine records for individuals
and other vaccine ordering and
management information
it offers numerous benefits to public
health agencies health care providers
and individuals and is a key component
of immunization best practices
recommended by the centers for disease
control and prevention
the department of health and human
services is in opposition of hb 1608 as
the legislation as written is
contradictory to current rules and puts
patient safety at risk as we continue to
navigate the unpredictable turbulence of
the deadly pandemic
under emergency order number 76 the
state of new hampshire acted as a
medical provider
through the issuance of a standing order
for the administration of covet 19
vaccines at our state-run sites
as such vaccine recipient information
was collected in a manner similar to
vaccination in a primary care provider
office pharmacy or other location
as this is not a typical function of the
department and the agency does not have
an electronic medical record
the state's iis was used in the same
fashion as an electronic medical record
to document vaccine administration
the new hampshire board of medicine
rules state the licensee shall retain a
complete copy of all patient medical
records for at least seven years from
the date of the patient's last contact
with a licensee unless before that date
the patient has requested that the file
be transferred to another health care
provider
based on the board of medicine rules
this proposed legislation would
contradict the obligation of a provider
to
preserve the standard of documentation
of the vaccine administration
this information should not be removed
for the iis
as is proposed by this bill as there is
no other record of documentation
hb 1608 would require the department to
contact individuals who were not given
an opportunity to opt out of having
their coveted vaccine information
included in the state's registry
there were approximately 790 000
individuals immunized prior to the
expiration of this emergency order on
june 11 2021.
our analysis provided in the fiscal note
worksheet for hb 1608
outlined a breakdown of costs and
logistical challenges of implementation
the language in the bill does not
specify a method of contact but
regardless of which method is preferred
the department would need to hire
additional personnel to make phone calls
and or mail letters
and based on the existing contract
with a call center the department
estimates it would send spend an
estimated 6.2 million dollars over the
course of the six-month period proposed
by this legislation to reach 790 000
residents
it's estimated that the cost of postage
and staffing needed to mail the letters
to each household would exceed eight
hundred thousand dollars
not included in this fiscal impact
analysis are the expenses anticipated to
be incurred in order to manually remove
the information from the iis
the department would need to pay for
staffing beyond six months in order to
complete the removal process of those
who were not
reached and did not respond to the
attempts to contact
the anticipated cost of staffing this
part of the project is two hundred sixty
seven thousand dollars for every one
hundred thousand names being removed
from the iis
it's also estimated to take at least six
thousand six hundred seventy five hours
to delete one hundred thousand records
if this legislation becomes law the
department would need staffing resources
and additional time to complete this
project the department estimates 45
staff members working full time for one
month would be required for each 100 000
records deleted
while the actual number of records to be
removed is indeterminable the department
anticipates a high number of
non-respondents
this could be as high as 78 percent
based on the department's experience
with other outbound call initiatives
we tried to contact 46
104 vaccine recipients to verify the
information after multiple attempts to
contact our overall response rate was
22.5 percent
reasons for low response may include
incorrect contact information due to
change of address or phone number phones
being disconnected and ignoring attempts
to contact due to the concerns that the
outreach was a scam
if this effort produces a similar low
response rate
it's estimated that the cost could could
easily jump up to 1.6 million dollars to
remove more than 600 000 names
if this bill were to become law
funds to cover both the contacting of
the recipients and removal of the
records would need to be made through an
additional appropriation
it's not just the challenges of
implementing this bill and the financial
burden it presents but we also oppose
house bill 1608 because it would give
the state the authority to arrest erase
vaccination information if after three
attempts to contact an individual
results in the non-response
under administrative rule hep 307 o6 the
choice to opt out is sole responsibility
of the patient
not the decision of the state
this bill assumes a non-response equals
consent when in fact there is no
informed consent if a patient is unable
to be contacted
this goes against patient privacy and
the standard of patient care that people
currently when individuals receive a
vaccination from the state and choose to
opt out of the registry their vaccine
information is recorded on paper
as the opportunity to opt out was
suspended under the emergency order no
option of a paper record was provided
this will be problematic for individuals
for whom all data will be deleted by
this proposed legislation
if that individual loses his or her
vaccination card this is the only hard
copy of their record they will have no
proof of vaccination because they no
longer exist in the registry
their information is irretrievable
the department is receiving calls
emails
daily from people who are asking how
they can replace their vaccination card
fortunately this is a simple process for
those who can choose to keep their
information in the registry
they can not only replace the card but
they can also don download a copy of the
vaccination record through the patient
portal
in the last six months alone thirty one
thousand two hundred seventy nine people
have requested their vaccination records
through either the patient portal in
writing or by calling 2-1-1
the department is committed to patient
privacy
following the end of the emergency order
dphs has educated health care providers
and vaccinators and established
protocols to ensure that no patient
records should be entered without the
opportunity to opt out of the iis
to date
a total number of 20 individuals out of
the approximate
thousand
who have received the coven 19 vaccine
under the emergency order have requested
for the information to be withdrawn from
the ias despite communicating that
option through medical providers vaccine
clinics posting it on the dhhs website
nationally the current opt-out rate for
vaccine registries is just 5 to 10
percent according to the american
immunization registry association
furthermore the iis data has proven to
be a vital tool in new hampshire's
public health response to covid19 in
determining vaccination coverage
providing equitable access to the
vaccines and identifying any gaps in the
response
under emergency order 76 the department
was
acting as the medical provider for those
who received the vaccine prior to june
11th the ias was used in the same
fashion as the emr removing these
records now would have a significant
fiscal impact and more importantly would
place patient safety at risk by
eliminating all medical records for
vaccination
thank you so much for the opportunity to
speak today i'm happy to answer any
questions you may have
thank you i missed the number of people
who had asked to opt out and i wonder if
you had written testimony and if so has
it
is are there any extras anywhere that
anybody sees because i missed one
thank you the testimony was emailed to
you as well this morning oh okay thank
you
any other questions representative
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
in the beginning your testimony you
mentioned that this would be a threat to
patients can you elaborate on that a bit
more please sure well if these records
are removed they will not have any
record in existence during the emergency
order because it was suspended we used
the ias as their electronic medical
record therefore we collected the
information that was needed for
documenting the vaccine
in the iis if a patient should need to
have their record after it's removed or
if we needed to contact them for any
reason
so if there was any information that
came up about a specific lot number or
recall we would not have that
information to be able to give to the to
the person in addition if anyone needed
their record for subsequent doses they
would not have that record to
demonstrate what their minimal time
intervals between dosing would be
because that record would not be in
existence so therefore any provider who
goes to give subsequent doses is not
going to be able to find their record of
previous doses unless that person kept
that one piece of paper that was
provided to them at the time of
vaccination
are you willing to accept that that some
people may be scared of getting their
name on those lists giving the the
rather vicious treatment of unvaccinated
we have people getting put in intern
internment camps in australia we have
people right in
a few hours to the north of us and
canada being denied
entry into food stores
because of their vaccine status even if
they're masked or not
are you willing to accept that
i think that the failure to keep these
records is more hazardous than having
the information in but we also do agree
that people should have the
responsibility and ownership of having
that information it is their information
to have if they should choose to
withdraw their information we would be
happy to assist them with that and that
process is fairly simple to go ahead and
do
we are getting the information out more
and more about
opt-out about the ability to withdraw so
people do have the right to go ahead and
do that they would just need to know
that
they would need to transfer the record
to their health care provider or they
would need to keep their copy
what we do want to prohibit or
make difficult would be the arbitrary
removal of the vaccination records of
those people who were not able to be
contacted so this legislation if after
six months they were unreached we would
be required to remove those records and
and that would be a significant problem
for those people who just were not aware
that their record was being
yes representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so um just so that
i'm clear this database is separate then
like a pharmacy a pharmacy database
where somebody would get their
immunization from
so
would the pharmacy then not have that
information if they lost their card
the pharmacy would have that information
only if they accessed it through the ias
i see the far
i should correct that
if a location such as a pharmacy had
their own record
and they were not connecting that
information to the is the pharmacy would
go ahead and do that under the emergency
order the majority of the people who
were vaccinated were vaccinated at
state-run sites they were not vaccinated
at another location so therefore those
records don't exist elsewhere if you
were vaccinated in your primary care
office
if you were vaccinated in a pharmacy
those locations should maintain your
record separately from the iis thank you
representative snow
as a person who
has been stung
by
email and telephone requests for
information
or
response on something
i automatically don't pay the attention
i just hang up on the call and don't pay
any attention whatsoever to the record
and i have a feeling that a lot of the
people who
might wish to have their records
maintained
are going to lose out on the opportunity
to do that because
like me they don't want to get
into another situation where somebody's
after the other information and
got some money i had my i had my entire
computer system shut down once because
good call like this and the demand for a
huge amount of money which fortunately i
was able to get out from under but it
was a terrible ordeal and now i just
refuse to do and i think there's a lot
of people out there just like me who are
doing that so i think it's foolish to
assume you're going to have any good
outcome you're going to have a whole lot
of people that just won't respond you're
going to end off the list and then
they're going to be done mad
that they thought they had a record
that they were free and if they have to
get kicked out of a drug store or a
grocery store they assume they had a
record and they don't have one
and
anyway enough sad that was good
that wasn't a question but you can
respond to it i'm sorry oh that's all
right i know what you meant would you
believe i know you meant that
thank you very much for your comment we
would agree based on our experience
we've only had about a 22 response rate
so therefore we feel as though
approximately 600 000 people would be
having their records deleted arbitrarily
by this law
so that would be great significance
especially if an individual needed their
vaccination proof record for
for their work
you know
representatives
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
so
my question is do you
would you be amenable
um would the department be amenable to
changing the bill to make it so that one
letter
is sent to everyone who had their
information entered into the system and
informing them that they have a right to
withdraw their information
so that they are presented and you know
that it goes to each individual
we could go ahead and do the letter but
once again the information that we have
at the state is only as accurate as what
was provided us at the time that they
were vaccinated if someone moves they
don't necessarily
meet that does not necessarily translate
to they received
the letter and i guess my question would
be i'm not sure exactly what you're
asking to have in the letter or if we
would automatically
withdraw people if there was a
non-respondent so i would have to have a
little bit more clarity on that
follow up
thank you
uh so
the the letter could say you know what
section two of the bill says except it
could say
uh indicate
you know below if you would like to have
your information withdrawn
and then
you could withdraw it if you receive the
letter
and um
and my follow-up question is
uh oh um so
we have a constitutional right in the
state of new hampshire to privacy and
our constitutional right was
sort of unconstitutionally removed and
this information was taken from people
without the opportunity to opt out and
that's question of the constitutionality
and legality of that is questionable and
so i think that
every attempt like sending a letter even
if all of the information is just as
accurate as it was
when you know the addresses as when the
people received the vaccination is still
you know something that the state should
do would you agree
in the interest of privacy and
i saw you gearing up
thanks for the question representative
cushman i just wanted to reiterate that
through emergency order 76 dhs ghhs had
executed a data sharing agreement with
the cdc to protect any identifiable data
and the identifiable data
was made available to the cdc and other
agencies for
reconciling and tracking the covet 19
vaccination um and we certainly were
very um uh stringent about preserving
and protecting
personal health information um as far as
your question goes um again as ann
um stated it will be difficult to to
send a letter it wouldn't be difficult
to send a letter but we couldn't we
couldn't guarantee that everybody that
we sent the letter to based on the
limited information that we were given
at the time of vaccination um would be
received and responded to and we still
would be responsible for then um you
know removing information from someone
who didn't either receive the letter or
didn't have a chance to to um to respond
emergency
um
to outreach we do have a withdrawal
process in place currently and that
information is available on our website
um i think we would have to look at
again we could amend our fiscal note to
see what that would cost us to be aware
of that but i think we could have
further conversations about that thank
you
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
the question uh with this i would like
to clarify that you would be we could
talk about having an amendment where it
would clarify that it's providing that
withdrawal language that you already
have one time to the best information
that's available on your records nobody
would be withdrawn but doing this as a
specific targeted outreach would that be
something to discuss
i think that we would be open to that
the cost of sending a single letter was
just over eight hundred thousand dollars
so if state appropriations were made
available to us we could go ahead for
the informational purposes of letting
people know that they have the right to
withdraw
the concern once again would be if we
were forced to withdraw if there's a
non-respondents
representative gay
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um i have two two questions so i'll ask
them together and you can answer them
how you like
what data besides which shots people had
do you need
for
analysis
and the other is specifically
how do you
thank you very very much for that
question so the information that is
obtained with the vaccination would be
similarly to when you're receiving a
vaccine in your doctor's office so
they're asking your demographic
information
whether you've had any contra
indications to receiving the vaccination
so that we could administer that vaccine
safely
it also gives us the dates of those
vaccines so that we can look at the
minimal intervals
to make sure that subsequent doses are
administered at proper times for the
most
efficacious dosing
as far as your second question
um please repeat because i'm in the
moment listening to you
how do you how does one
what what is your website our process
okay thank you very much um so our
process to withdraw from the ias we do
have a letter
that is in
under our administrative rules to be
able to withdraw from the iis it simply
is stating that you wish to have your
information withdrawn
and that information will go to the ias
i'm sorry follow-up one follow-up
exactly how does one what is the website
what is the link
where do you do this yeah so
you would go to the dhhs
website
and there is information there on how to
withdraw and i can get that exact link
okay i'm sorry
okay
dhhs
serves more people than anybody else in
the whole state
i want to know the exact link and i'm
hoping it's on the home page
i i can get that link for you it is on
yeah thanks representative gay we can
certainly provide you with the link but
if you went to the if you went to the
home page of dhhs and looked up
immunization registry you would find the
link that you would need
and you will email this wonderful
committee
the exact steps absolutely
and thank you for your testimony the
chair now recognizes
paula minihan from the new hampshire
hospital association i no longer call
her our old friend she is our friend of
some standing
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee again my name is paula minihan
senior vice president state government
relations new hampshire hospital
association representing all our
hospitals in the state we are opposed to
hb 1608
and there are a number of problems with
this bill
there are there were many emergency
orders issued by the governor during the
state of emergency declared on march 13
there were a total of 90 emergency
orders that were issued subsequent to
the declaration and imagine if all those
emergency orders were subsequently
reviewed questioned resulted in
legislation to challenge the decision
made during the state of emergency we
would be we contend that this would
cause chaos
we were under a state of emergency and
actions were taken to protect the
citizens of new hampshire including
obtaining life-saving covid19 vaccines
from the federal government
and as stated in the fiscal note drafted
by dhhs there were approximately not 790
individuals that chose to obtain a
vaccine
during this that time that was in place
the requirements of the cdc the federal
agency responsible for issuing vaccines
to states was to ensure that the
individuals receiving the vaccine be
included in the registry for safety and
efficacy reasons
using the vaccine registry to document
vaccines administered to individuals can
help to keep patient vaccination data
records to date and give all medical
providers that care for patients across
to access to complete and accurate
information about the patient's
immunization record as
indicated by anne-marie and um and abby
from the department
from a practical perspective requiring
dhhs to reach out to all these
individuals that received the cobia 19
during vaccine during the state of
emergency time period to ask if they
want to opt out for the registry is
simply impractical and very time
consuming not to mention expensive we
should not be expending limited state
resources on this effort
from a clinical perspective a complete
vaccine vaccine registry is an important
tool to ensure that health care
providers have access to a patient's
full vaccination history to make
informed clinical decisions for their
patients for these reasons we are
opposed to this bill and on behalf of
our hospitals we urge you to find this
inexpedient to legislate thank you for
the opportunity
representative soloway thank you mr
chairman miss millehan it's nice to see
you nice to see you again
um would you believe
that there has in fact a study been done
in another state
of the efficacy
of tracing vaccine recipients
and using that data to make policy
decisions
that research which is not yet published
and whose author i cannot name i regret
but will be published i will guarantee
you
indicates that the effort on the part of
a state government i won't identify the
state
was it produced totally completely and
utterly dirty data
because
it was
impossible to contact people telephone
numbers were inaccurate addresses were
inaccurate people declined to respond
and the individuals collecting the data
fudged it
and
the completed quote-unquote dirty data
then went to state government with
directives to create policy based on the
data
and
they went to the media with false and
dirty data it was a complete fiasco
the research was submitted to
a paper competition
and won the outstanding paper of the
year award
and
will be published
um i'm one of the judges in the contest
which is the only reason i know about it
um so
would you believe that this could be
that big a waste
of new hampshire resources to wind up
i believe you especially since you were
my professor at unh i will not disagree
i've i've learned i've learned
at which place you learn to trust him as
you are you saying
we go way back
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question uh i i just want to
understand from your testimony does
would you be opposed to the notification
of people's ability to opt out so that
they could make sure that they are
comfortable with having their
information in the database or not
um i think we'd have to see what the
amendment looks like and again the
fiscal note i
i am concerned about again spending um
expending i should say um state
resources um on on this effort um but um
i believe um because of the work i do
that the opt out provision is very clear
and the author of helping us to create
the opt out is sitting in the audience
so i i do believe that we have made it
very clear there have been some
impediments to trying to get the vaccine
registry up and running and getting the
opt out to be effective um unfortunately
but and that has um has been i believe
has been a detriment to our our citizens
um but um i'd have to see what the
amendment looks like before i could
comment
thank you representative folsom
thank you chairman pearson thank you for
taking my question it's a very simple
one when people filled out their
information did they by any chance also
provide email addresses
i do not know um and i was one of them
because i got a vaccine at the state
site so i don't remember if i gave i was
trying to remember this morning as i was
driving in i may have i may have i
probably did
representative weber says i probably did
so um i
that's my answer
it probably
so that would be
one way of reducing the costs if you
followed up by way of emails
that's another
consideration certainly again um i think
that's those are all good suggestions
for the committee to consider
thank you very much thank you and the
last pink card the honorable neil kirk
of where and sir it's an honor to sit in
the chair that you occupied for quite
some time
thank you mr chairman that was another
committee
no no you were finance right that's
right this is health and human services
as i understand but i'm sitting in the
chair
sitting in your chair
thank you for recognizing me mr chairman
and for the record i'm neil kirk i live
i
i'm very concerned about the opt out ms
minihan was very generous in saying that
i authored it but
there were a great many people involved
in that and i was one of them but
that's about as much credit as i'll take
uh
i have a problem with this bill it's
very expensive and you don't get much
for your money
um
i did not give my email address i did
not give my telephone number
as you might expect i'm concerned about
privacy so i give as little information
as possible and i'm sure there were many
others like me so
as you suggested
representative hulsel
that probably would not cover a great
many people
moreover
i think we all know the principle of
inertia
and one of the facts of life is that
people don't
move unless they're forced to
so if you send out notices you're very
likely to get a very limited response
even if you sent them to every single
person in the state and they were
actually received
it's just not the way we work as human
beings
to spend somewhere according to the
fiscal note between a million three and
seven million to
do this seems to me to be a waste of
taxpayers money whether it's federal
money or state money i pay out of both
pockets
i have another suggestion i have an
amendment mr chairman if i may pass it
out you may
and we are going to be putting an
amendment committee together
on this under the chairmanship of
representative leon
and others from this committee who may
eventually
this amendment basically
is designed to
provide a compromise between the
information that the department needs to
do decent public health work
and the privacy interests of citizens
that the department will erase
all of the personally identifiable
information that means name and address
not city
not the type of vaccine you got not the
date that you got it none of those
things
without consulting anyone they will do
it as a matter of statutory obligation
if this amendment were to be adopted
that would put all of us back to the
situation that we were in prior to the
emergency order 76
that would mean that no one would have
to opt out everyone would be opted out
so we would be back to where we were now
like all proposals including those which
this committee ultimately adopts there
are going to be trade-offs
if this amendment were to be adopted it
would make it impossible for anyone to
call the vaccine registry and say help
i've lost my information
please give me what you have it wouldn't
be there
and that could be problematic for people
but that's one of the prices that we pay
in this case in this approach
to give the department the information
they need to do public health research
and yet balance that with privacy
interests so they don't know
the names and addresses of the people
who got vaccinations
there are many other ways that you could
go with this and i'm sure mr chairman
with your
amendment committee you will come up
with something but it will be a balance
you will have to give up some things
including privacy in order to get some
other things
but i would ask you not to impose upon
the department an obligation which
really um
is not going to be productive and that
is to notify people it doesn't work
decide one way or another which way you
want to go and do what you can to solve
it
one other thing that you might consider
is this
it's not the best thing
but it would be for the department to
mount a pr campaign and i don't mean
something where you send a letter to an
individual
i mean a massive pr campaign
website their website of course that
tells people
that they have 30 days or 60 days to opt
out
and if they want to do that all they
have to do is send the department a
letter you don't have to have a doctor
signature you don't have to do anything
fancy like in some cases the department
through its forms require you to do to
opt out making it almost impossible as a
practical matter to opt out or at least
so
burdensome that many people who would
like to opt out just will not go through
that approach requires good faith on the
departed department which i think you
can count on
but it would give everybody real notice
that they can opt out
and those people who are concerned about
it will fill out a little form hi my
name is neil kirk date of birth blank
blank blank my address is such and such
kindly opt me out
i don't have to have it notarized
i don't have to have my doctor sign
i don't have to do anything i can take
an ordinary piece of paper and i can do
it by mail
if i don't want to give away my email
address so i don't have to do it on
their website
or i can do it on their website whatever
you want but giving everybody an option
to do it a clean way that's another way
to do it
probably a decent compromise but the
amendment that i put before you is one
thing i'd like you to consider
good luck mr chairman thank you and i'd
be pleased to answer any questions if
there are any representative connect ask
representative
kirk yes exactly i was nice to see my
doppelganger um so yes i have a question
that's that's only that's only a name
certainly not in physique
hey come on we're the same size uh we
had katowski going that one day um so
here's my question and what you just
said that proposal because it's just
because i had written the same thing
down just a massive public education
thing for opting out
my question is would you then
if we did that
you would not
have the automatic deletion yes
if you do in a massive pr campaign you
don't need the automatic deletion
the information would stay in the
registry except for those people who in
response to the campaign
said
that answered my question thank you very
much
did i see representative webber's hand
up
you did thank you mr chairman
uh
can you imagine the harm to all of the
people who assume that their records are
being kept and who are glad that their
rep
records are being kept because they're
not very good rep
record keepers themselves
who assume that a registry will keep
their records and find when their dog
eats their vaccination cards that there
is no longer any way of documenting
[Music]
their vaccination records
and
the impacts on people's lives of that
if this amendment were to go through
unannounced
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative uh i have a question
about the pr campaign is this something
where we could have both a tv ad social
media on the website and then possibly
do an every door direct mailing i'm
seeing we could do it as low as 27 cents
a postcard just to also hit everybody at
their house would that seem to be a more
reasonable way to reach out instead of
individually contacting those who are on
the registry already i like everything
you said except for the postcard
and
the reason is
too many people ignore it and it's too
expensive it's the the cost-benefit
ratio i think is just not worth doing
that but everything else probably is
worthwhile
thank you very much
thank you mr chairman and good luck to
all of you
would you be interested in helping our
amendment committee i'd be glad to serve
if asked
you've been asked and you've been served
let me know when it meets thank you sir
thank you
and who else from this committee would
like to serve on the committee to come
up with an amendment
and gay
okay
all right that's a good start if you uh
suddenly
decide to you can let
and with that i closed the hearing on
fn and
we had planned
at one o'clock for representative woods
to make a presentation on the question
of what is science
and it's not obligatory although i'm
certainly not going to miss it
we've heard the term science invoked all
over the place
often incorrectly
and he and i
three four weeks ago had a conversation
on well what exactly is science and i
thought his answer was masterful so i
said would you make a presentation to
the committee for our edification so
that's at one o'clock if you wish to be
here you certainly may the next hearing
will start as advertised at 1 20. we're
um
great
good
oh
no you asked the question in the reverse
order it is while i'm eating me i listen
well
this topic came up and i must confess i
don't recall the exact discussion
that the chair and i had relative to
what is science so i hope i'm hoping i
am covering what he had in mind
um
just uh
this is a sort of a general perspective
of mine
um
sort of uh uh
jeff's not here but uh i he's he always
uh
gives me a hard time about talking from
the 30 000 foot level and this is
probably a hundred thousand foot level
uh but uh hopefully it'll stimulate uh
some thinking and just give a
perspective on
of um
my take on science uh just a very quick
background um i went to berkeley you
know a little school on the west coast
from being from california
in physics and then did my graduate work
in biophysics at hopkins
before i went to medical school and
had maintained over the years
a close uh relationship with things like
nanotechnology
uh and served on ama's council on
science and public health uh
and a variety of other things and uh my
uh i i've enjoyed a lot of it and it's
uh interesting to see the progress of
science
well what is and isn't science um
uh in a sense i i can do this in a
sentence
science is
a social cultural construct used to
engage our environment
science isn't
an ethical or moral guide
there that's what science is what
science isn't thank you very much we
please go on
um i'd like to expand on this a little
bit and
try to put a little bit of perspective
on what i think of science
um
introduce it with a quote from eo wilson
who's a
well-known scientist and
his quote he
made the observation
that humans have paleolithic emotions
medieval
that sort of puts us in perspective of
where we are as individuals in this new
you of science and i'll try and expand
on that
and close with a couple
questions so what is science as i said i
i view science as a social cultural
but what are its characteristics
well science is really as old as
humanity
it's probably an expression of a
fight flight self-preservation mode
tracking animals to see whether that was
the bobcat that was going to eat them or
whether that was just a bird around
that was collecting data
and it served him well so he could
figure out what was around and what he
didn't want to know about
um
there are some species of nut ammons
that's why it's supposed to be people
call it almonds but
the correct pronunciation is actually
ammons
and some were
poisonous and over the course of time
they found that some weren't
so with observation and a deduction
sort of a scientific method
they were able to eat almonds
taming animals growing crops planting by
the seasons
that's a synthetic process
putting some of the data together
taming animals
goats cows
for good
meat and for milk
instead of walking five miles to pick up
the wild rice uh he dropped some on the
way and next spring he found out gee
it's sprouted hmm
why should i walk five miles when i just
put it in my backyard and voila we have
a agriculture
planting by the seasons
and the mayans and the british we've
seen all kinds of large structures to
keep track of the seasons
to do just that
so science is really not new
sciences however has become very complex
shifting from a reductionistic to a
synthetic approach
reductionistic is
what's that small piece made of
a little bit of
rock turns into sand sand turns into
atoms and adamson turned into subatomic
particles
um
our bodies uh
uh vesalius um did some anatomy
took things apart and we've gotten
smaller we found organs and then we
found different kinds of cells we got a
microscope
and then we found there's kind of
molecules inside what kind of molecules
were there well we get smaller and
smaller and
and then we come together with physics
and biology where the
subatomic and some of the atomic things
overlap
but science although it's complex is
also unsettled
we don't know a lot of answers
and
those two things go together complexity
and unsettled go hand in hand
science is really a balance of some sort
between inspiration the aha look what i
found
kind of thing
and investigation
they typical
do the experiment and make the
hypothesis kind of approach
but it's also made up of a lot of
mistakes
and some triumphs
and those also have to be balanced
finally
characteristic science is progressive
always looking to see how new
information can be applied
what science isn't
science as i said is not an ethical or
moral guide
science tells us what we know
but not how to use
what we know
probably one of the classic examples of
the problem of finding out what basic
science does and has its application
is nuclear fission
wow look at the energy we can get out
by having
controlling nuclear fission
and then someone discovered wow we can
science doesn't tell us anything about
5g
this legislature had a commission on 5g
and its biologic impacts
5g has a tremendous amount of potential
but
from the basic science served i served
on the commission
the basic science behind some radiation
is very disturbing and i would love to
talk to you about proton tunneling and
the disruption of the
bonds in dna but that's for another
story
pfas this commit this uh legislature's
also dealing with pfets
well at berkeley i worked for a company
that had the patent for teflon didn't
know exactly what to do with it and gave
it to dupont
needless to say they wish they hadn't
but
out of teflon came all the pfas kinds of
chemicals
so science tells us we can get stuff but
not how to use it properly
observations
technology is just
progressing at such a tremendous pace
it's outstripping
the what i mentioned to begin with the
social social and cultural constructs
technology is just going
with the pace that we that uh that is
unbelievable and we can see that with
computer example as computers and how
fast
they've progressed
but how we use computers
what science isn't
it's not settled but it can still be
quite useful
and we need to be aware of that
right
gravity is settled
no it's not i agree it's not settled
if you drill down to quantum mechanics
and that's the physics of small
particles
they can't take into account gravity and
there's
totally said that quantum mechanics and
quantum electrodynamics is one of the
most precise
theories
and experimental supported theories ever
invented by manned
but it can't take into account gravity
but we have no trouble we know that if
we step off of the table we're gonna
fall down
yet on the other end at the end of the
universe as we know it
there are some things that are we're
seeing that are saying hmm
[Music]
well
maybe we should make some adjustments in
gravity too
so at the small
and at the very large
i
like to ask when i do these kinds of
talks
where
[Laughter]
your eye works
because a photon quantum particle comes
in interacts
with a molecule creates a quantum
mechanical process
and that sends an impulse and those
collection of photons interacting and
those collections of impulse
we call
vision
so you love quantum mechanics
relativity
ah
why of course you don't use relativity
how many feel they have a familiarity
with
relativity special and general
relativity
when the sun's hitting us
excuse me when the sun is hitting us
um
iphone
and you use gps correct you get places
gps does not work
if you don't use special and general
relativity
if you did not take into account general
within very short order within about a
minute or two it would be inaccurate i
mean really inaccurate
so
um
enjoy your quantum mechanics enjoy your
special relativity
um science is now much more complex
and
it's in the sense that it's truly global
a pattern that we don't generally think
of
it's truly intergenerational
crispr you know genetic modifications
that's truly intergenerational so
science is complex
truly global and truly intergenerational
sort of aspects that we don't deal with
on a daily basis
the power of science is really becoming
to the fore i'll just use one example
uh we're all familiar with the concept
of artificial intelligence one of those
far out sort of science fiction
but we're now finding that using ai we
can use retinal scans x-rays and
evaluation of pathology slide cells
and
uh just to give you an idea how comp or
how powerful it is you know about uh
checkers so you can write a program to
beat somebody at checkers you can write
a program for chess meet somebody at
checkers very simple that's an eight by
eight
board that plays on
the game of go which you may be familiar
with is 19 by 19
much larger
the number of
possible moves in a single game of go
is greater than the number of atoms in
however using ai they were able to beat
the international champion four to one
and in one game they thought the
computer hit a glitch everybody went
including the international championship
oh my goodness what was that
turns out
it never been conceived of by humans
there's a quote i want you to tell me
who wrote it
he who controls a.i will control the
world
and i think he is
what is science it's uh
it's different
for scientists and lay persons
increasingly because of the
sophistication and complexity of science
this was pointed out by c.p snow in 59
when he gave a series of lectures about
the
disparity between science and the arts
um
some of it the quantum mechanics
relativity and ai and sometimes if we've
taken the position of the culture
sometimes if we don't under know it or
we don't understand it
however um
we can't do that
and
we're impacted
with science from every direction
and we can't ignore it
and we deal with it
so i want to leave you with two
questions
the answer to the second question
addresses our common goal
producing good legislation
the first question
moral comment
will science be able to answer
all
questions
or put it another way
does man have the intellectual capacity
to understand all processes in the
universe
the answer is casually assumed to be yes
but that remains to be seen and may
second is the question i want to leave
you with
how can we better understand and
interpret society's response
often there is confusion in the public
about the interpretation of science
leading to conflicting postures
and therefore my reference to
legislation
vaccines not being fully
fda approved
not just eu approved
fully fda approved led many to reject
acceptance
on the other hand we've heard ivermectin
is not fda approved
for treatment yet receives very wide
support even though it has no fda
approval
and thus the conundrum how do we as
legislators
interpret properly
for
our constituents and i'm still thinking
of patience
being retired but
um
and that's the conundrum that we we have
to live with
addressing
the science
and and as i said science uh is
basically
a social
cultural
construct used to engage your
environment
but it does not
provide an ethical or moral guide
it tells us what we know
but not how to use what we know
thank you
[Applause]
i'll take any questions
i'm sorry we got one minute or two
minutes
she's not here but representative canuck
you have to be calling me according to
lucy
[Laughter]
whatever so i have a question though
that was really
not your thirty thousand foot you're
right this is more like a three hundred
thousand foot view if we get kind of
down to maybe a thousand feet into the
nuts and bolts of how we do studies and
how we analyze them would you agree that
in terms of experimental science
that there are certain criteria one uses
to be able to analyze whether or not a
particular experiment or a particular
study or a particular paper
has a level of validity or at least you
can compare the relative levels of
validity between different studies using
set
known criteria
well that's that's the whole scientific
method is to have a
a subset of experience in this case
mathematical in many instances uh and
math goes across all that do provide you
that foundation
but some of that is
anyone else
represent betty gay we're not in a
hearing
and i apologize that i am never formal i
never say thank you mr chairman and
you may call me dr pearson when we're
not
yes okay
um you mentioned the 5g and you didn't
want to get into it i think you would
have a heck of a big audience if we did
uh if you were willing to talk about it
because i know there are other people
who are very concerned one of the
senators that said that's why i ran
because she's so concerned about the 5g
radiation and i sure would like to learn
about it
well i um
i i'd be happy to i i'm very familiar
with some of the aspects at the
molecular level um because
both the undergraduate i did some
independent study on the quantum
mechanics
that involved in molecular interactions
and in proton tunneling i mentioned that
uh and some of the work i did in
graduate school as well
absolutely this is this is the
difficulty is that when you begin to
look at this because our dna is held
together by hydrogen bonds
and
if they can exchange it when they meet
together the two parts the two strands
that hydrogen bond is basically a proton
and if you look at quantum mechanics
if there's a
barrier you say well it can't go through
the barrier quantum mechanics says
there's a certain probability that it
will just somehow appear on the other
side
and that's proton tunneling
trouble is what happens when it gets on
the other side when the dna is red it's
a misread
oops error
and that's proton tunnel
well it's miss red
okay because the protons on the other
side it looks different
and so when it goes when if
dna is red at that time it'll be read as
a different item
and put into the code
it can be repaired
but that's a whole part very complex but
the point is at the very basic science
level things like proton tunneling and
that's quantum mechanics
the application of quantum mechanics has
impact on and this is not ionizing this
is not heavy duty this is very low
energy
so you don't have to have ionizing
radiation that's all story for a long
time so another time we are now going to
be stripped of all our other titles
representatives
and i call
house bill 1537 establishing a pilot
mental health drop-in center program
representative klein knight
thank you so much mr chairman and
members of the committee i love to hear
all the laughter this seems like the
healthiest mental health committee i've
ever been a part of it's the healthiest
committee of any kind i i'd like to
so um thank you for being here today
and uh
giving
uh this idea the appropriate amount of
time that it deserves
considering
the data that we've been
receiving as leaders i'm sure you're
aware of our mental health crisis and
emergency
what this aims to do is
just provide
more resources
for
people that are in need in our state
this is directly adopted from other
states that are doing this as well
so rather than invent the wheel
i have tried to see
what is working and what other people in
the same exact predicament are are
trying to resolve
so we have some
some uh
studies and
data points that we'd like to
pass around that you're doing right now
so for your reference that would help
you make
and this this is
this is aiming to prevent
hospitalization this is aiming to get
ahead of a problem that we are all very
well
informed of that is happening
um
if anybody has um
been following the djhs reports you know
that
the past two years we've been at our
highest numbers specifically in
pediatric mental health care as well the
double digits getting
up to 32 children waiting in the er
around the state for weeks
to be seen
and so they just sit there and sit there
and sit there without any recourse or
resource to go to
we don't want them
i obviously we shared this common goal
we don't want them to have to go there
in the first place there should be
resources in place that we should be
able to offer
families and children a place to go
before even gets that bad and so we need
to put our heads together
this is a complete bipartisan issue it
transcends
any political agenda
it is
something that we can get really
creative with
and collaborate with
and it aims again to reduce the the
amount of people that are going to be
waiting for weeks
in the er without getting care burdening
our health care system and
you know
we're not
we don't win they don't win nobody's
winning so how can we get ahead of this
how can we address this how can we
provide more resources for our people so
that it doesn't become that bad
and i'm open and amenable to any and all
amendments and all ideas
again
this is something that i think we all
need to come together on and i thank you
for your time and i'm open to any
questions
please
ask
am i on you are on um
thank you for granting me my question
and thank you for taking it do you
envision this as a 24 hour
a day open facility
i would love that i know there are
certain urgent care centers that do
operate on that level and i would love
to see a similar model adapted but
specifically for mental health care in
general
a follow-up follow-up and um
you know as a psychotherapist i'm
wondering how
who would you envision staffing this
uh and to and then
um you know a whole patient intake for
each person that came in
you know just some of the um nuts and
bolts
yeah questions i'm hoping to get a
wide spectrum of all mental health care
professionals to work as teams
um on all levels whether that
psychiatric or
whether that looks like counseling
whether that looks like medication
i'm aiming to help people that may have
misplaced their medication and then
can't go without it that same day and
then don't necessarily need to go to the
emergency room just to get their
medication
because if if any of you are familiar
with i'm going and relapsing off of
ssris
that can lead to many more health
concerns and actual emergencies
so this is this again this is a
preventative idea
to to to get ahead of a situation that
is really out of control right now
thank you
thank you very much um though i agree
wholeheartedly with this there is one
concern i have which came up in another
bill
in that a sense that it's it's funded
via arpa funds
and so
the concern is whether or not we
actually have authority as a legislature
to distribute our funds because i'm it's
not the it's not usually in our purview
it's from the executive department
right and um thank you for that question
and that also that can be amended um we
are looking to
make an ask of where the arpa funds are
going and i'm certain as a legislative
body we can at least um
you know recommend and and make that ask
because there is going to be a lot of
money that um i'm sure we do have a say
in where it's allocated and i'd like to
not place a further tax burden on our
people
also
on an unrelated note there is other
bills coming down the pipeline in the
legislative
body that
will provide more funding for for
um
for projects like this so i urge you all
to
um take a look at those as well and keep
our eyes open because uh this doesn't
this this isn't this that mechanism for
funding doesn't mean that we need to
take this idea and kill it we we can
certainly i'm sure come up with a
creative solution on how to move this
forward representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative
um
i agree this tremendous unmet need
um in my community in keene
we have monadnock family services which
is the community mental health center
and then we have a peer support
organization
monarch peer support
and between the two of them
i think they do
many but not all of the things um
that you're describing
so my question really is would you
view a pilot program as being something
completely new and independent
but maybe or maybe somehow embedded into
the organizations that already exist
someplace
um thank you so much our representative
shapiro uh
again that is open to this discretion of
how best you feel as a committee to move
forward um i would
i personally feel like we don't need to
reinvent the wheel and the people that
are on the ground level of experiencing
this crisis how we'll have a lot to
offer and we should have maybe uh
railroad certain ideas right into the
you know the game plan here and
definitely out of respect and education
uh value those people that are part of
thank you mr chair thank you
representative for taking one question
along some of the lines that were here
um i'm trying to understand the scope
and how much it would cost even if we're
looking at
that um
at
for funds
because
um i work for an organization that
provides a drop-in center
but um
you know you've got brick and mortar
facilities you've got people you've got
to have somebody that manages it if
we're looking at
government funding we've got to have
part of the organization that ties into
the granting organization that provides
it
there's this is just to start there's
not there's not a lot of depth behind
this
the i the concept is great but
where do we go from here
i'm so glad you asked representative and
that is exactly why i came to the
professionals
and
the the um
experts in this committee to help flesh
it out and i was told by um the chairman
a couple of weeks ago which uh was uh
was greatly respectful that um this is a
matter that is taken serious on both
sides of the aisle and there will be
time to add things of such detail which
i trust
and
relinquish to you as as the experts in
representative gay
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question and
suggestion it really is a question
because you're talking about arpa funds
and it says very clearly note the
federal government is directing our
money to the states to address mental
health and addiction consequences
so wouldn't that mean automatically
that we could use the funds apply them
to whatever
methods we have to provide the services
and if we already have
serv
have a network that provides
would that mean that we could just hire
more people have more phone service for
24-hour day
if we could just fund more people
of course we also need to get more
people to become counselors
i thank you so much representative gay
for your question i um i'm under the
assumption just like you that that's
that's how it reads to me as well it's
not specific in the terms that we can
place these funds where we need them the
most and since there are certain ideas
in the state that are similar
we can definitely
take some models and adapt them to this
this is why i think this is so important
and and real crucial to look at and and
build off of and the fact that
the um
these funds are given to us with such a
broad scope and term
is is basically it's in being entrusted
to us to spend it wisely and
specifically on certain things that are
so so needed
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
right here in front of you
in regards to as i look through the
intent of this legislation
is the intent for them to get
treatment at this location or basically
for someone to act as a triage in other
words
a place where these people can walk into
at that point in time help the person
find the therapy they need
are you looking for somebody to actually
be available them
at this location to provide
mental health therapy
thank you that's a really good question
i think we we do have uh substantial
resources when it comes to a long term
um we do have other centers where people
can go in and just like urgent cares um
i'm hoping again that this models a
similar form of medicine where if
somebody is
doesn't maybe have a provider that they
see on a regular basis that this is
still an option they can go to again
keeping in mind that these are resources
we're making available to the public so
that they don't end up in the emergency
room as their normal
reliance of care
follow up
thank you mr chairman
so
are we looking to you at this point in
time at the location having what i call
highly qualified mental health workers
to help the patient that way for someone
that would say in the legal profession
paralegal somebody who has some basic
training in mental health to help the
patient navigate what they need
because right now my understanding is we
have a tremendous shortage of qualified
mental health
professionals
to help
patients with their therapy
and i'm concerned that we wouldn't have
enough resources to staff it so are we
looking for somebody at that level
somebody's more of a paraprofessional
that has some basic training by somebody
eligible to give the training to help
navigate that patient yes i i'm hoping
more for um a person to come in and
provide next steps of treatment and care
and work as a team to maybe have those
actual connections to to then place them
in a long-term solution
so that again that
we can get people in and out and that
they they feel comfortable going to a
place that's not waiting in in the
emergency room where they're not
necessarily coming every week for
long-term care treatment but there's a
place that they know that they can go to
to maybe get the um
when you get referred to as as you would
say
representative mckay
thank you thank you mr chairman
uh just a very brief uh personal thing
uh this fine lady uh
asked me about uh sitting on those
wooden chairs over there
in bedford
and she logged in for every meeting we
had over there this love seat that was
very comfortable
i'm not so sure about how much love
there was
there but uh
but
i very much appreciated that it made
life simply
if you look in this
on line four
shall provide a peer-focused recovery
model
that's a very specific model that's a
very much like a alcoholics anonymous
but but for people with mental illness
or addiction
so that the
notion
is that somebody who
has had
a mental illness or an addiction
is well qualified to help somebody
because of their experience with the
illness
i have some doubts about
that program
but that
in in general
the new hampshire
has developed a state mental health plan
this is a well-developed plan
it's
was preceded by one that i was chairman
of that nothing ever happened and then
it was preceded by two others
the mental health planning
activities should be consistent with the
mental health plan
and as a whole
team of people
in the department of health and human
services
that this does not
indicate
a
a team of
mental health professionals like social
workers psychologists psychiatrists
this is this is these are individuals
some of them may be
people with mental illness
so i think
it's great that you're bringing in
something that will get us to focus on
the mental health
issues
that's a the mental health plan is a
complex plan
and it needs to be funded in total
if you don't do part of it it collapses
so that
i have
this would not be my
first top priority
in terms of
where money should go
and but i thank you for
bringing in legislation that makes us
continue to
think about
we
last
year we did pretty good with mental
health i'm concerned that
what looks like we did pretty good may
not
come out because we have this thing
called the back of the budget
where the department has to cut
a significant amount of money hopefully
that might be
mental health
but thank you for
yes representative if i can respond to
that yes please
i think with all due respect the numbers
coming out of dhhs
show that we're at the worst time in
history for the state in the mental
health that we've been providing
and those
numbers don't lie
and
we also i would like i don't have
the amount on me specifically but if you
do go
to the dhhs website and you look at
funds that have been provided for these
ideas the ideas are there and that's
absolutely correct but there's
millions of dollars that have just been
sitting there for a couple of years now
and actually haven't been spent
and that is really concerning to me
yes thank you mr chairman and thanks for
taking another question
i am intrigued by the idea that this is
a pilot project and once again i'll go
back and say that my community now that
i read this carefully all of these
things are really provided already
there aren't enough staff
there is not immediate access which
would be implied in it for a drop-in
center that there'd be immediate access
so i think the structures for all of
these things are
in place at least in
in keene
and provided in a very imperfect way
so i'm my question to you is really like
how will
whether we
[Music]
a pilot project to me
implies that it's going to be tried and
studied
and i'm wondering
what's your idea of what will happen
after a pilot project
after we conceive of something that's
already there as this pilot project or
if we create something
what's the next step after a pilot
project thank you so much for your
question representative shapiro um i do
think that we do have a lot of similar
resources that are already there across
the state um but they're all separate
they're floating around and they may be
even hard for our people to access if
it's not a one shop stop and i do think
that having a one stop shop
for resources such as this should be
studied and
if it if it shows that we lower the
emergency rate waiting times for people
that are suffering from mental health
issue
we'll be knowing we'll know that we're
going in the right direction because
with the ideas that have been brought
forward they're great ideas for the last
several years i know people have been
working tirelessly on this issue but the
numbers don't represent
the right direction that we're heading
[Music]
now is it on
okay
i do agree i
pilot program like this to come in the
entire state
some thought needs to go into where that
might be located that this is really
dropping it has to be readily accessible
to a pretty wide range of people
and
i guess also
staffing 24 hours right now we have
programs that have been included in this
plan
to try to address the same problem
without having a physical location
but
we're really struggling we're i'm
talking about as if i still work there
but
you know trying to get the staff
together and finding professionals to
come in to do this is really an enormous
challenge
one of the things that we're including
that plan is we have now what's called
mobile community crisis response teams
that are located presently in every
mental health center around the state
and the new plan also calls for a team
that would either include within that or
have a separate team to respond
uniquely to children
and adolescents who have that need this
is a team of people that are available
they are available 24 7
and it's an alternative to having people
brought to the emergency room when
they're experienced in a crisis
it's a trained professional along with a
peer support person that goes out
sometimes with the police oftentimes
without sometimes we're called in by the
police to help them in dealing with
something they don't understand in lieu
of hauling them off to the emergency
room where you're right they're going to
wait
instead what they try to do in that
period of time
is to develop a safety plan what can we
do to keep you safe over the next
first 24 hours then a little bit later
and continue to follow up
and look for the plan and they have a
kind of an interval of contacts in
between and i think the people the
division behavioral health
department can answer this better me
i've been retired can we come to a
question the question i'm sorry if i
didn't do that
i guess the question i have is would you
don't do you feel that having these
teams located throughout the state
on that kind of a basis would accomplish
many of the same goals without a
physical location and without it seems
to me as if we're struggling to
accomplish the same thing without doing
it with a single location would you
agree
um i would
i think there's it's not so black and
white so i'm not going to give it a yes
or no answer i'm going to say that the
crisis response teams are great idea
um it's been something in the works for
quite some time first there was only one
and within the last two months the
second one has just been adopted and
they at the beginning of the last two
years at this session they were not
meeting the scope of the need and the
numbers in the er showed that and i
would love it if this crisis team could
work with a model such as this again i
think we could get really creative here
we could use all the resources that
we've been working with already and just
because an idea is already in place
doesn't mean we don't need more and
again the numbers reflect that we need
more
representative merchant looks very eager
so i will let him go before me
in the spirit of bipartisan cooperation
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative king
um
as i listen to
the presentation lawyer by
representative woods listen to
representative snow a couple neurons
actually hit each other
and following up on the technology we
talked about before
is there a possibility in this pilot
program set up someone going to see a
therapist or somebody at the location
using the technology we have today where
somebody could walk into a facility
that's equipped for them to have
telehealth telecommunications so
therefore
instead of trying to bring the patients
to the provider providers to the patient
we use the technology out there that
creates that link and therefore
we are using and tapping into existing
resources but using technology to do it
is that any possibility yes i would love
that idea to be adopted in this model
again using all resources at our
disposal
the ideas that we have brought forth in
the legislation in the last couple of
years and making this all connected to a
spot where we can refer people to
anything such as telehealth services
yep
follow up
thank you mr chairman
what really also triggered my fanciness
whole thing i was in a pharmacy the
other day which was kind of interesting
inside of the pharmacy the pharmacy is
always interesting
uh if you get to speak to the pharmacist
but in saying that they actually had a
room set up and this goes back to what i
think representative canark talked about
the other day
which caught my attention inside of the
room was a
tv screen
hooked to a provider
and in the room they actually had an
autoscope
that could through bluetooth technology
transmit to the provider so the person
could see inside of the ear
they had a same thing with their scope
that you could actually somebody could
help the patient at that point in time
use the equipment but the provider on
the other side was actually
visually seeing what was going on
which i thought was kind of a nice great
use of technology where somebody could
walk into a pharmacy and get access to a
provider without having to actually go
to
i just i'm trying to follow up on the
same thing so there's a question there
somewhere
well i wouldn't you believe
yes
i would believe it and i would suggest
too that the crisis mental health
response teams aren't pharmacies and
they're limited to their scope and what
they may or may not be able to treat on
the ground right in that
immediate
you know in an emergency setting that
might not necessarily require an
emergency room visit so
again which is why something like this
would be super beneficial working with
what we already have in place and i mean
wouldn't you believe that a similar
situation to what you described doctors
without borders in other countries just
right here in our beautiful
country do help over
other well-needed places through that
kind of situation via
video conferencing and if we did in fact
have a shortage of people why not have a
facility to operate in the same way
until we have those needs met by our own
people
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative merchant for
uh kind of setting me up actually every
question so far is because
my question has morphed
about four times already
um
first of all i'm your neighbor in
milford
and um
i don't know if you're aware of some of
the programs that uh monica gallant and
at the boys and girls club is working on
uh such as uh soul safe and cast and
and others um you know i
i'm a little disturbed
i probably shouldn't end it right there
but um i'm a little disturbed that
milford high school only has one trained
professional to identify mental
health within our our school system
and
when you look at
substance use disorder
root cause you know the professionals
that i talk to
the
the cause
is mental health
and
so i think
where i've come from after all of what
i've heard i've learned so much and
representative shapiro i definitely want
to talk to you afterwards um
how do we unite ourselves to
uh to tackle this statewide
will this pilot program
provide that
thank you so much for your uh question
representative king and thank you so
much for being such a pleasant neighbor
um i have taken a look at a lot of those
and i um i hate to use the word um but i
also am disturbed i'm disturbed with the
proportionate amount of of children
that have been increased in hopelessness
and suicide ideology and the numbers are
increasing every year and so um with all
due respect like just the our ideas that
we've already implemented are are not
suffice their to to say the least
they're we're not hitting our goals if
the numbers of more disparaged children
are ever increasing
i do hope that
again since this would be a pilot
program that this is not something that
we
we can we can certainly keep adapting
and
trying to fit best practices and best
needs which is why there there wouldn't
be such a that we shouldn't knock this
before
trying to collaborate
on all levels of what's already been
implemented
to to just do more because we're we are
failing
anyone else thank you representative
cannon
thank you representative for taking
another question
are you familiar with the doorway
program
i believe i am if you'd like to talk
about it please go forward
well part of the part of that program is
focused on mental health as well as
all sorts of other
substance abuse and so forth and and i'm
wondering if
if what you're talking about here might
be it might be something that they
aren't fully implementing but have
have part of the puzzle
for implementing
and it's probably worthwhile looking at
is this something that would work uh in
addition to what they currently offer of
course i think this is here so that it
could be worked in addition to whatever
is being reached and maybe again since
you guys are all the experts and have
more knowledge in this uh field than i
do you could pull all those resources to
the people that are already doing things
and get them involved in something like
this so that the whole state's talking
about it we're all on the same page and
that if one if this isn't a one size
fits all for mental health if something
works for one child it might not work
for another child and that is exactly
why we need to collaborate and bring
everybody together on the resources that
representative mcmahon
thank you mr chairman
uh miss uh representative klein knight
specific to line nine on page one
uh
could you comment on who was the
authority having jurisdiction
to specifically identify
the area
that a
single pilot program would be
placed
i believe that maybe this body
again i would urge you to
work with dhhs on this it is up to you
and again it is a pilot program so
i would take a look at the demographics
and urge to suggest that you put it in
the strongest place where there's the
most need
follow-up thank you mr chairman
uh specific to following a model that
was dealt uh dealing with disabilities
which is the area agencies
we have 10 of them throughout the state
in identifying where the
identified need for increased access do
you have a comment as the
submitter of the bill
as to where you believe in your
experience the pilot program would
be best initiated
well um as a representative from
manchester i see a great need and i have
a high population but i don't want to
get greedy and i'm willing to open up
the floor to all the representatives for
the entire state and come to a
compromise on where exactly to put
something like this
thank you mr chairman representative
mckay
would you believe that
representative snow and i will be
activating the
mental health caucus
for a lot of reasons which are pretty
obvious
we haven't got started but
now is the time to do it
and this bill and other bills
would certainly be
very useful for our discussion so i just
thought we'd give a little advertisement
okay
thank you thank you and thank you
um
it because it's a pilot program and we
have just certain amount of money that
we want to spend and
see what works
would this prohibit
a much expanded telephone service for
people in crisis
and then i really like your um idea that
you mentioned here about
see if i can find the words
um
peer support
uh
on the basis of like al-anon and
and d.a and
um i would think that it could be a
diffusing would you would you think that
it would be a kind of um
uh first
when people are feeling troubled that it
would be a safe place to go to
to talk to be with other other
teens
people
of all ages
so that the money could go and serve
many places so even though the brick and
mortar sounds really appealing
and maybe we'd have enough money to set
one up
but in order to serve as many people as
possible would that be
would that suit your goal
to have
a
a telephone line that people could call
and also encourage
um
just like we have
al and on and aa and d.a
all over the place could we set up some
of those to invite so the people would
get person-to-person contact not just a
phone
thank you for your question
representative gay and
taking the time to not only mention
certain values that this bill proposes
but also more ideas to include in this
and that is exactly the com kind of
conversation i was hoping to get because
would you believe out of necessity
because of the lack of resources that we
they do
the out of this they need to they have
no other recourse but to go to peers
because there's a lack of
professionals so what exactly what this
aims to do is not to necessarily drain
any sort of financial budget as well but
to
have some
um
balance of volunteers professionals
uh you know standards that need to be
met but certainly um a community network
so to speak as as what you're suggesting
um to to adopt the ideas that have
already been in practice
and to collaborate and get us all more
organized so that we can refer people to
thank you for your testimony
representative in presenting this bill
to us today
the chair recognizes representative
thank you mr chair um thank you for
having me here it's always an honor to
be before you
and i am humbled to have this discussion
on mental health care and here in the
granite state for the record my name is
representative megan murray i represent
the town of amherst i come before you in
support of hb 1537
seeking integrated and forward-thinking
multi-faceted approaches to the complex
and anemic state of mental health care
services and access to them here in new
hampshire
i applaud the state of new hampshire for
its recent launch of initiatives like
the nine new hampshire 988 rapid
response access point for those in
crisis however
my goal is to see folks thrive and avoid
states of crises or long waits for
dedicated receiving facilities by having
ample community-based resources for
mental health wellness
available to them before situations are
critical and complex and potentially
require inpatient care
while 988 response is helpful especially
in crisis that alone though a step in
the right direction is not enough
and as i come before the committee i
also issue a content warning
as this discussion mentions suicide
the students have excuse me the citizens
of new hampshire and my district are
seeking expanded access to care options
including peer support centers like the
ones sought through this bill
over the last few years alone
painfully
my district has seen a rise in of
desperation and suicide particularly in
children and excuse me young adults
and our community and those in rural and
underserved settings seek more resources
for community members to engage in with
regard to their mental health wellness
last year new futures held a symposium
in milford which i was honored to attend
where youth and their parents talked
about their lived learned um experiences
and the need for peer-supported options
they thought grad greater access to
programs inside school learning
communities and with their own
residential communities too
i believe there was a representative
from the state i can't recall if it was
the department of education or
department of health and human services
that was there but they were in
attendance
looking back in time briefly to 2018 the
national council on mental well-being
cited that those
situations were dire with regard to
mental health
access then and frankly access to
resources and providers by and large
currently in 2022 now more than ever the
evidence is clear that mental well
mental health wellness and related needs
are among the highest concerns of
government leaders across america
over 52 percent of the mayor surveyed in
boston university's initiative of city
survey of mayor's report cited mental
health as their primary and most
pressing concern
while it's true that the fiscal note
provided does not specify or direct how
much money should be allocated or given
to the pilot program
[Music]
it is noted that
over five million dollars
in fiscal year 2021 community mouth
mental health block grant programs to
the american rescue plan supplemental
awards has been noted as well as 5.5
million targeted to substance misuse
separately for the state of new
hampshire
in rural and underserved communities
across new hampshire there's a void of
brick and mortar resources available in
many new hampshire communities while
telehealth medicine is incredibly
helpful and an integral resource to
folks in our communities it's true that
many in underserved areas have
telecommunications and broadband access
issues right now
and i think some of you had mentioned
throughout my district
that they are seeking care for
themselves or a child so you can utilize
both in-person therapies and telehealth
medicine and both avenues of care are
heavy with lengthy wait times in
scheduling or a lack of participation
providers
through interstate health compacts or
other issues listed as a barrier to the
constituents receiving and seeking care
many have also shared with me that if
there were an increased availability to
peer support centers like this
with um mentioned within the bill that a
reduction in stigma
and a supported sense of community both
for youth and adults
would be bolstered as folks navigate
their mental health wellness journey
i thank the committee for their time and
urge the community to pass 1537 in
establishing a pilot mental health
drop-in center program and i thank you
and would be happy to take questions
yes representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for being here and taking
questions
um looking at this as a peer-focused
recovery model i'm just curious why this
is something that needs to be done
through the state when it's a peer-based
program and if that might be the sort of
thing that's uh better served through
some of these
other other voluntary groups that's a
great question thank you for asking that
um so
we have seen a myriad of other states
implementing this as just one other tool
in the toolbox for folks to connect with
other folks
as a first step sort of an introduction
for folks to go if they needed a place
to identify needs or care services we do
like representative klein knight had
mentioned there are some resources that
already do exist that's true
but what what we are asking for is a
pilot program that
is innovative in the way that um is
approaching this need in a way that is a
state
approach to the issue
so that we are implementing this
potentially if it if it is a successful
representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman thank you
for taking the question this is just a
quick question which is that i've heard
um
both of the people who testify talk a
lot about children and adolescents
but i don't see that that's referenced
in this bill so is this
is this
pilot program
intended to be for children and adults
uh thank you for the question yes it
would be and i think that this would be
an integral resource for both parents
and adults individually if they're
seeking mental health wellness resources
as well as if a child alongside of their
parent is attending
one of these drop-in centers to to
receive some care or a
conversation around that such as some of
the other um programs that i think
representative gay had mentioned as well
as like
we know that they exist some of those
other programs like alcoholics a or
narcotics anonymous or any of those
other types of resources this would be
an integrated approach to mental health
wellness and helping to address
stigma in an interconnected issue i know
that
um
when i attended the symposium
that children and their parents were
sharing that they were desperately
seeking this type
of service
thank you representative
in the chair calls julianne carbon from
dhhs
thank you
and good afternoon my name is julianne
carbon i'm the director for the bureau
of mental health services i believe i
met you a few weeks ago at our dhhs meet
and greet so pleasure to be here again
we just wanted to provide some
information and simply say that we're
here for the committee if you have
questions about
our current state of mental health
services and the resources and the
challenges that our system is facing
i think we are thrilled to see
a bill like this be put forward
in acknowledgment and recognition of the
very important role that peer support
services play in our system of care and
just the unique type of services
that they offer
i have brought and i'll leave some
handouts for you
regarding our current peer support
agency network so we have eight agencies
that are located in all 10 community
mental health center regions around the
state
they are our network of peer support
agencies they offer walk-in drop-in
services
and they provide peer support services
on both an individual one-on-one level
as well as group services
their doors are open approximately 44
hours per week
it is a provision of our community
mental health settlement agreement so
that's why we have this extensive
network available statewide
some of those peer support agencies also
offer
recovery oriented step up step down
services which are a residential program
as well as peer respite
so again i'll leave
just a basic handout about those
programs
as you've heard and this committee is
very knowledgeable about all of the work
that's happened in connection to the
10-year mental health plan
and so you may be familiar with the
i know you're you've talked about this
this afternoon
the
crisis redesign that we've been
embarking on
and so just as a reminder that system
does include
24 7 phone
text and chat services
where people can get connected to both
mental health clinicians and peers via
that modality
um the mobile crisis response piece that
is available statewide
is also as you heard a combination of a
clinician and a peer who would deploy
and the next phase of that model which
really is a
national and it's called crisis now and
it's a best practice model for crisis
services and it includes that third
component of a place to go a
location-based service where people can
walk in
24 7
for a variety of support you know it can
be a law enforcement drop-off
unit
here in new hampshire in about 2018 we
did launch a pilot program
here in concord called the behavioral
health crisis treatment center
and that model
was designed
to be one of those
drop-in locations
they were never actually as
representative snow indicated staffing
has been a significant challenge
especially for the overnight shifts and
they actually never got to the point of
being able to staff their
center 24 7.
and so as we look forward and as you've
heard so much money has come into the
state as a for mental health regarding
um as a result of the arpa funding
one of the pieces that we are starting
to explore and we'll be looking
to better understand is what model will
work here in new hampshire
that model wasn't very successful
there's a huge need i mean you're all
aware of of the access challenges
and so that's a priority of ours at the
department as well working with our
partners to better understand you know
what will be viable accessible
our current network of peer support
agencies is only available to adults so
limitation of the programs currently but
that's strictly because that's how the
funding has been designed
so again my colleagues and i are here as
a resource to provide information and
support if if that would be of help to
the committee
any questions
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
is there any data out there
that looks at other models that have
done some other states that we could
instead of trying to reinvent the wheel
type of wheel that's already been
invented and utilized that we could
adapt here
yes that's an excellent question and we
so we are part of a national network
of state mental health program directors
and through that association
they've done a lot of research on what
type of models have been most effective
so there are some great models around
the country that we're looking to and
they're often a combination of that you
know as indicate that pure living room
model so just kind of comfy chairs where
people come in and talk with peers to
have their initial crisis resolved
all the way up to something that's
slightly more clinical so
representative king
thank you mr chairman
and
thank you for taking my question
um
sometimes i'm a little dense so
are you supporting this bill or not
supporting this bill
you know it's hard to know i mean i'm
simply here to provide information
i think a lot of the
types of resources that are framed out
in the bill are in place today so i i
even heard that as part of this
discussion
up
uh i'm sorry to cut you off but um no i
got it wrong
go ahead
um
what do you think has
in your opinion what do you think has
worked and what hasn't worked in the in
the pilot programs that you've
you know it's so and we as you hear we
are in a really
different place today than we were
two years ago and so i i think as we
look forward maybe what worked two years
ago
won't work as we move forward there have
been a lot of suggestions around
looking at alternative methods of
connecting via telehealth and
um
so
what we have found
when we've seen programs that have been
really successful it's been a result of
the community collaborations where we've
had the agencies really working together
we have peer support agencies partnering
with our community mental health centers
to provide integrated care so that's
really where we've seen some synergy and
some momentum
in some of the pilot programs we've been
doing
thank you representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chair
um and thank you for taking this
question um
you reference the fact that there are
already peer support um programs that
cover the whole state
only eight of them in the ten
districts but somehow they cover the
whole state and i know there are family
resource centers
that are
would not strictly be considered a
mental health service
but they do
work with families and children um i
think of all ages um probably mostly
with younger children
and i wonder if there's been any
examples of collaboration between
mental health center
peer support groups and these family
resource centers
that would
um
be somewhat similar to what this bill is
describing
that's i don't know the answer to that
question you know again our peer support
agencies because of the way they were
they came about they focus on adults so
those connections may be happening
locally but i'm not aware of it
representative netarapam
thank you
um would you have any idea of the
statistics of the number of people that
would call
a hotline resource who end up in the
emergency room anyway i mean is that the
advice sometimes that the hotline would
give
that that's a tough question i mean the
hope is
that
the majority of people do not end up at
the emergency room you know the
intention is that we have this lifeline
that people can call text chat into
and about 80 of those those contacts
will be resolved over the phone with no
needed
you know deployment no needed hospital
stay
so the hope is that we're resolving and
helping to keep people happy and healthy
in their communities
okay thank you very much
representative snow
thank you mr chairman thank you just as
a quick observation would you say that
the
mobile community crisis support teams
see how bad i am at technology i can't
even talk
about it
because i've heard reports that these
mobile crisis
response teams have really headed people
off of landing in the emergency room
would you say that you've gotten data
back to indicate that those have been
reasonably successful in many cases of
shutting off that
that stop
yeah so i mean as you're aware we've had
three mobile crisis response teams
operating around the state for a number
of years now and those teams
we do see data we publish it quarterly
as a requirement under our community
mental health settlement agreement so
you'll see that data
and they have been successful in helping
to divert people and so our hope is now
that we have
a system statewide we have data
requirements statewide that we'll be
able to analyze some of that information
statewide follow-up and you are
expanding those teams at least in i know
in manchester it also now responds to
children but you're expanding those to
include children all across the state is
that are you hoped to
that is the requirement is that they are
providing integrated
crisis response services to people
across the age continuum
a specific question to you relative to
the bill
uh on line five six and seven are those
services being met now with the programs
we i should say that you've described
today
um they are currently being provided by
our peer support agencies during that
kind of business hour
time frame
they are required to provide
voluntary short-term services to help
people on their wellness and recovery
through our peer support agencies yes
and follow up follow up thank you mr
chairman then relative to representative
klein knight's goal in this bill is it
i mean i think what was referenced is
that it's really hard for people to even
know what resources are available in the
community people aren't you know the
utilization numbers are very low we the
state do fund these programs and our
funding is minimal it ranges from about
150 000 a year to 450 000 a year
per agency
and so you know they have limited
ability
of the numbers that they can reach
one more time one more and then specific
to the bill where the goal is to
identify increased access
do we already have the access and do we
need to advertise it more
that is absolutely a strategy that we're
looking at is better
information and public awareness around
how to access care
and with your successful achievement of
that goal as just described do we need
i don't know that i'm in the position to
answer that i think you know do we need
to build out our network of um walk-in
and peer support services i would say
yes that's a system that that needs
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
um
was there any disruption to the
availability of these peer support
services being open in the last two
years with the pandemic
yes and so we we have some information
about that as well that we publish
quarterly
so i could get you that information
although i must say that our peer
support agencies were remarkable in
their ability to pivot
to provide remote services they were
doing personal phone calls to people
engaging in a different way and opened
their doors quite quickly
so there was limited interruption
thank you and one follow-up one
follow-up oh just quickly um so are they
all open again and operating
um with their normal hours and walk-in
i hesitate because of staffing you know
it's an ever-changing day or week so
when they have the staff available
thank you miss carbon
different ones had suggested changing
this or that
is there sentiment
for
a group to
tweak this with an amendment
and would you chair it
so thank you uh representative mckay and
who else would like to work
representative snow
and acton
and king
so
representative mckay is sharing this
with representatives snow acton king
shapiro and kelsey so make the
connection this is an early bill we have
to
execute by the 8th of february so work
quickly
and with that we bring to a close the
and now we open the hearing on house
bill
allowing out-of-state mental health care
providers to provide
telehealth treatment during a mental
health emergency
thank you again
for the record i'm representative klein
knight and i
um
represent manchester hillsborough
district 11.
there this is a bill that
was worked on by a lot of different
people
trying to again creatively solve what is
in fact a glaring crisis
a lot of us know and what we just heard
reiterated that we have an extensive
lack of
providers in the state
what
happened the last two years proved
a couple of things
and if those that are studying
um telehealth communications
they
know a couple of things about this one
that telehealth was all of a sudden
funded very well
for everyone
that were being quarantined or
not leaving their houses
and number two
how many people
started to use those services because
they had never
had that option before
so there was a couple of things that we
noticed we noticed
just how many people expressed interest
in therapeutic services
and
and the need for therapeutic services
that they had never gotten until this
moment and how it was made available to
them so i'd like to point that out
because
that um that number is actu is very very
large and scary
so
we're moving forward we're getting
healthier as a country we're going to be
losing a lot of these services and the
funding that they provide because we're
not going to be in crisis we're not
going to be an emergency anymore
but again the numbers don't lie the
number of people that took advantage of
these health care services and the
number of people that also said they had
never been able to get these services
until they were offered just recently in
the last two years has been quite
apparent and we cannot all of a sudden
offer these services to people and then
drop them off
so with that being said
the whole country was
giving services
to all different states
um if you couldn't get a
therapist in
one state it didn't matter because you
were meeting them
online and you were meeting them
remotely
it was
explicitly
of great value to our state because of
the lack of providers
so with that being said with people now
getting the help that they need from
these providers that are all over the
country we suddenly find ourselves in a
position
where
thousands upon thousands
of our residents are about to lose
their therapists that they have been
seeing for two years online
how do we
mitigate that especially since
if they drop they get dropped by their
therapists
and we don't have enough therapists here
in the state
are we going to be doing our people
knowingly ending
their and disrupting their services are
we setting
them up for failure are we going to put
more of a burden on our hospital and er
situation and are we going to add to
that double-digit number that we see
every week for people waiting for
services in the emergency room
so i challenge you this bill may not be
perfect again
but you guys are the experts here
um
but this is a problem that's not going
to go away and we're not going to be
able to sweep it out of the rug and when
we end the health care coverage that all
these people are getting treated for at
the end of this very month
on our website it states that
people will not be able to continue
seeking out of state providers on
january 31st
what is that number going to look like
in our institutions what is that number
going to look like in our emergency
rooms and how is
that
lack of funding that we just heard from
dhhs going to keep up with the ability
to
um treat these people now before i'm old
i'm almost done
i swear
there is a compromise right
it says if you look at it
not more than five prov not more than
five people a provider out of state is
is um
giving therapy to
should be required to pay for our
licensing
the idea behind that
is that
this was waived during this pandemic
they hadn't been paying the licensing
fees
and they're already helping all these
people
and the other idea behind that is
if a provider out of state
isn't seeing an entire workload to to
add to their income and they're in fact
doing us a service
our state of service from another state
would it be fair
to then make them pay a licensing fee
for one or two people that they're
helping in our state
i leave that up to you
to decide
but this is again a creative way to try
and keep our people
getting the help that they are getting
right now and continue to get the care
so that we don't see
an ever increasing amount of emergency
room visits and people and and again um
i hate to say it but um a skyrocketing
and um with that i'll take questions
thank you mr chair and again thank you
for taking my question
i'm thinking back to a bill we had
pre-covered covid
that dealt comprehensively with
to keep
not only to
increase access but also to ensure that
somebody who is temporarily out of the
state can keep
on in therapy with
an established
therapist
but my question is that was only for
psychologists which is a very small
portion of our mental health
workers
and i guess my question for you is uh
how are we at the moment monitoring the
quality of care
that is being
administered
under this program
i completely understand your question
thank you so much representative weber
again this is only pertaining to talk
therapy
and i do believe that the talk therapy
licensing is very very similar
throughout all 50 states and i'm also
pretty sure that if somebody was not
being able to be treated in the state
before having the ability to talk to
somebody is better than having no
therapy at all
and i'm also sure that i hope and i do
hope sincerely that
they also would have the ability to see
a different person as well
i'm seeing as i was trying to work my
way down to see if this
had really been answered
uh but am i correct in thinking this
only require only applies to physicians
because it says this paragraph shall not
oh it doesn't apply to physicians so
how do we know that the people who are
providing the services are appropriately
licensed in the place where they are
providing it is my other question thank
you so much for your question and there
may be an amendment that's needed to
clarify that they are licensed in their
own state and that would be a very uh i
would be grateful for that
to solidify the any misunderstanding and
to know that they are actually qualified
to
oh
sorry can i ask on paragraph four if you
would answer
it says here that
uh out-of-state mental health providers
who provide telehealth treatment to
fewer than five patients per year
okay i'm assuming
those are the people who are
licensed in their own state but not
licensed here in new hampshire
and the sentence at the top of paragraph
four which says
notwithstanding the provisions of law to
the contrary and out of state healthcare
provided providing services by means of
telemedicine for telehealth shall be
required to be licensed certified and or
registered with the appropriate
licensing board within the division of
health professions i'm assuming that
means
that if you're an out-of-state provider
and you you get a new hampshire license
you can then provide all these services
and if you don't get a license but have
a license in your own state you can
provide services up to five people is
that a correct interpretation of that
i'm sorry i'm having i i didn't quite
hear your the last part of your your
question close enough
i'm sorry
i'll get close thank you
what it says here is that uh the the
opening of power of section four says
notwithstanding
any provision of law to the contrary out
of state healthcare
provide a healthcare professional
providing services by means of
telemedicine to tell health shall be
required to be licensed certified or
registered by the appropriate
relationship board within the division
of health professions i'm assuming that
sentence applies to one of the boards of
licensing that are
here in new hampshire so they'd be
required to get a license here in new
hampshire then the exception comes that
if you're an out-of-state provider who's
licensed in their own state but not here
you can then provide treatment services
to up to five patients per year without
having to apply for new hampshire
license am i interpreting that section
correctly
i believe so the idea is to
allow people to
help our state out of state providers to
help our state alleviate the shortage
that we have
and if they're actually having more than
five and i'm i'm not sure if it says it
in here but again maybe you can include
this in the amendment that
every
year that the licensing would be coming
up to approach to renew anyways and
they'd have to report how many
clients that they're seeing
and again to keep this fair for our
state um
you know people should be paying
licensing fees so that
that isn't
what
we're saying that we want all people to
get out of licensing fees we're hope
we're hoping that and
again um you
have
the ability to change that number i
leave it up to the discretion of this
body just
one
follow up follow up okay
in addition to the division of public
health there is a another body that
licenses
all of the health all the mental health
professions social workers clinical
mental health counselors etc the only
ones that are an exception to that they
have their own board with psychologists
but those two boards need somehow to be
integrated into it and they would be the
ones that would decide who is registered
and who is not registered in this state
do we need to tie that in or do you
think this paragraph makes that clear
enough
that's a really good question
um i i'm not sure if it isn't clear i
representative
thank you very much um just a question
looking at
lines
five six and seven it talks about an
annual needs based analysis to be done
by the department
and then also in um
lines 19-21 the oplc who does an annual
audit of out-of-state medical mental
health providers have you checked with
those departments about the financial
impact and whether a fiscal note would
be needed for this
i've checked with
the licensing department only on the
basis of
what it provides to allow people to
conduct
telehealth medicine and talk therapy
i
did not
and
have not asked about the fiscal note
providing that
and this again might need an amendment
where
i'm hoping that the
providers are forthcoming and just like
any other provider applies for a license
at that time they then tell this
department how many new hampshire
residents they're seeing
and i hope that it would work similar to
what is happening right now during the
crisis
so i i
assume that whatever's been happening
right now has been working and i'd like
to keep continuing
what's been working
also
and i'm not sure if this is a red flag
but
we probably need more people working in
the licensing department because i've
heard a lot of providers can't even get
i just had another question based on the
fact that you have used the
uh phrase talk therapy a number of times
and i'm wondering
is there something in the bill that i've
missed that limits it to that or are
we are we talking about people who can
prescribe medication um
is
are you intending to limit it to one
thing or are you intending it to be
broader is what i'm asking i'm intending
it to limit to just talk therapy so this
isn't abused by other providers in
medicine and because there are other
licensing requirements for other scopes
and more in-depth invasive procedures in
medicine so i'm trying to alleviate um
the need for
what we have in the state which is a
lack of therapy providers
and is that specified in the bill at
this point
i tried to specify it and again if it's
um not
specified and
and now knowing my intent i would hope
that you could maybe
put this also in that group that you're
gonna be having
that would be really really awesome
[Music]
representative king
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
which i will admit that this might be a
bit of a stretch because i'm
kind of putting words into
what i'm sensing from our discussion but
the word i want to use is rest
reciprocity
and
i i actually met somebody
in october who had just moved to the
amherst milford area
and she couldn't practice in new
hampshire
because she was not certified and could
had to go through the whole
certification and she was moving from
massachusetts which i'm sure everybody
in this room would say that they're
probably a little bit more regulated
than we are and probably tougher
standards even
so um my question is is could
reciprocity be
incorporated in this bill
yes absolutely um i hope that
we make things easier for people to help
people and not harder
and i also hope that um
not only
people can continue seeing
people that they've developed a
relationship with over the last couple
of years that they don't have to
stop and find not only what is
i'm sure i'm not sure if i'm not sure if
you have had calls from your
constituents
but i have in regards to
i can't even get a therapist even if i
wanted one or there's a wait list this
long or
i had a therapist and they just moved
and now i have to find another one or
i'm going to lose my therapist at the
end of this month because they don't
live in the state and then also on top
of that to have to i have to then go
once i do find one i have to
start at the beginning of my trauma and
i have to relive that experience and
start from ground one and then if i
don't like that therapist or we don't
work well together i have to do it all
over again and then i have to wait even
more months to get the treatment that i
need or work on the here and now of what
problems i'm having in life right now so
as you can see the list starts to get
longer of what we can and cannot help
our people with
thank you
representative gay
both of you
i have really basic questions how much
does a license cost
that's one
i'm questioning the limit of five which
brings up the whole issue of reciprocity
accepting someone's certification
licensure from another state because it
seems like what our real goal is
is to incorporate more
therapists who
should be in practice
and
five seems really limited
and the cost how expensive is this
because is that a driving force
on the limit of five
yes and no
that's a good question
um our licensing
fee for um therapists is um i believe
not over three hundred dollars for
annually for two years i believe
but um
i
i know some of you may know just how
low
income a a social worker or a therapist
might be
and that they don't go into this
profession to
make an exceedingly amount of money and
they
might struggle with that and that
to
pay a fee before helping um
one or two you know just what if if they
want to
see one person from new hampshire
um
they're not going to do it why would
they do it and especially in a time
where we need it so this
is trying to
make it
look
viable or helpful to people that might
have a little
representative snow thank you mr
chairman i do remember
a couple of years ago maybe it was
longer than that
we had a specific bill about reciprocity
that we considered
and that was a very
complicated bill to deal with i know the
board of licensure got very involved
with us and they had some concerns about
giving it as pure reciprocity because we
don't always understand
did the standards that existed in
another state
really
measure up to our standards which i
think are pretty strong here in new
hampshire
but in any case
they finally did something where they
expedited
i think
that if you were licensed in another
state
you could
kind of abbreviate the process it took
to get your license transferred
and opened here in new hampshire without
having you through all the steps that
somebody applying for the first time
does this ring a bell with anybody else
that was on this committee at that time
yeah i do think that there are steps
that were already taken to expedite
somebody that was like your
neighbor who was licensed in
massachusetts which does have good
standards
that i think the the board relationship
and they'll already have to be the ones
to answer that they've taken steps to
make sure they don't have to go through
all the
and there were a lot of steps you take
when you're applying for the first time
but i think it was expedited so that
ought to be explored and
wouldn't you think that ought to be
explored yes yes
um
if i may respond i of course i think
that ought to be explored and of course
um i
think there might need to be changes
here and of course we only had a week to
kind of get our ideas into the office as
you know that being said that's not a
great excuse as a
lawmaker but again this isn't my area of
expertise i i did the best i could i'm
trying to come up with a really creative
solution to assist our people in
continuum of care
i myself am about to lose my therapist
at the end of this month
so and i for one
don't
know what to do along with all my people
and if there's a waiting list and
there's not enough therapists
and i'm sorry to the licensing
department i really am
but again i was trying to come up with a
fair number and if it's working right
now during a pandemic
any other questions for the
representative
seeing none the chair recognizes mr john
hinck or dr john hinck from the new
yeah hi i'm dr john hank i'm currently
serving as the president
of the new hampshire psychiatric society
which is a district branch of the
american psychiatric association
the new hampshire psychiatric society
and i support the house bill 1405
so i have a couple of
statements
from the american psychiatric
association regarding tele psychiatry
the use of the video based
telepsychiatry helps meet
patient needs for convenient
affordable and readily accessible mental
health services
with a robust evidence base that shows
telepsychiatry leading
to improved outcomes
and higher patient satisfaction
ratings
and they have a policy
that telemedicine and psychiatry using
video conferencing is a validated and
effective practice of medicine
that increases access to cure
which we definitely need in new
hampshire
the american psychiatric association
supports the use of telemedicine
as a legitimate component of a mental
health
delivery system
and they have done a couple of surveys
since the pandemic
and that has shown the results have
shown improved access to cure
reduced no-show rates and
a high rate of patient satisfaction
this underscores that psychiatrists
continue
to rely on telehealth for treating
psychiatric and substance use disorders
and that the regulatory changes made at
the beginning
of the public health emergency to
increase access to these services
continue to be essential
the benefits of tele-psychiatry include
that patients are more likely to keep
their appointments and when patients can
use telehealth to be seen
while at home they are satisfied with
treatment
they are more likely to continue with
their course of therapy
research suggests that this results in
better medication compliance
fewer presentations to the emergency
departments
fewer patient admissions to an inpatient
unit
and fewer subsequent readmissions
this results in improved access
better outcomes overall
decreased cost
and preserves limited community
resources
for example too few psychiatric beds
and what's happening currently
in the survey what the survey showed is
that
the um
patients
located so in other words currently what
i'm trying to say here
currently the psychiatrists being
surveyed we're saying that they were
most of them were actually treating
patients from outside their state
so that's what the apa
survey results were showing
and uh that the flexibilities around the
licensure
enacted because of the public health
emergency
has actually increased access to psychic
to psychiatrists
nationwide
so in closing
the new hampshire psychiatric society
supports the house bill 1405
but i would recommend a couple of
additions number one
and this would be to strengthen the bill
number one if
out-of-state practitioners provide
telehealth
mental health services during a mental
health emergency
they agree to be subject to the same
rules and regulations of the new
hampshire
licensing board in their specialty
as if they are licensed in this state
and then number two
they must have adequate liability
coverage for the treatment being
provided
thank you
thank you dr hank would you take
questions
absolutely uh
representative canark
yeah thank you i think this is a rather
quick one in the beginning your
testimony you commented about
video telemedicine but our telemedicine
statutes currently do include audio
video and other electronic media are you
comfortable that we include all of those
you representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question i think you
partially answered the question that i
was going to ask when you said you would
suggest an amendment
that would that said that people who
were practicing across state lines
would be subject to the same rules and
regulations
as people who were practicing with an
in-state license is that correct correct
so
that's good
um
who would have jurisdiction over
[Music]
following up on those rules and
regulations so for example if somebody
from new jersey was
doing telehealth with someone in new
had a
significant problem with something that
that therapist was doing an ethics
issue or something like that
if if the person was licensed in new
hampshire they would address that
complaint to the
new hampshire board of mental health say
if it was a social worker um
with this person now practicing across
state lines
who would have jurisdiction
in terms of
i'm not sure about the answer to that
question so sorry about that but i i
believe a patient who would want to
complain
could have a choice of complaining to
their own
state medical board or complain to the
new hampshire medical board
representative woods
thank you mr chair
just um
if you
and thank you for taking my question
it's very simple could you provide us
with the wording that you would like for
well i have a written statement here
okay i i don't write as fast as you yeah
yeah
so submit it at in writing at the end
i will or or simply email the committee
member email okay
representative wood follow-up
quick follow-up um
would you believe that it's my
understanding that uh
the current status of telemedicine
responsibilities in the area of the
domicile of the patient
that's where the legal
matter would be handled if there was an
i'm not certain to the answer to that
but i believe
okay all right yeah thank you for
answering that okay
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um i don't have
totally the answer but one of the things
that
after being on the board of arms for 10
years one of the things i think you're
going down right wrote here as far as
having the
out-of-state provider consenting to
being held accountable to the licensing
board one of the things that could
possibly that you thought of you know if
you thought about this but
they're
consenting to the fact that if there's a
complaint to the medical board of
licensing boards we want to make a
complaint to that they have somehow
obtained from their respective licensing
board in that state that they'll be seen
and overseen by
the board here in new hampshire through
the board and say new jersey
it's one of the things you could try to
build and draft the saying is that i
incur that if the board of medicine in
new hampshire
has an issue from a patient complaint
here but the providers in new jersey
that they're providing the board of new
jersey oversight to it because you get
into a situation where
one side is in new jersey but the other
side is the patients in new hampshire so
if you could find a way for the boards
themselves to have some sort of
reciprocity about discipline that may
solve the problem
okay thank you
representative folsom
thank you chairman pearson thank you for
taking my question
um
what
happens if
the psychiatrist wants to
prescribe a certain medication and the
patient lives in another state
do we then have some problems with
the pharmacy license i mean can no
never mind my pharmacist just answered
that question in the state of new
hampshire if i may mr chairman stated in
hampshire as long as the
provider who wrote the prescription is
licensed in a respective state
the state of new hampshire pharmacy will
honor it
when i was in practice i was licensed in
maine new hampshire
and massachusetts
and
and i
had a condo in maine
so i used to use that to see patients in
may
until i discovered that maine taxes
your entire
income
in maine
so that
i suddenly stopped seeing those
patients but it's complicated
but
the issue for telehealth
which i've had an interest in for a long
time
was was the way in which that they can
provide services to the north country
and particularly dartmouth hitchcock and
that population
in fact i was so excited i thought we
should get a grant you know to provide
services to children
only to find out that there had been a
grant for the last three years before i
checked in so that
but that has been very successful
but there are these
issues about
a person even being licensed in two
states
that you may find it quite shocking
when
that happens doctor would you join in
it's got to be a question
anyone else
that's a question
good thank you doctor oh thank you very
much look forward to that written
testimony i think an amendment uh
writing team is about to come into
existence and they would really
appreciate what you can send them great
thank you so much thank you
attorneys
phillip bradley and john williams from
dhhs
let me get myself all together in the
right senate and house here we go um so
um good to see you again
chairman pearson good afternoon and
members of the health care
i can't even talk easy for you to say
sir health and human services elderly
affairs committee it really is a
pleasure to come before you again today
um how and i have with me also um
attorney philip bradley
from the department of health and human
services thank you
and philip is our general counsel and he
provides support for legislation as it
relates to our division for behavioral
health so i appreciate him being here
today with me
um the department is here to start off
with our observations and concerns that
we have with section one of the bill
just to give you just a very high level
overlay that section one of the bill has
been designated as being a
responsibility of the department of
health and human services
uh and section two of the bill starting
on line
eight is within the office of
professional licensure and certification
we have the wonderful attorney lindsey
courtney who is the executive director
of the office of professional licensure
and certification she's here today to
answer questions as it relates to her
state agency in addition to that we have
the also wonderful tyler brennan who is
administrator with the new hampshire
insurance department who will be able to
provide a resource to you and the
committee as it relates to what
essentially is the remainder of the bill
starting with sections four starting on
page one line 22 for the remainder of
the bill as it relates to the insurance
department legislation
one observation in looking at line one
is it provides that it's going to amend
rsa 310 a colon 1g by inserting a new
paragraph after that the new paragraph
is a roman 2 lowercase a
in the same way that the department of
health human services has its enabling
legislation for the commissioner to do
global responsibilities and
duties we have ours under rsa 126 a and
it's generally seen in a colon 5. so if
you think about hhs and placement of
where our rulemaking authority this will
make some sense
my following commentary
that rsa
310 dash a colon one is essentially the
equivalent for the office of
professional life insurance
certification it essentially sets up the
duties of the executive director as well
as responsibilities and oversight of the
licensure of certain occupations and
professions under uh that particular
chapter and also under that title
because there's a enormous i should say
enormous but believe me attorney
courtney does an amazing job with a lot
of boards and agencies that fall under
her umbrella so our first observation in
terms of placement is that this new
paragraph that would require
the department to make an assessment
over the number of actual providers
within the state to declare a mental
health emergency
so again the placement of this is within
the office of professional licensure and
certification not dhhs and as much as we
do not want to push our wonderful other
agency under an economic bus that
currently is over the department uh we
just want to make that that note we also
don't license the professionals that are
enumerated in that section it does fall
within the office of professional
licensure and certification so you are
complicating matters a bit even though i
will say that the sponsors of the bill
very well intended in support of access
to telehealth telemedicine which is
something our agency feels very strongly
about but the bill is currently written
um has some
significant mechanical at least
mechanical defect in terms of the
language but also as pointed out by
representative knurk
the department nor the office of
professional licensure certification or
the insurance department uh had an
opportunity to weigh in by doing a
fiscal analysis of the bill so we do
come here before you today to raising at
least concerns as to not only placement
what the language does but it doesn't
provide for any resources for any of the
state agencies involved to provide the
services that are
our additional work that needs to be
done again want to applaud the sponsor
for the bill because she obviously is a
stalwart in terms of promoting access to
health care we also agree with dr hinck
on behalf of both when he was here
presenting on behalf the medical society
and psychiatric
society
that the bill in a high level is is very
well intended but if you look at what's
in front of you and the questions need
to be posed about line by line word by
word what does this actually does do
how does it relate to the bill that you
passed in 2019
um which was senate bill um i believe it
was let's see 232 which came before this
committee as well uh and they created
the psych pack which is essentially the
psychology interstate um um agreement
and so you there's a lot of unanswered
questions there's a lot of work that has
to be done with this bill to even assess
what it actually does and then
determining how does that promote
better access to to care is is an
important question so it requires us in
lines
three through
seven of the bill to do an annual report
and conduct a needs-based analysis
and provide that to the legislature
regarding its determination of whether
to declare a mental health emergency for
that year
beyond the scope of the fact that it
provides for no appropriation it also
doesn't provide with any clear standards
as to the mechanism as to which an
agency whether it's hhs or oplc office
of professional licensure and
certification would trigger that
particular
event so um regrettably we're we're here
today obviously as a resource but in
terms of representative king and i'm
praying that he doesn't ask us the same
question that he asked of miss carbon uh
we are here as a resource and i will do
my best to dodge but i can't do as
diplomatic with the job as miss carbon
did bill do you have anything to
add i don't i i would say that our our
area of expertise here would be more in
the mental health services mental health
services
system not so much the individuals
regulated which is more the realm of
oplc
but if there's anything we could
any questions we could answer concerning
that system we'd be happy to and again
our regulation really concerns the
public mental health system not so much
the private one so we couldn't really
even capture all of the professionals
practicing
that i think the bill would like to
capture
any questions representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
both for taking this question i i heard
you say there's some confusion in terms
of
um
whether this paragraph um roman numeral
2a
should be
whether that task should be tasked to
the office of professional licensure or
whether it should be tasked to the
dhhs
or neither
but if one of those organizations had to
make a determination
and i understand you're saying there's
also not clear criteria but if there was
clearer criteria
departments had to make
this determination
um
it does say it's based it does give a
little criteria that it's based on the
percentage of licensed mental health
professionals
residing in new hampshire if that's
adequate to
cover the needs which i understand is
not maybe that precise
but
my basic question is if one of those two
departments would be in a better
position to make this determination than
the other which would it be
i'm going to defer because i really like
attorney lindsey courtney who's sitting
behind us um this this but if you're
asking in terms of placement currently
it is placed in the oplc statutes if you
look at the preceding paragraph
that deals with telehealth telemedicine
and that's where the attorneys i presume
at the office legislative services found
a home for it under the professional
life insurance certification it is a
marked leap to place this upon the
department of health human services who
do not regulate uh individual uh
licensees under that statute and in fact
if you look at the preceding um
paragraph that's not here because it's
an add-on to that it gives you the whole
host of all the specific chapter to rsas
that are covered under telehealth
telemedicine which also begs without
trying to get into devils into detail
when you talk about licensed mental
health professionals what is that
universe because there's really no
definition we get back to definitions
and accuracy exacting language in bills
and here are you also going to include
or exclude for example those individuals
with co-occurring disorders as it may
relate to the alcohol and other drug use
professionals that are actually licensed
under here so there's a lot of
unanswered questions but i think the
clearest answer in terms of where this
is housed it is housed with the office
of professional licensure and
certification because it comes under
their executive directors and their
agencies authority uh not the
departments so that was a long-winded
answer to your question about who should
be getting this
thank you mr chair and i'll try to take
it easy on you mrs williams
i think what i'm hearing
is that there's two things one and being
conflated
there's a declaration of
emergency which i think should fall
under the department of health and human
services possibly even the legislative
oversight committee
and then number two is a question about
the licensing
so in essence the two agencies really
have two different roles one is that the
department health human services
is the one responsible for declaring the
emergency
but the issue about oplc and licensing
resides with them
is that a fair way
and chairman pearson
as you
will observe from other bills that have
been before you but i'm going to keep it
specific to the language uh question
here that when you typically think of
our commissioner's emergency power
authority it falls under 141c which is
public health not mental so mental
health so this would be even though i
can't disagree that the subject matter
is certainly of importance of the
department access to tell health
telemedicine important to the department
but this is a significant leap in terms
of our current authority for declaring
emergencies based upon
a mental health emergency and i would
ask
the attorney the wonderful attorney i
felt bradley if he has anything else to
offer
sure i i would simply add that that the
information we would need to declare
that emergency would come from uh oplc
which would know the number of licensed
professionals and perhaps have data as
to the correct number uh per 100 000 of
population or something like that which
is probably
information studies have published
so we would have to use information that
comes from another agency
we don't currently have access to that
information as far as i i know
representative merchant follow up
thank you both with the attorneys
um i understand getting data from
another agency i think it's something
you probably as an agency already do
today with other things
so i don't think it's foreign to the
department of health and human services
number two mr williams please
um number two in regards to
your point about public health i
understand what you're trying to get to
and that's what i'm thinking maybe it's
more like the legislative oversight
committee
provides
the will through the department that
authority therefore
you're trading into an area which i
don't disagree with public health this
could be public health but i think
having a legislative oversight committee
being there with the department may help
so chairman pearson to the first
question which is do we
receive information from other state
agencies the answer is absolutely
correct we do work very collaboratively
with state agencies and in many examples
they're obviously the architectures
through legislation that provides the
map for which we would do that
information sharing with them however in
the same respect that you're hearing
from our agency regardless of who ends
up being tasked with this very uh
arguably very important
issue
that there's no funding mechanism in
here to take on base based upon already
the
enormous work that we do um with
resources so there's nothing specific
that i'm aware of that would provide for
us to leverage any funding to be able to
do this and i'm going to ask attorney
bradley to make sure that there's
nothing he might be aware of that i'm
not uh no there's there's there's
nothing else i would just make one more
observation i did find the discussion on
the interstate compact for mental health
counselors
and uh reciprocity very interesting and
perhaps something like that could be
helpful
he's running
he
is now while he's still in the room
he's given lindsay courtney a big gift
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee lindsey courtney executive
director office of professional
licensure and certification
certainly supports the purpose of this
bill
there certainly is a shortage of mental
health workers
i do want to
kind of talk a little bit about what
we've been doing in that sphere in order
to
bridge the gap
as you're all aware you know the
governor issued an executive order back
in
i think it was march of 2020 now that
would authorize the office to issue
emergency licenses based on
having a license in another jurisdiction
we were interested to find
at least in the first couple weeks that
the majority of those that we licensed
were indeed mental health workers a lot
of them were from neighboring states
vermont massachusetts who may
have switched to a telehealth platform
and by virtue of that needed a new
hampshire license i think that was
interesting data that demonstrate
demonstrated what we already know to be
true which is that we have a shortage of
mental health workers in this state
throughout the pandemic we licensed 22
000 health care workers
and 63 percent of psychologists who were
active to practice in new hampshire
during the state of emergency
i think it was 45
of mental health counselors were doing
so only on an emergency license and so i
think that
again is data that demonstrates that we
do have a significant shortage of mental
health workers
in 2020
the general court passed a bill that we
fully supported and requested that gave
the office the authority to issue
temporary licenses for 120 days based on
the same criteria
so as it stands right now if you're a
healthcare professional another state
you apply to the office you present an
informal verification you have a license
in another state
that could just be a screenshot of the
other state's licensing portal
we license you generally in about 24
business hours provided that your
application is complete
and that gives the provider 120 days to
submit their permanent application which
we have found a lot of providers utilize
to hit the ground running start working
and then
seek permanent licensure if they so
desire
there's uh so right now under senate
bill 155 the
22 000 health care licenses that were
issued under the state of emergency are
slated to expire
what we did i think it was uh i don't
know the exact date um earlier this
month we promulgated an emergency rule
through the office
to essentially convert all of those
licenses to temporary licenses for 120
days that was pursuant to the statutory
authority i just referenced
so we
extended those license essentially and
those licenses will expire on may 31st
which gives the general court an
opportunity to figure out what to do
with those licenses
there is a bill pending right now it's
senate bill 277
that would as as drafted
it would
extend those licenses in additional two
years
the office had recommended that rather
than just simply extending the licenses
that we convert those licenses to
permanent licensure which would then
require that the individuals actually
affirmatively do something to to to
request re-licensure but as well as meet
the continuing education and other
requirements established by the boards
it would give the boards an opportunity
to look at those applications
i don't think that proposal is going to
go forward some of our mental health
boards strongly opposed
that proposal
there are a couple of other things in
the works there's senate bill 330 which
would allow the office to
issue licenses to individuals who have a
license that's substantially equivalent
in another jurisdiction a permanent
license
what we learned throughout the pandemic
after issuing 22 000 licenses is that we
only received a handful of complaints
and none went to adjudication
so that to us was a good data
demonstrating that at least if you've
actively practiced another state you've
been vetted by another state we can
reasonably rely on that state and maybe
there's there's not um
sufficient reason for us to impose all
these additional application
requirements so that's senate bill 330.
i don't know where that one's going to
go because a couple of our licensing
boards
in the mental health sphere are
are opposed
the um
we
we have the compact requirement for the
side packed we've also proposed uh
through i think it's senate bill
forget that i forget the actual bill
number but there's a mental health
compact bill we've proposed to join the
mental health compact for mental health
counselors that's going to be going
through this session again this year
that for mental health counselors would
provide greater portability so we talked
about psychologists
this is another way
so i think the state is headed in the
right direction in terms of recognizing
portability um
we do have concerns over the language of
this bill because i'm not sure that it
fully
if it fully does what i think it's
intended to do particularly we have
concerns
that we wouldn't really be adequately
protecting the public so the purpose of
a licensing body and the purpose of a
license is to protect the public within
new hampshire
the
limitation on five patients seems
somewhat arbitrary if the state has
determined that we need a license and we
need to have providers meet certain
licensing requirements in order to
demonstrate minimum competency
why would those five patients not um
not be subject to the benefit of of
having that vetting process
seems a little arbitrary
um
we also
you know
and i appreciate the need for talk
therapy
and certainly mental health counselors
but there is a reason why we
we require licensure for mental health
counselors
this bill would essentially take those
licensees outside the jurisdiction of
any new hampshire licensing body
so
if there was an issue and in the mental
health sphere what we see most
frequently in terms of complaints
is complaints regarding boundaries
people
not adhering to appropriate boundaries
people getting into relationships with
their patients
people who are already
you know vulnerable
expressing things to their therapist
that they wouldn't normally talk to
others about
that's what we see most often and so
there is a need for regulation
under this proposed legislation there's
no new hampshire licensing body
that would actually be able to take
action
on a complaint
if
if the provider did not comply with
rules and regulations so we have we have
some concerns about that
um and then finally practically um
the bill at section three
speaks of a requirement to conduct an
annual audit
we we are not sure what what the audit
would entail i think that certainly that
could be hashed out an amendment um
and of course we would have we would
like an opportunity to do an analysis to
see whether there could be a fiscal
impact
certainly the office like many agencies
are kind of stretched too thin right now
and
so
we have some concerns not knowing what
an audit
would require
happy to take
any questions that you may have
representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman and thank you
for taking the questions i have two
one
relative to discussion during the last
first
how well-suited would the office of
professional licensing be
to um
figure out the criteria for
and analyze whether there is
quotes a mental health emergency
um if that task was fell to your
department
would that work
so i think uh we would need
more direction the office would need
more direction as to what constitutes a
mental health emergency so certainly we
know how many providers we have what we
don't know is how many active providers
are actually practicing a lot of people
keep up with their licenses their
continuing education don't actually
practice so we don't collect that data
so it may not be as reliable as you
would think
i think the general court could
certainly say in legislation um you know
we need x number of providers per you
know thousand individuals and that would
take the discretion out of it
my sense is that you know we're going to
be in a mental health emergency for a
long time um so i i'm not really sure
whether the declaration is required um
to me you know you could just take that
out of it
and i think that would alleviate any
issues
follow up
um yes i'm one of those people with a
license who's not currently working so
and so i so what i heard you say to that
question was that
we could just assume that there's a
mental health emergency for the
immediate future um
getting back to what you said that um
has been done in terms of
um people with a license elsewhere
and i guess we're talking about a lot of
different groups people are using the
term mental health counselors but
they're social workers as mental health
counselors there's
substance use disorder
clinicians
and i'm not even sure if this included
psychiatrists but we did have someone
testify about psychiatrists as well
um
but can you clarify um in terms of the
issue of
um
people currently seeing somebody from
out of state
and that's gonna
the ability to do that will terminate at
the end of january
um it's now may 31st correct if they
have only an emergency license may 31st
crashed okay
so um
that's not going to change until may
31st and you're saying there are some
bills
um
there are currently some bills that
might extend that for quite a ways past
that
correct okay
yep it senate bills uh 277.
it was just heard by senate finance um
that would effectively extend uh these
emergency licenses what we don't know we
have 22 000 licenses but what we don't
know is how many of them have actually
already sought permanent licensure
because the data sets are different
unfortunately when
when you compare the data sets they just
can't be effectively compared so many of
these individuals probably have already
either sought permanent licensure or
they were traveling healthcare workers
that a lot of our facilities are relying
on and the four months or the the time
during the state of emergency was
sufficient
so we really don't know how many
would would continue out of the 22 000
which is why the office proposed that
they be converted so then they would
have to renew and it would give the
licensing board an opportunity to vet
their credentials at that time and the
person would have to affirmatively you
know apply and say yes i still want a
license
one more
so for those people who have already
sought a new hampshire license or do so
before may 31st
they won't be limited to five seeing
five people from new hampshire
there won't be any limits
correct if you have a if you have a new
you you are permitted to provide
services to new hampshire a person
physically located in new hampshire
representative
just a quick question because you gave
that 22 000 number a couple of times
and with your comment about being
travelers is that referring to only
mental health providers or all providers
it's all health care providers
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
so for uh mental health professionals
and actually anyone um any medical
professionals who are licensed in
another state um for
the issue of complaints could the
patient file a complaint with the
licensing board
that is the source of that
professional's license and seek
you know um a resolution that way
i think they certainly could um not
being that jurisdiction i don't know
what i would advise them um because what
gives the licensing board jurisdiction
over the complaint is the fact that the
individual has a license
here i think arguably
because the patient would be physically
located in new hampshire new hampshire
law would apply
new jersey law wouldn't apply
so
um
i guess that would be an open question i
don't know i'd have to
have to go back and take a look it's not
clear
i did see another hand representative
merchant
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here direct according
21-2
which talks about positions
key to that was that the physician
is taking responsibility for the
out-of-state position
could that same concept be applied here
with a mental health worker
where there's a
person in the state who's taken
responsibility therefore there is some
jurisdiction of our state
over some
licensed individual
and they're taking on responsibility for
the person from out of state
i think that's true i think that could
certainly happen i think the other
distinction in 329 is that those who
provide consultation services don't
actually have a physician-patient
relationship and i think that would be
different here and that
the new hampshire provider
the new hampshire license provider
wouldn't be the one actually providing
the services they would be the out of
state and they would develop that
thank you very much thank you for your
time
and our friend from the new hampshire
insurance department tyler brennan come
thank you tyler brennan life and health
director with the new hampshire
insurance department
and we do not have a position on the
bill and i'm going to address just the
insurance sections i think so far we've
just heard more about licensing
but there is a substantial component to
the insurance side and just by way of
background we actually already have
fairly broad coverage requirements when
it comes to telemedicine and that
section is under 415j and it's even
titled the new hampshire telemedicine
act
it requires coverage of all healthcare
services through telemedicine insurance
company can't deny just because it went
through telemedicine it includes all
forms of telemedicine including audio
only coverage
um so what this bill does has adds a new
section not to the telemedicine act but
separately under under 415 so it's a
little bit of an anomaly because it
would be redundant in terms of the
requirement at least as it relates to
covering mental health care services and
through telemedicine
we also have very detailed network
adequacy requirements in new hampshire
we have a statute and a very detailed
set of rules that stipulates time and
distance standards that you must be able
to access health care services to
the insurance company can satisfy those
network adequacy standards using
telemedicine so if they have a health
care provider whether it be in state or
out of state that can perform the
service through telemedicine the carrier
can provide that locally to anybody who
can get access through it so there is a
natural incentive for an insurance
company to look for where they can
obtain care by an in-network provider
using telemedicine and may even be a
financial incentive since new hampshire
has reimbursement parity with in-person
visits you find an out-of-state provider
where there is no in-person equivalent
it's relatively open negotiation in
terms of how much you might pay that
health care provider
so the actual bill just requires
coverage of an out-of-network mental
health care provider and so that's
probably pretty easy for all our
insurance companies to to satisfy
i haven't heard it discussed including
my sponsor but
when i read the bill i thought
they may actually be thinking about not
just healthcare providers that are out
of state but providers that are out of
network
and that's a pretty loaded issue so even
though it's limited to five patients
there's not much detail there's not any
detail in the bill about how you would
resolve sort of how much that health
care provider is going to be paid
cost sharing protection to the patient
not to have to pay more than cost
sharing claims processing all of the
sort of requirements that you would
expect when you go to an in-network
provider in new hampshire including new
hampshire laws that are actually include
provider contract standards so if you do
intend to cover out-of-network providers
in this capacity
it would mean going through a number of
very controversial
decisions because it does deal with
payment levels and that means it's
probably more of a bill that should go
so i'll stick with the insurance and
i'll end there happy to take any
representative soloway
is there likely to be pressure
by the insurers to reduce rates of
reimbursement
um you mean very generally speaking is
there is there going to be pressure yeah
there
there has been a lot of interest in
research that shows savings when people
access healthcare through telemedicine
the insurers were not particularly
interested in seeing the reimbursement
parity legislation that passed but there
is some evidence coming forward that
when you access healthcare through
telemedicine it can be more cost
effective it can keep people out of the
emergency department and so i think to
the extent that an insurer is always
looking for where they can get the most
cost effective care that's going to
continue to be their interest regardless
what happens with this particular bill
and maybe that answers the question you
have
uh in between the lines yes thank you
thank you mr brennan great thank you
and
the model
of patience holding down the back corner
representative
megan murray
i've been holding on to your card for
thank you mr chair and it's a pleasure
to be back before you again my name is
megan murray and i represent the town of
amherst new hampshire
um and i do in
um
for as for as many um
issues that we have i do support the
idea of
this piece of legislation for several
reasons
i am
increasingly receiving calls from
constituents who are with great
consternation expressing to me
their concern over an interruption in
their service
whether it has been
somebody
who has just recently relocated to the
state
and is then having to seek care
and it's not um and i do understand the
testimony before us behind us
uh with respect with the extent with
respect to the extensions
that said
um
the communication that individuals are
having from their health care providers
has not been that and therefore i have
been contacted
um one of the other issues that i have
been made aware of was that in addition
to just
telehealth services
general health care services as well
that were
potentially going to be interrupted as a
result that individuals would be
participating remotely
um and so
where we go from here with this specific
piece of legislation i don't know that
is
under your purview but i would i would
say that
um
the increasing concern that individuals
seem to be having over the fact that
their services could potentially be
interrupted whether it's ending in
january
or in may i think is problematic and so
if this
bill is not the vehicle then how else do
we get there to make sure that we have
continuity of care for individuals
and aside from that i
don't have anything else for you unless
saying none thank you so much thank you
as i've been listening to the testimony
i've come to two conclusions
number one
as the part-time ceo of a medical
facility with three
family practice providers i know very
well
the importance of this this is important
stuff to a lot of people
but the second conclusion i've come to
is listening to
the various people bringing testimony
saying this reference needs to change
this paragraph needs to go somewhere
else this doesn't work here and so on
we have two choices
one is
to appoint a subcommittee that is
probably going to have to completely
re-research and rewrite this bill
you've heard all the reasons why
or we're going to say to this primary
sponsor and others
great ideas now you heard the testimony
too
you go off and rewrite it and come back
next year with something those really i
don't see another choice in here so if
there is sentiment i'm talking to the
committee now um
if there is sentiment for a group of you
to rewrite the bill i'm not going to
stand in your way
but if there isn't there's the other
choice representative shapiro and then
canark
i think there is one other alternative
the director of olpc
referenced several senate bills that
were going to extend
temporary licenses
and
people could get on board with working
on one of those bills i think she
referenced two or three of those bills
so um
prime sponsor are you aware of those
senate bills
pretty much
do you think those would be the kind of
vehicles yeah come on up this is
um yes i i think as a school of fish
whatever bakes it right
sure
yeah um representative canark is next uh
yes sb 277 is one that just extends it
for two years automatically and it would
seem to me that if we put our i mean
we've done this often where we have two
bills and one of them is going to be a
better solution coming out of the senate
that will give a longer horizon doesn't
set up all of the difficulties of having
to declare an emergency that may go on
forever anyway
and um automatically just gives us the
two years to keep working on this uh so
i would think that may be a better
solution overall not that i don't like
the idea it's just it may be a more
workable solution
we want to do the best for all the
caring and hard work you've done to get
something along representative soloway
thank you mr chairman taking a page out
of representative wood's playbook i'd
like to go to the 30 000 foot uh view
um
and as we operate one of the things that
uh we have a principle we've operated on
for the years that i've been on this
committee is it is not our
responsibility
to rewrite
legislation
if the proponent of legislation cares to
suggest amendments if members of the
committee wish to come in with
amendments but rewriting legislation is
not our job and as you indicated earlier
when you brought this subject up it is
always the prerogative of the uh
initial
provider of the bill to rewrite it for
next year and i would like to suggest
that we take a very conservative view of
our role in rewriting legislation we
already have an excessive workload thank
you mr chairman representative it always
warms my heart when i hear you use the
representative leon thank you mr
chairman
senate bill 330 was also mentioned and
that one was actually a request of the
office the professional licensure and
certification so i i think your idea was
shared by many and i think maybe we
should let the senate run with the ball
on this one and then send it to us in my
opinion
representative woods
now thank you just a question for the
all the sponsors and co-sponsors are you
working with the commission on
telehealth
um that's active and it's
doing a much of the same sort of
processing
um thank you for your question we've
been working mostly with nami
um and again uh
we've been
we've been doing the best we can
and i just want to i don't know if it's
appropriate since it sounds like you
guys are kind of an executive session
right now well you know we were
wondering that up here okay
we're technically not we're lurching
towards it okay i just want to say on
the record for every single committee in
this body and with all due respect to
representative soloway i think it's
entirely inappropriate to kill a bill
just because it's not perfect when you
hear an intent that is really needed and
when you have an over surmounting amount
of constituents in a life or death
situation to not at least give it the
old college try
representative
i don't know
my hearing aids are running out now it
is oh it's good
thank you mr chairman and
i'm bothered by the fact that and this
raises a question in my mind about how
to move forward but i received two
emails from members of the board of
licensure just recently one from the
chair and one from someone else and each
time we've considered changes in
licensure nobody from that board ever
shows up
to give their point of view and yet they
oppose all these bills
i think if they can't make a
contribution and they have a strong
opinion about this we ought to hear
about it before we try to redraft or do
anything to avail i apologize to this
woman that she got very little help from
them but i think at least we ought to
pass the information along to the senate
that we receive no assistance from this
board and that we think i think either
of those that would extend it in some
other way either for the two years or as
as he said to the give the board of the
board of relationships
really go ahead but if they can't even
come in here and let us know why they so
strongly object to this bill i don't
feel we need to take any
thank you representative representative
kanark sorry it just took me a moment to
find it but uh sb 277 did pass out a
committee six to zero ought to pass
so i think there's a high probability we
do you like this bill that senate bill
yeah but i would think we could perhaps
also given the may 31
expiration date perhaps we could ask
that the senate would expedite this over
to us and we should act upon it the
house very rapidly speak to your
higher-ups in your party see what they
can do and i'll run to the speaker too
um
well being a republican bill i thought
maybe you might uh speak to your
higher-ups instead
it did have just about every senator on
it
just about every senator uh
sponsored this bill
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman also thank you mr
sorry representative conner um help me
understand because i'm trying to find
out on that bill
it looked like it went to the house
finance committee
my concern is that if it crosses over to
the house
is that it comes to this committee and i
go into either eda edna
or some other committee because it seems
like a lot of the expertise is here
and not in other committees in the house
so do you know where it actually started
in the senate
it's um i'm sorry let me i should be
should be able to say
anybody know
it went to finance in the senate
it went to finance and senate so it came
out of the finance
there
i don't know what department he would
come to here
obviously so mr
mr chairman i guess the question to you
is the leader of our committee how can
we somehow work with the
leadership and the house to have that
well as they said it's my party so i got
to do it
um what i would suggest
yeah please just the thing is licensure
issues are usually
our plc and that goes to edna eddie so i
would think actually it would probably
be more appropriate in edna than us even
though we have the technical
the health expertise
but it might go might be a two committee
bill i'm not give it to the other
representative pearson i like that
he's on edna
uh let me suggest this that um
we don't have to decide this right now
can we um you know chew on this for a
week or so and see what we can do with
the senate and you've got some ideas and
you know i i mean we're most of us are
fixits here we like to make things
really good although i do really
appreciate the two-year extension
just like the last extension
was january 31st per the government
governor's executive order and now
there's another extension to may 31st
that all providers aren't really being
made aware of and they're dropping
patients already and so to allow this
body the responsibility to continue to
kick the can down the road in language
is i think
really irresponsible of us
well the problem is that you heard all
of the different
this needs to be changed and that is in
the wrong spot and so on it's a lot of
work to you know to get this one up to
speed here
i think all of your work notwithstanding
i understand and i appreciate all the
work and unfortunately i think that's
what we signed up for
that's why we get the big bucks okay
with that i'm going to close the hearing
on 1405 and take a five-minute mental
health break
okay
um
oh
yes
[Music]
is
yes
videos
um
is
okay
i open the hearing on house bill 1659
relative to criminal history background
checks for certain health care workers
presenting the bill is representative
abrami and he is vice chair of ways and
means so if you wonder where the money
comes from that we get to spend
norm major and pat abrami are the guys
that get the money so you got to treat
me well guys no
well thank you mr chair uh just for the
record state reporter brahmi
rockingham 19
stratum
and
let me just read you some prepared
remarks here and
i was asked by the new hampshire health
care association and the new hampshire
hospital association to file this bill
to help with the current staffing
shortages for nursing homes and
hospitals and additionally reinstate a
law that was passed in 2017 sb 152
which sunset in 2019 right before the
pandemic hit
this the issue this bill is addressing
are criminal background checks which
must be completed on anyone who is
required to be licensed or certified
licensed
and is being employed by residential
care and health care facility
namely nursing homes or hospitals
the healthcare providers in the state
have been struggling with workforce
shortages for years but the last two
years have been even more challenging
in part due to the pandemic
the process to get healthcare clinicians
licensed is time-consuming and is
further delayed by the criminal backed
background check
process the department of safety has
done a terrific job recently opening a
portal for state criminal background
checks for anyone however
the health care facilities must have
national fbi
backed as well as state background
checks the department of safety portal
only does new hampshire criminal
background checks
this would this bill would allow the
health care facilities to utilize a
third party vendor to complete the
federal background check
which is requirement of of health care
facilities licensing under rsa 151 colon
2-d
these
these third-party vendors can both
can do both federal and state checks in
one process
the bill does not preclude a facility
from using the new hampshire department
of safety
it just gives the facilities an option
to use whoever they choose
and and
whichever is most expedient
this bill does not eliminate the
requirement
of health care facilities to complete
the criminal background check for all
employees
it just removes the language in health
facilities licensing statute to obtain
the criminal background checks results
from the department of safety only
this small change
will expedite the ability of these
facilities to get health care clinicians
on the job helping their patients in a
more expedited fashion
thank you mr chair
there will be representatives from the
new hampshire healthcare association and
new hampshire
hospital association who will be
testifying on this bell
and they are willing to come up together
and do this to hopefully answer your
questions all at the same time
matter of fact i would probably defer
questions be asked to them because that
will save even more time
so thank you thank you both for your
chair calls theresa rosenberger and
i just want you to remember i have 37
with that i'll start while she's passing
out onto teresa rosenberger
representative o'brien that was left
when she had two minutes to speak and
she was 37 seconds to the good so she
so i'm theresa rasenberger from
bernstein shure and i'm here today on
behalf of the new hampshire new
hampshire healthcare association nursing
homes and we had
um specifically asked representative
abrami to put his bill in and it's okay
i'll talk quickly then we'll let paula
of the hospital association speak um
there was a bill a law that was passed
in 2017.
oh sorry
uh in 2017
we believe it or not did have staffing
shortages in the nursing homes
particularly with lna's licensed nursing
assistants so in 17 the um
healthcare association put in a piece of
legislation
that allowed
folks who had gone to school and were
waiting for their licensing
as an lna and had been hired by a
facility to actually work temporarily
for 90 days
while they were awaiting the licensing i
mean excuse me the criminal background
check it was taking
almost 90 days at that time to get a
check there was a staffing issue and
you'll see in the legislation they had
to be under the supervision of a
licensed provider et cetera et cetera
so that bill passed in 17
unbeknownst to well i shouldn't say
anyone knows my client but my client
called me up this year and kind of said
what gives the state all of a sudden
start stopped allowing the 90-day
temporary
licensure for people waiting for their
criminal background checks lnas and i
said well the state can't just do that
he said they did so i looked at the law
and guess what it was repealed
in 2019 and i think at the time bob dunn
was working for the nursing home homes
at that point i think they truly believe
by 19 the state and the department's
safety would have their portal up for
criminal background checks and this
wouldn't be an issue
it repealed
we have the pandemic and as you all know
the situation is far worse than it was
in
2017. when the legislation was put forth
so what we did is we literally put
exactly the same language in as was in
the statute in 2017
and then my friend paula manahan calls
me up and says hey can i jump under your
bill
for hospitals and in full disclosure i
also represent north country health
which are the critical assets hospitals
in the north country and so
we talked about it
and i said sure you can you can jump on
and we asked representative romney if it
would be all right because they have
some of the same situation
we are not in any way asking that there
not be criminal background checks
we fully believe there should be state
and federal we're just asking to
expedite the process right now if you
are
hoping to be an lna
you have to have a state criminal
background check to attend school
after you finish your schooling you have
to have a state and federal background
check in order to get a license as an
lna
and if
one of my nursing homes hires you you
also have to have an additional state
and federal
federal
criminal background check and as you see
in the legislation
it specifically references department of
safety
and we will be the first to say they
have done an unbelievable job with this
new portal that it was just recently
opened we met with them this summer and
up and this fall
everybody says it's dynamite and it is
unfortunately it only does a state check
it doesn't do the federal
so right now if you want to be in lna
and work in a nursing home you still got
to go through three checks two of which
have to be federal so we're just asking
that
that language that says department of
safety be removed if you want to go to
safety you can and if you want to go to
a third party but you've got to have the
checks it's the bottom line you've got
to have a state check
and the state and federal check so paula
it's all yours thank you teresa
and again for the record my name is
paula minihan
senior vice president state government
relations for the new hampshire hospital
association we are in strong support of
1659 and we do thank the sponsor
representative obrami
and all the co-sponsors including a
couple that are sitting on this
committee for agreeing to sponsor this
legislation it is very important as
representative obrami articulated what
it does
and teresa's right when i saw the lsr i
immediately
reached out to representative abrami and
found out
that the healthcare association had put
this in i reached out to teresa and then
we started working together so there are
two components of this bill but as she
said
um it helps health care facilities in
general but the hospitals specifically
we have heard through
working with our hr folks um for years
that they use often um a third party and
pt research is an example um that they
have used for years um so what happens
is because of the way the language the
current statute specifically states
department of safety you have to go
through the department of safety
and they use as a condition of
employment a they have to do their own
um checks and so they go through they
you they pay for through the third party
another fbi check so it's duplicative
it's expensive it's um
unnecessary and um and time consuming so
by taking those words out again it's um
it allows it's silent on whether or not
you use department of safety as teresa
said so it doesn't prohibit anyone from
using them but
it gives some flexibility and
this is a very important bill for our
members
and um we again are very appreciative of
um representative obrami and all the
sponsors um
and i'm happy to answer any questions
but that's it's a pretty i that's pretty
much um
exactly what it does
i have a question on page 1 line 29
under the direct
supervision would you define how direct
direct supervision is here
[Music]
well in a nursing home direct
supervision we have a myriad of
different
licensed
categories of so
in this case because these nurses are
not
permanently like these lnas are not
permanently licensed they're working
under under a nurse and a registered
nurse
or anyone who is licensed and qualified
in the facility
let me rephrase that
does that mean the person who is under
direct supervision is never out of the
watchful eye of somebody over him or her
well they have to go to the bathroom
i'm sorry well i don't mean that but i
mean can they go into a patient's room
to do whatever they do without another
staff person present
i'll have to get back to you on that i
think they are part of a team so they
have to be with the staff person and so
therefore
if one person may be doing one
one
duty and another another in the same
room but i will get back to you why i
ask that is because my mother was in a
nursing home
in met
in
and somebody was provisionally licensed
and when they finally got the background
in there they fired the person on the
spot
my mother was not in danger because that
person was never alone with my mother
was assisting was working as part of a
team
so i can understand that but if you're
saying we're turning some people loose
here
it's supervision
in a paper flow chart
that raises some questions i will double
check for you um and also please note
that in here it says you have to have
had a criminal background check within
12 months understood now that doesn't
mean they couldn't have done something
within those 12 months
but but i will double check and get back
to you thank you representative kanark i
think you actually have two one as a
follow-up on yours and that is because
in most cases direct supervision means
yes we're supporting but we
we often they are not in the room at the
same time so i was wondering whether we
should have something in this to clarify
under visual direct supervision
that's one that's just a question to
follow up in his the other one was was i
was going to ask representative abrami
that question about who does this other
background check and you talked about
third parties but i don't see any
mechanism in here about how we
credential that third party i mean you
know
it would seem like anybody could just
kind of you know set up their little
thing and do this
do we have any standards for
credentialing that third party to make
sure that they are doing proper
background checks and records
i will check with the hr directors and
find out um they
um contract with them so they and they
pay for those services and they're done
throughout the country as my
understanding um but let me get back to
you on what the pro
process is for them choosing these third
parties to do this follow-up and then a
follow-up on that is given the fact that
the cost on page 2 line 11 the cost of
the check is borne by the licensee or
certificate holder
um once they have had this check and
let's say they
decide they want to be going to a
different place to work
are they provided with a copy of that so
that they have that as a portability
does that have to pay that a second time
to apply to another place in other words
i guess does it follow the licensee who
was applying or does it only stay with
the institution and that licensee has to
keep paying over and over even if just a
few weeks later they decide they don't
like that job and want to go somewhere
else
so
the
first part is the responsibility of the
facility to
as a condition of employment they must
make sure that they have done that fbi
check so it is not borne by the licensee
there's also the licensee is getting
licensed um as a clinician so there's
that process as well that's why it's a
little confusing but
they're the hospitals um i'll just speak
for them they
as a condition of employment they must
ensure that they they have gone through
this um check um this fbi check just a
clarification follow-up sure
you said not formed by the licensee but
this does that it is borne by the
licensee are we talking about the
licensing of the person or a licensee of
an institution well where is that uh
you know we talk about licensed
healthcare facilities and licensed
providers what kind of license are we
that's what i thought it would seem like
so the provider has to carry these no
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i misspoke
in order for the nursing home to be
licensed
they have to do the criminal background
check before they can hire these folks
so and at least
when i've talked to our nursing homes
the nursing homes pay for it so so the
licensee in this case is the institution
not the person
because
this is this statute is having to do
with residential health facility
sorry it's no matter what
the facility has to do the criminal
background check which includes state
and federal in order to hire the person
anyone else
thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question on
the federal background check
is there one source for the check in
other words regardless of who request
federal background check
is it going to be the same
is it basically standardizes the federal
level when i request the federal
background check so it really doesn't
matter
who requests the background check at the
federal level the report is going to
come back the same
is that that is i will confirm that
representative but that's my
understanding is the process is the same
that they they check every single state
um for um any criminal history on that
individual that you're hiring so i think
the i think you're right but i will
confirm that thank you yeah follow up
follow up
in regards to
the
about the licensing
i think once you have the federal
background check and it goes in the
personnel file
in essence it becomes part of their
record and they're entitled to it so i
would also go back onto a line
page two
line three
has provided the facility and the
licensee which is the provider a copy of
the criminal history check
for two reasons one is it should be part
of their property this is in the record
number two if they have a question about
the history they can speak to it at that
representative not a robin
is it on it's on would you believe i've
been trying to renew my psychotherapy
license through the office of
professional licensure
which i mailed in in july
and in september i hear oh you need your
fbi check
oh
and where do i do that well you can go
to salem
uh
we can give you an appointment in three
weeks
and it may take
four five or six weeks for the report to
come back
by which time the committee who meets
once a month has met two or three more
times and i've missed the boat again
would you believe that
so i would think any mechanism that
would speed this along and gather in a
third party
you know registered official
up and up
organization to speed this along
would be an excellent idea if i had had
a job offer it would have been blown
so
and i have already been licensed in the
state of new hampshire for 15 years
they have all my original paperwork and
like why do i need an fbi check but one
that takes five six weeks is ridiculous
now what do you believe i i believe you
um however i do believe you represent
and that's hard to see you over there um
but there you are um nice to see you so
this was in august
is that what you said i i do believe
would you believe that um the process
has um improved
significantly what happened in july
august
at the state at the state oh okay great
because and their backlog what happened
when the state of emergency was lifted
um all of one of the
90 emergency orders that i are the
executive orders that i mentioned
earlier today one of them had to do with
criminal background checks that went
away
immediately overnight the backlog at the
department of safety plummeted uh i mean
expanded um so
so then um we immediately had a
big problem and the department of safety
has been extraordinary in trying to help
move this whole process along because
they became really backlogged very
quickly that's why things have gotten
much better and this portal has helped
on the state side which gives them more
opportunity to work on the federal fbi
side of things because it's the same
staff that has to to do this and i
thought there was someone from the
department of safety here and maybe they
are still here yep they're good
so i am not going to speak for them but
i um
they are working very hard to address
this so i think they would believe it i
think things have gotten better my my
state check
i just drove up to concord i waited 20
minutes in the hallway and i had it so
they did their job great
yeah thank you yeah okay and i do think
the other thing that we we have not
mentioned here are the people who hoping
to be employed
and you you can't be employed unless you
have these checks and you've got your
license so without this
you've got lna sitting out there that
have finished their coursework they're
waiting for their licensing and they've
got a job offer and they
don't you know so then the question is
do they sit and wait to be an lna or do
they go
work somewhere else and so it's just
it's just a snowballing situation we
just
trying to get more bodies on the floor
thank you
in regards to this bill i keep hearing
the word lna but the way this seems to
be written it applies to any employee
including volunteers the scope of
employment for direct
contact with the patient
plant records plant tissue battery
fluids and so forth
that goes way beyond an lna i mean there
are physical therapists therapists and
there there's nurses in there so we're
just talking about lnac here are we
talking about the whole scoop
you've got the nursing homes and the
hospital and the bill that we put in in
17 and the bill the part of this bill
that we put in
for this year or asked representative
abrami to was specifically dealing with
the lnas because that's where we were
having the real problem and then when
paul in the hospital association came in
that's when it's clinicians and expanded
so
i mean frankly
i think it's what is it line
it's page 1 line 25
through
page two line six
that is the original bill from 2017
that the hot the nursing homes put in
specifically for lnas and also on the
back page the boldest
section so we've combined
the clinicians with the lnas i hope that
would that make sense
yes and no um
mr chairman
thank you sir um
i'm still getting hung up here between
one part of the bill speaking to one
scope of practitioners another one
speaking to a limited scope of
practitioners so i'm not sure exactly
this bill
which one we're trying to accomplish or
if there's one another way to word it
because if you go to page two
talks again nursing program approved by
the board of nursing so we're in some
parts of the bill talking specifically
to lna right other parts of bill we're
talking about broader scope of
clinicians generally speaking so
if you go back and look on page one
any employee
correct
so when you get into that it goes beyond
an lna
yeah which i think is what the heart is
amending two different rsas yeah yeah
but
it's because i glommed on to their bill
because i was trying to
create one less bill that you guys had
representative gay
i apologize for coming in late uh this
deal about any employee
because the whole bill seems to be
written for lnas and we all know there
is a crying need for lna's
crying need
uh in my town too
do we
is it going to hurt the bill
i want everybody's opinion they're going
to hurt the bill if we leave this to any
employee is that going to be a hiccup
or
or can we leave it in there because
you know we definitely need to
give a temporary passage to be an lna is
it going to hurt anything if we do the
same temporary thing and my other is
would you believe
that i
be interesting to know what has to be
approved to get the
pending the results of the criminal
history
the gun line is working now and it works
in you know
less than a day
what's the difference
between the requirements of passing
the gun line as a passing to work and
take care of people
it's still the department of safety and
i'm going to defer to the
expert that works at the department of
safety to answer that because they're
i would not recommend expanding it this
is specific to lnas
and lindsey courtney who's testified
earlier is in charge of oplc and they
again have many many bills on that
they're working through to try to
address
some of the other issues with other
clinicians this is very focused on lnas
and then again
the part of the statute that i requested
representative obrami to change had to
do with the health facilities licensing
and just removing the department of
safety from that
section to try to make it easier and
more flexible that's really all so i may
be having a brain cramp at the moment
but line page 1 line 16 it applies to
volunteers
did i have a brain cramp
that's current law
so it's still there okay it's not it's
not going to change the point of
information is anybody who has contact
better now thank you yeah
we are just i think i think
what the sections of the hospital
association wanted to bring in is really
trying also
to expedite what the representative they
needed to hire a clinician
then again safety's done a fabulous job
and you can get your state background
check back in minutes but
you can get your state background check
back in minutes but it's the federal
side so we're just trying across the
board
trying to say we're not changing the
rules you're going to continue to have
to have that federal check we just want
to be able to do it in the most
expedited manner and if it turns out the
department of safety eventually is the
fastest and the least expensive my guess
is people that's where people will go
but
if that's the next step i think you can
ask the
the gentleman in the back but that's the
next step so we're just trying to get
people on the job
any further questions who are qualified
yeah right yeah we're trying to do that
thank you so much and uh state police
thank you chairman and thank you for
members of the committee
my name is victor muzzy i am currently
the commander of record information
services for the new hampshire state
police which luckily today encompasses
the gun line or our permits and
licensing unit in the criminal records
unit so
i think the state police by and large
i'll start off by saying is in support
of this i think we um pursuant to what's
been discussed the troubles that we had
with the executive order being lifted
the rush of folks that we saw have to do
background checks on and other things
contributed to our delay over the summer
which thank you for the credit and
working through that and i think we are
at a
more sustainable point at this point
with our backlog
i think um it's important to note and my
concern would be um as i think it's been
brought up here this afternoon
um
i i don't know what the third party
check consists of i don't know what that
means i don't know how that's
credentialed and certainly if the
members of the committee decide that's
the route that they want to go then then
that would be fine my concern would be
what does that really mean
and i think to speak
in regards to the federal process and
why that's so cumbersome let's call it
um is a result of of the process that we
go through in which to retrieve that
record which as most of you are probably
familiar with requires the applicant to
get fingerprinted
typically at one of our live scan
machines which is uh ever so helpful
um if we if they get printed by uh ten
print ink cards as we call them the
manual fingerprint cards that everyone
is probably familiar with that requires
an extra step for us
our folks actually have to scan that
fingerprint card into some software
where they then do some quality control
and some pre um classification of that
fingerprint ahead of it's being sent to
the fbi
our aphis machines as they're referred
to the automated fingerprint
identification systems that we have um
where we're electronically capturing
those prints does a couple things a the
prints are far more clear
and the rejection rate now that's the
rejection rate from the fbi not from the
state police the rejection rate
goes down quite significantly for us
we're able to obviously we have that
electronic file for those fingerprint
images that we're able to process much
more quickly but i will say it does
require a set of human eyeballs to look
at each set of fingerprints that we
collect for an applicant that
causes
some of that delay so our people our
experts in the in the unit
have to actually classify those
fingerprints um
quality control them classify them ahead
of them being sent off to the fbi the
fbi gets those fingerprints
they
look at our preliminary determination
they make some further findings as to
classifying those and quality
controlling them and then they send us
back
15 exemplar potential fingerprint
matches
it's our job to then go through those
matches and ultimately go back and forth
with the fbi until a final determination
as to
verifying this person's identity through
their fingerprints from that we then
match
that fbi record to those fingerprints so
again i can't account for what a
third-party vendor may do in that
instance that's what we do
and that's what contributes to that
delay i can tell you that our focus has
largely been the applicant uh prince as
all of you are probably well aware as
it's as it's pressing for us also
um so that as a result of that our
criminal side of fingerprint
identification and submission to the fbi
for our arrests has created a backlog
we're in a backlog for that at the
moment so
hopefully that helps explain a little
bit of of a couple things why the
process gets delayed um and the reason
for that um and again we're in support
of the bill and our only concern would
be what how are these third-party
vendors credentialed what are what are
the uh prospective employers really
getting for a records check i don't i
don't know what the result of those
things are um or what they may or may
not be
um
how official quote unquote that record
may or may not be so
um i hope that answers the the topics
that have been discussed and i'm happy
to take any questions any questions for
the lieutenant representative canark yes
since i was the one that asked that
question about credentialing of these
third parties do you have any idea of
are there any national standards there's
any credentialing agency or anything
i'll have to get back to you on that it
seems we've had a couple of
conversations about that
um and what stands out in my mind is
that i'm not sure that the federal check
by a third party vendor would be
fingerprint supported meaning
the federal check may be run for
convictions but the identity of that
person
may or may not be confirmed via the
fingerprints but don't quote me on that
that's that's what comes to mind based
upon
a couple of ancillary conversations i've
had relative to third-party checks
representative would you thank you would
you then suggest that we would
uh
perhaps amend this by adding some
language that would identify
how it is credentialed but if there's if
there is no credentialing we have no
idea how they're credentialed i'm not
sure what language we could add so can
you give me some guidance on that yeah
and i don't have that guidance at the
moment i don't know what the language
should be relative to that i'd have to
research myself
um and and perhaps find out
about the third party vendor i'm not
opposed to that at all i think from a
safety standpoint though i can't
i don't know how that would
it may be perfectly fine uh honestly i
just don't know the answer if that's my
only concern
thank you thank you
saying i think the only other thing i
can speak to is the gun line question as
to why the gun line is quicker
i think because when it when a record
check is run through the gun line it's
not supported with fingerprints it's
simply seeing what is on the record
versus
doing all that preliminary homework to
determine that we have the right person
in front of us i think i think nothing
from aphis
that's correct okay
okay actually sir anybody understands
you're on a roll yeah could we ask you
to forward that information to us your
concepts about the credentialing because
if that is a sticking point it's hard
for us to process this bill unless we've
got that information i can do that is
there an email or a particular
venue that that should be sent to
the
committee
all house members of the health human
of our committee yeah yeah not not all
house members not all the house members
yes ma'am on our committee yeah if you
go to the committee page it has email
all committee members perfect click very
very good hhs e a lecture
dot nh dot u s
okay representative canuck would you be
happy to take up a little amendment
committee i don't think it would be much
but it would be addressing that and
quite possibly
page 1 line 29 my
desire to see the word visual added in
there it is under direct visual
supervision
rather than merely administrative
i i would think so i'm not sure any much
of a committee i would just be glad to
just
do it i would think uh if someone
yeah i mean just it doesn't have to be
yeah i mean the two of you have the same
concern about visual because we've both
supervised people where you know you're
not even the same place but we're their
direct supervis supervisor
well that's not enough for me exactly
because they if they're a convicted
elderly abuser you don't want them in
there take care of them so if
representative woods and representative
kinerick would do this this would be a
i hope everybody got that it's too late
in the afternoon
okay yes representative gay
thank you um what is this uh third party
that
is this a third party we're going to use
to make the fbi happy or whatever
i believe there are third party vendors
that will supply
federal
record checks for a cost
what that means or what they have at
their disposal i don't know that's i
guess our concern i i have to do the
research on that myself to understand
follow-up and and that is permitted by
the fbi that they accept these
third-party people
it's
it's permitted it would in this case
would be permitted by the employer
as to
where that check came from i think
i guess i would equate it to
a google search where you're going to
get whatever you're going to get back
from the internet i don't know what
venue these this this third-party
supplier of background checks i don't
know where they're getting that they may
be getting it directly from the fbi and
if so then i think that would be
sufficient for the purposes of the check
i just don't know the answer to that and
that would be my only concern is to
determine that
one more
so if say a nursing home
is trying to
match
trying to fulfill all the requirements
it sounds like this is a federal
requirement
so that's why i was wondering that would
the federal requirement be satisfied by
a third party
they would no no good question
is it
representative speak to it no i don't
know i said it's a good question it is a
good question oh i thought you had a
i'm sorry i forget i can't speak so loud
in a math um the hospitals and the
nursing homes now accept the third party
checks
and they have to be
and i i will find out
about what the credentialing is etc but
in order to see if i can even get you
what maybe they they give you back
but it's what
the most important thing is we have to
meet
the licensing guidelines the federal and
the state guidelines should be licensed
and if you don't meet that then
obviously you can't run a nursing home
or a hospital so i think everybody's
trying to be very careful
about what they do but i'll get you the
so my life's work i consulted in
hospitals for 43 years so wow
yeah i did operations consulting i
i work with every department in
hospitals
hr departments tend to
uh
basically uh
shift
the burden of having to do the
background checks to these third parties
that aren't really doing the checks
they're just doing the paperwork
affiliate you know instead of one of
their people having to do it
that's what happens but they're still
going through the fbi they're doing all
of that
so but i i think what we can do is i
would suggest to uh both associations
that they get one of their members to
clarify that that's exactly what's going
on
um and there are reputable firms i mean
this is very common across the country i
consulted all over the country
and
using
third parties to
help them process get the paperwork
through but they they they don't do the
check themselves they are doing the
reaching out to
whoever in that state or and as well as
the fbi
to uh to get the backgrounds checked so
but
perhaps i'm sure um
teresa and paula are going to
talk to their members and give you some
real life examples of
to confirm that as well
and that should go to representatives
connect and woods who are the amendment
team on this the tweaking team okay i
know both of them well yeah
okay
all right thank you
so this ends the hearing
on house bill 1659 thank you
representative brahmi and
teresa and paula and lieutenant who's
left and so on
um i asked the ranking
or asked
the co-ranking
democrat member if she had any
objections with a couple of these bills
because it didn't look like we had any
objections on our side of the playground
either
so
including
this opens the hearing the exec session
on house bill 1327
including diabetes and the conditions
listed for eligibility for a service
animal and you remember senator
shaheen's grand
daughter and grand dog and uh
the testimony about how
monitor
thank you continuous glucose monitor
but we saw that the dog sometimes
figured it out first and
when you're cold and lonely the monitor
doesn't do anything for you but that dog
is your friend
should someone make a motion first
oh probably a good idea who would like
to make a
motion of otp anybody
representatively
on
i i'd like to move that ought to pass on
house bill
13 20 13 27 need to keep my paper
straight and do we have a second from
over here representative shapiro
or not representative woods
i heartily support this i
uh very familiar with the uh dogs in
this particular setting and their
ability to do that
uh i inadvertently just mentioned it to
my daughter who is an em
not at the moment was an emt for about
12 years
um and she was very familiar with this
by virtue of meeting people they picked
up with diabetes and they said that they
work well
and to that point when i ask
can the dog actually do a better job
because
glucose monitor
gets you at a high level a dog is at a
lower level and it's the lower the
consistent lower glucose level that are
just above the abnormal that cause the
consistent level of damage in diabetes
one yeah the
the retinopathy the neuropathy and all
the other organ changes that we know
occur with because it's a microvascular
disease
and the small vessels get damaged
regardless of where they are
and it's that constant level just above
the normal
that creates the issue
which the the
dog can detect whereas the
the continuous monitors are can't do so
i'm i'm very much in favor of this
anyone else
i'll speak if i may
when i was on wall street i worked with
the continuous glucose monitor companies
and one of their biggest challenges was
figuring out how to deal with lows
they you heard how some of them went
blind to the noise because they got the
alarms too long too often and if you
miss a low alarm and nobody else is
there you're dead
and the insulin pumps don't do anything
they don't they can only bring your
blood sugar down they haven't figured
out how to put the one that brings your
blood sugar up into the pumps yet
so
they're not only trying to get the low
side correct but they're also trying to
catch the speed of decline and they
the sensors just aren't good enough for
that yet but these dogs are little
miracles that are a companion that fill
in exactly where the cgm's are weak and
that allows the
the person to then try and aim for a
better therapeutic range because they're
not as worried about those lows because
you want to stay as close to normal as
possible you don't want to be 20 points
higher just to avoid that low i think
that this is i'm so lucky i'm so happy
the clerk please call the role house
bill 1327 including diabetes in the
conditions listed for eligibility for a
service animal moved by representative
leon and seconded by representative
shapiro representative leon
yes representative mcmahon yes
representative acton
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes
cofoul delemus weber absent
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative uh soloway
absent representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant absent representative pearson
yes
any objection to consent eighteen to
zero that dog will bite you if so
you start seventeen eighteen to zero
eighteen i was eighteen i don't think so
okay good thank you aren't you glad you
stayed um that ends the exec session on
13 27 i open the exact session on 1507.
[Music]
requiring child care we heard this on
the 11th if you are filing them by dates
requiring child care investigatory
findings to be published
i'd like to move that we uh
uh ought to pass this piece of
legislation please
sir
a point of order i had contacted you
that we had not resolved some issues on
this
yes sir you did yes because there was
the the person who
um from the department said it needs to
be 21 business days it was just as
simple leaving out a word it's business
days and line 10 but it's not in line
eight
and i also
brought up the question across
referencing so a person can't just
rebrand
and open up a new facility and then have
no record and she thought that was
intriguing and wanted to see if they
could do it so we still have some work
to do on this one i'm afraid the chair
did not accept your motion good though
it was so
[Music]
it has not been moved or seconded so
now before
i would like and the
representative
webber agrees to look at 1634
relative to state grants for researching
the effects on the human body of covet
19. are we good to go on that everybody
yeah we heard this on 11 representative
greeson
sole sponsor he wanted to get a study
going
and we had a lot of trouble with it
before i plow in and make a mistake uh
i don't think we put together any kind
of an amendment thing i think we all
just did what you're doing
so so
we can go with this one
uh i'm saying generally
yeah
okay so there's no pending amendments or
anything that i have forgotten all right
good
open the hearing on 1634 fna relative to
state grants for researching the effects
do i have somebody to
uh move
itl
moves ito
and we have a second representative king
thank you
i spoke representative woods
i i'm
adamantly against this one for i'm
adamantly against
you know i've this bill i want to itl
i'm sorry that's i did i get it that
right
um
looking at this bill from a number of
perspectives one of which was this the
grant application uh
my brother-in-law is a
he's an md he does a bone marrow
transplant but he's also a researcher
he's also a reviewer for nih and so i
went with him in detail over this grant
process
uh and how it occurs at nih and i'll
just be very i won't go
i'll spare the gory details but this
process is not
would not fly well
and would not end up
giving us the result we want
both in terms of the quality and the
timing and what's required
representative canarch and i would add
to that that the dhhs does not have the
expertise they confirmed they would need
to outsource that as well that is not
listed in the fiscal note we would
likely end up chewing up all of the
potential funding in the administrative
aspects of trying to do such a program
and it's already being done at a much
higher level and i think that we should
let the higher level continue thank
you representative leon
leon yes i try to make it nobody speaks
french anymore yes
lay on the table perfect
thank you i i i looked uh i had spoken
with some people involved in clinical
trial design and it would have taken
more money and it would have been the
two years so it was not structured the
right way even if we were asking the
right questions
but
but well designed the right way maybe
something like this in the future but
this is not designed at all the right
way so i'm ito
representative woods just to add to your
comment i've i nosed around a little bit
in the literature the work is already
being done yeah yeah we heard that my
wife quoted some studies here thank you
and i spoke with the
prime and soul sponsor on this and kind
of relayed in a soft way
our hatred of his bill
and uh
and told him we'd write him a very
appreciate one of you would write a very
appreciative blurb commending him for
his concern and all of those wonderful
things
you know let him down slow here okay and
he's he's amenable to that he knew it
was coming he's a minister he's a nice
guy
thank you grayson
representative full of grace yes
all right
anybody else
good when the uh is ready
she is ready you may call the roll on
house bill 1634-fn-a
relative to state grants for researching
the effects on the human body of
covet-19 vaccines moved by
representative nutter upham seconded by
oh yeah
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative acton representative gay
yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
co fault delemus weber absent
representative mckay representative snow
yes representative knurk yes
representative soloway absent
representative cannon yeah
okay
this really is just water
i want you to know this really is just
water
um uh representative shapiro
yes
representative woods yes
representative pearson yes and now
that's sixteen to one or sixteen and
zero with five absences
maybe she needs something in that yeah
you may be better for that
i know what i put in my water
uh representative
nutter
would you write the blurb please
sure a consent calendar consent
yes of course
now before we uh this ends the executive
session on 1634-f
n-8 now
the bill we heard a minute ago
representative klein knight brought us
two bills we put together a
work group to fix the first one
uh what about the one we just heard i'm
not i'm just looking for nods or
have
we have one mind or do we want to take
her
bill remember this is the one that
right yeah
so
if i could have an informal
um
i itl is that
yeah we got some representative kanark
you had your hand up
well yeah just the old line we do
tune-ups not total rebuilds and this is
going to be a complete rebuild we will
get much more out of supporting sb 277
and i think we still should ask them to
fast track it so we can get it through
the house the senate the house and the
governor before may 31st we're going to
get a hell of a lot more
backing back out of that we're going to
get two years and then we can figure out
how to he'll deal with a long-standing
mental health emergency after that tell
me the senate number again 277 sb 277
that is the current one that except two
seven seven that is the one that extends
it for two years till 2024 and has
already passed out of commerce in the
sorry finance and senate six to zero and
has nearly every senator um
let me see what i can do
uh 14.05
and could i have a motion
you have to open the executive period
i'm opening this thank you hearing for
allowing out of state mental health care
providers to provide telehealth
treatment during a medical health
emergency
and the chair would entertain an ito
motion
i will all right my first
nurse
okay
representative
that means i have to write this
somebody from over the side of the
specifically you know i'm looking at it
all right thank you representative
it's been moved and seconded on house
bill 1405
representative folsom moves
representative cannon seconds allowing
out of state mental health care
providers to provide telehealth
treatment during a mental health
emergency the motion is itl clerk please
call the roll
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king yes co fault delemus weber absent
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative salloway absent
representative cannon yes representative
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant absent representative pearson
yes
16-0
any objection to consent good
and representative folsom
yeah i get the blurb
well i do apologize i sort of keep you
to five it's five minutes to five but
we're done so this ends the hearing on
1405. i'll see you all tomorrow morning
that way sure sure we can still we have
one more to do 13.90 the telehealth
translation i've got the amendment i
told you earlier i've got everything
ready to go on that
anybody want to help this gentleman out
the doctor go for it uh
sure
[Music]
shall i move the amendment and then
speak to it sir well no not just quite
what yeah number one what's the number
again 1390 one two three nine zero all
right i got it now
and actually probably a good idea to
read it first
the amendment
yes well i can also guide people through
it
i mean
just to set the background i can explain
what it's what it's about
i opened the executive session on house
an act relative to access to language
our new friend representative murray who
is here much of today
representative canuck would you speak to
your amendment please and what it does
yes sir um basically as you may recall
we sort of all agreed with that it
sounded reasonable but it's in the wrong
place statutorily
the statute that it was placed into is
the licensed special licensed facilities
special healthcare service licenses
those are places that do radiation
therapy and some other things like that
it doesn't cover hospitals and all that
kind of stuff that we really wanted to
have covered so i worked with john
williams to get the appropriate
localization for this
and so that the tele sorry the
the statute that was placed in was 151
to f
the one it should be in
and there are two paragraphs here
is
415j3
that is the telemedicine statute that
covers insurers including managed care
and the other one that's that's section
one section two
does the medicaid coverage of telehealth
services and that's 1674-d
both of those are ones where they are
statutes about telemedicine that's their
topic it covers then
all of the
facilities and providers
but again the only people are required
to this are the ones that are required
federally to provide translational
services
then they would be required to provide
those services
for people using telemedicine so the
idea is since it has to do with
telemedicine put it with telemedicine
and we wanted to re to actually be
talking about the appropriate facilities
not just these special licenses so
that's all it does is it changes where
it hangs out
i have a question and by the way let me
just clarify so
sir for example in the original bill
section five the bold
um
that that is what that is incorporated
because this these are new
paragraphs that's why they're not bold
in the amendment
so that language about if they're
required to ensure access to limited
english proficient speakers under blah
blah blah you'll notice that that is
repetitive between lines five through
eight and lines eleven through fourteen
um
and uh again it just finishes with the
last part of either line eight or line
fourteen in person or utilizing
telemedicine so the reason it's not
bolded in the amendment is because there
are new
uh
sections
in
415 j3
and
n1674d
representative cushman did you have a
question
yes i'm just
double triple checking clarification yes
so i believe
that this is saying that
uh facilities that are already required
to have this technology
um for in-person
are now required to use it or not
technology but service are required to
use it for telehealth services
and
section two is
just
ensuring that those required by the
federal government to provide medicaid
coverage
it's being written into state statute
also
yes because basically what it does is
it's putting it into the statutes for
telemedicine in the
insured
population and in the medicaid
population and we don't of course
control the medicare population that's
not ours
so basically john
john williams just guided us as to where
the better placement would be that's all
thank you john williams oh he's here oh
i didn't even realize he was still here
he's always here yes
we can ask him if there's anything else
wind extra copy there should be an extra
he said it was perfect too wow
representative canaric would you uh
propose a motion uh yes sir i will
propose the motion that we
uh i move amendment number two oh two
two zero two one zero h
to house bill 1390
and which way do you move it
oh
well no the for the amendment i'm moving
the amendment to pass i'm good yeah well
all right just you can't i tell an
[Music]
yes
um dr cushman please
you're never going to live
nurse
um
so
i guess i'm just a bit confused of why
it's necessary if it's already required
by the federal law
oh
claire you know it's the what it is is
we didn't want to make it that
absolutely everybody had to provide
all these services it's only that if
the facility is required under the 45
cfr section blah blah blah blah blah to
provide these services then they shall
also do it if it's in telemedicine in
other words if they are are not required
to provide
the translational access anyway
then they would not be required to
provide it for telemedicine either it's
just to keep it consistent so we're not
asking the
people who are not required to do it in
person would now suddenly be required to
is there an insurance mandate in here
well that is what these both are these
are both in the insurance
that's why it's in the telemedicine uh
in the
for the insured and telemedicine for the
medicaid so it is telling them that they
representative shapiro
i'm not positive of this but from my
experience with providing
interpreters in the mental health center
where i worked it wasn't the insurance
that was mandated to pay for it it was
the
it was the service provider services
so in that case it's
a mandate on the
facilities
okay but they already provide these
services anyway because they're required
to okay thank you good thank you thank
you for your tenacity appreciate that no
i do appreciate that
at five o'clock in the afternoon thank
you so much
would the clerk please call the roll on
representative leon yes representative
mcmahon yes representative acton
representative gay yes representative
cushman yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king
co-fault dele miss weber absent
representative mckay
representative snow
representative knurk yes
representative salloway absent
representative cannon yeah
representative nutter upham
representative shapiro yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant absent representative pearson
yes
16 to 0 5x
now
except a motion for otp a
on house bill 1390 is amended by
2022-2022
representative knurk your co-sponsor you
get the honors oh am i
oh yeah you are sorry i forgot um yes i
would move please uh ought to pass
house bill one three nine zero
with amendment zero two one zero h
um and actually while i have the four i
would like to apologize representative
cushman for answering too quickly and
being incorrect it it doesn't say that
it's an insurance mandate that was my
error it says the facility is required
to provide it so it's a service
service mandate not an insurance mandate
my apologies
representative acton you lost by a thumb
last time would you like to second this
all right
yay
i had that job you know
yeah
that's right
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative acton representative gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king
co fault delemus weber absent
representative mckay
representative snow yes representative
knurk yes representative soloway absent
representative cannon yes representative
nutter upham
representative shapiro
representative woods yes representative
merchant absent
representative pearson yes
16 to 05 absence any objection to
consent thank you
and this ends the
exec session on house bill 1390 and let
the record show i owe all committee
mr
uh we have a request from the audience
stephen pearson
how old are you did he already forget
he already
he said 43.
i do this all the time remember those
four years
you wondered where i was
that's it
representative canark would you write
the bill of course the blurb
yes sir you've already yeah thank you
okay
yes
yes they already did send out uh
lindsay sent out the schedule for 31st
we better get out there quickly before
everybody